PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVEACCESS. TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH ONE OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
ARE MEMBER INTENDING REMOTELY
TODAY IS SENATOR STERN. AND WE
OFTEN IF YOU HAVE A STAFF
PERSON WITH YOU TO ADDED THEN
FIND OUT STAFF FOR NOW SENATOR
STERN. ARE YOU WITH US. HE'S
NOT THERE YET OKAY WE'LL MOVE
ON. ARE THERE FOR THE REMOTE OF
THE SENATE ARE PLEASED NEW TWO
YEAR FOR ARE CA. THIS WILL GROW
AID IN LIMON ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
USE THAT RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO I NEED. PLEASE SELECT A
NEEDS BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING
R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON YOU WHEN YOU ARE DONE
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOWING WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW TWO DAYS PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TO
AN ACCESS CODE IS. TWO SIX NINE
SEVEN NINE ONE FOUR LET ME
REPEAT THAT THE NUMBER IS.
877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO SIX NINE SEVEN
NINE ONE FOUR. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE IN OR THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND.
OPPOSITION PLEASE. PRESS THE
ONLY ONE OPERATOR LOOKS LIKE
THE IS PUT IT'S NOT. YES THAT'S
ONE RECEIVED LINE YOU WILL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATE
TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT
THAT TIME YOU WILL BE MUTE IN
IN YOUR NOW READY TO THE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST NEED
TO THE DEVICE YOU WATCHING. THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
AND HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS
MUTED WELL EVER EVERY EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL BE PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
WE HAVE A- BILLS ONTO. AGENDA
IN ONE BILL ON THE CONSENSUS
CALENDAR. ALSO PLEASE NOTE THAT
S. B. FOR TWELVE AND SB SIX
EIGHTY THREE. HAVE BEEN
POSTPONED FOR HEARING BY THE
AUTHOR. SO WE HEAR PRESENTATION
ON EIGHT BILLS IN ORDER TO GET
THROUGH TODAY'S CALENDAR IN OUR
ALLOTTED HEARING TIME. SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION WILL BE LIMITED
TO TEN MINUTES EACH WHICH
INCLUDES THREE MINUTES FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. AND
WILL BE LIMITED TO TEN MINUTES
EACH WHICH INCLUDES THREE
MINUTES FOR LEAD WITNESS
TESTIMONY. AND THE REMAINDER OF
THE TIME FOR ADDITIONAL CALLERS
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
BEFORE WE PRESENTATION ON THE
BILLS WE NEED TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. STERN IS SENATOR STERN
PRESENT. NOT PRESENTLY OUT SO
WE ARE STILL WAITING FOR. A FEW
MORE MEMBERS TO COME.
IN ORDER.
IN ORDER TO BEGIN EVEN THOUGH
WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM WE'RE
GOING TO START MOVING THE
AGENDA AND OUR FIRST BILL IS SB
THIRTY SEVEN SENATOR CORTESE IS
PRESENT. A GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR IN IN
SENATORS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR. PLEASE PERCENT SB THIRTY
SO A BILL THAT SAFEGUARDS
PUBLIC HEALTH BY PROHIBITING
THE USE OF COMMONSENSE.
EXEMPTIONS FOR PROJECTS LOCATED
ON THE CORTEZ YOU LIST SITES.
THAT LIST WAS ORIGINALLY
CREATED IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES BY LEGISLATION CARRIED
BY MY FATHER FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOMINIC CORTESE.
IT'S A LIST OF CONTAMINATED
SITES COMPILED BY VARIOUS STATE
AGENCIES FOR THE PURPOSE OF
PROVIDING INFORMATION ABOUT THE
LOCATION OF HAZARDOUS MATERIALS-
IN THE RELEASES OF THOSE HOUSE
MATURE BECAUSE THIS MATERIAL SO
ON THOSE SITES- GOING TO GIVE
THAT INFORMATION TO PUBLIC
LOCAL PLENTY AGENCIES. STATE
LAW. CURRENTLY PROHIBITS
CATEGORICAL EXEMPTIONS. FROM
BEING GRANTED TO PROJECTS
IMPACTING SITES LISTED ON THE
LIST BECAUSE OF CONTAMINATION
ON THE SITE POSES SIGNIFICANT
RISKS TO THE ENVIRONMENT. LOCAL
AGENCIES IN SOME CASES HAVE
SKIRTED THIS LAW. BY GRANTING
EXEMPTIONS PURSUANT TO QUOTE
UNQUOTE COMMONSENSE. ALONG
PROJECTS TO BE CARRIED OUT
WITHOUT GOING THROUGH THE
ADEQUATE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
AND PUBLIC SCRUTINY. DOING
THESE PROJECTS WITHOUT PUBLIC
ACCOUNTABILITY INAPPROPRIATE
CLEANUP POSES SEVERE HEALTH
RISKS TO LABOUR'S WORKING ON
THE SITE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY THAT LIVE NEAR NEARBY
THE SITE. IN FUTURE TENANTS OF
THE PROPERTY IN THE CASE OF
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT. WE
CANNOT CONTINUE TO ALLOW
PROJECTS TO BY PASS IMPORTANCE
EQUAL REVIEW AND JEOPARDIZE
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKER SAFETY. S.
THIRTY SEVEN SIMPLY CLARIFIES
THE LAW CAN. THE COMMONSENSE
EXEMPTIONS CANNOT BE GRANTED
FOR PROJECTS ON THE COURTESY
LIST SITES. I WANT TO THANK
TEACHER IN COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS FOR THEIR ADVOCACY
ON THIS ISSUE IN THE DILIGENT
WORK. ON THE BILL. HERE TO TELL
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. BUT IS
JAMES THEIR WATER FROM THE
STATE COUNCIL LABORS AND
CHELSEA TO FROM THE SAN ANDREAS
POVERTY ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND- I AM HOPEFUL-
RESPECTFULLY THE FOR YOUR
RIVALS THANK YOU. PLEASE
PROCEED VEER. TO TESTIFY
AGAINST THE OF SB THREE SEVEN
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS
NEEDS TO FIRST. PLEASE SPEAK UP
I'M NOT SURE. CAN'T HEAR YOU.
MISS TO ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
MARK. BUT. MODERATOR DON'T HAVE
AN OTHERS THE WITH ANY NOW WE
CAN HEAR USE NEAR. ARE YOU. WHY
MADAM HEARING MAN. MY NAME IS
CHELSEA TO AND I AM A SENIOR
ATTORNEY BECAUSE OPERATOR
POVERTY IRON. ATTORNEY HERE HAS
WORKED MONICA COMMUNITY AND
COMMUNITIES OF AND A FUN TRIP
AND PRACTICE IN SHORT THE DATA
EIGHTEEN RIGHT AND HOW OF.
THURSDAY IS THE COMMONSENSE
EXPANSION ARE THE CRIED BY
LOCAL AGENT. I DO KNOW SHE
KALRA CHOIR. UNDER COMPONENTS
ANALYZE PUBLICLY THE AND
MANAGED CONFIRMED- AND OF THE
PROPOSED PROJECT. YOU COULD
CONTACT A SPLASH IMPORTANT
NUMBER ABOUT LOW TRUMPETED LIKE
HOME ON LANDS ARE. WITH THERE
MATERIALS. WELL TAKEN AWAY THE
PUBLIC'S ABILITY TO ENSURE THAT
MAXIMUM CLEANUP IS DONE BEFORE
A PROJECT IS APPROVED. PROJECT
PROPONENTS NEED THE CHECKS AND
BALANCES BUILT INTO THE PROCESS
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
DO NOT CAUSE IRREVERSIBLE
HEALTH IMPACTS TO THE FAMILY.
ULTIMATELY LED IN THE
DEVELOPMENT PROTECTING. NO
HOUSING SHIPPED BE BUILT ON
TOXIC PLAN. THE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST I FELT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU I NOW MISTER
THURROCK ARE YOU ON THE LINE
TEST FOR THE. MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE MISTER JAMES THURBER
WACHTER ON THE LINE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. NO RESPONSIBLE.
MAYBE THEN LET US MOVE ON OUR
MODERATOR OPEN THE LINES FOR
THOSE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY SEVEN AND
PLEASE OUR LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS
TO YOUR NAME AFFILIATION IN
YOUR POSITION ON SB. THIRTY
SEVEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR- CAN YOU GUYS HEAR ME YES.
IT IS THIS MR THROUGH WATER.
YOU CAN HAND OUT. MISTER THUR
WATER IF YOU ARE ON THE LINE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. PLEASE GO
AHEAD HELLO HELLO MR WACHTER
HELLO WE CAN HEAR YOU. WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY SORRY ABOUT THAT
NO MORE NO WORRIES AT ALL AND
WE'RE NOT THE COMMITTEE. WHAT
THAT. PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY SEVEN YEAR AND SAID
LOOKS LIKE. YES GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMING IN SORRY ABOUT THAT. MY
NAME IS JAMES DIRECTOR NUMBER
THE CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
LABOR'S. THANK GOD BANKS IN A
REPORT AB BUT LEADERSHIP ON
THIS CRITICAL AND TIMELY PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THE LABOR
REPRESENT. OVER SIXTY THOUSAND
UNION WORKERS STATEWIDE WITH A
STRONG PRESENCE IN THE HEAVY
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. TO
RETURN OUR ROADS AND HIGHWAYS
IMPLEMENTED INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
MULTI FAMILY MIXED USE PROJECT.
IF YOU BOTH ARE WORKERS AND THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES OF OUR
JOB SITES REMAINS A TOP
PRIORITY. WHEN THEY CANNOT BE
COMPROMISED. SB THIRTY SEVEN
CLOSES A LOOPHOLE IN THE SEQUEL
REVIEW PROCESS OTHERWISE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF WORKERS
AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS AT RISK.
I EXPRESSLY PROVIDING THAT ANY
PROJECT THAT INCLUDED IN THE
COURT CASE YOU LAYS. WHICH IS
CREATING DISTRIBUTING POSTED BY
THE SECRETARY FOR KELLY PH NOT
BE EXEMPT FROM SEQUEL YOU.
CURRENTLY THE ECLIPSE THIS
CURRENTLY PEOPLE PROHIBITS
CERTAIN EXEMPTIONS FOR THE
THOUSANDS OF PROPERTIES ON A
STATE WIDE ROSTER OF HAZARDOUS
WASTE BACK ON THE COURT.
CATEGORICAL EXEMPTIONS ARE ONLY
SUPPOSED TO GO TO PROJECTS WITH
NO SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT OR TO HUMAN HEALTH.
ELEVATION AIMS TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC CONSTRUCTION WORKERS IN
FUTURE OCCUPANTS FROM EXPOSURE
TO DANGEROUS SUBSTANCES.
COMMONSENSE EXEMPTION HOWEVER
HAVE BEEN EFFECTIVELY QUALITY
BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN RECENT
YEARS EVEN EXAMPLE PREVENTION
AND COURAGE FAST TRACK PROJECT
APPROVAL AND ALLOW CITY TO
AVOID STATE REVIEW. DESPITE THE
FACT THAT SUCH EXEMPTIONS ARE
TO APPLY ONLY O THOSE PROJECT
REPRESENT NO POSSIBILITY OF
SIGNIFICANT HAZARD. IF YOU HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFULLY BY
PATHOLOGICAL REVIEW TO THE
TRACKING IS. UNFORTUNATE TRUTH
HERE IS THAT SOME OF THE MOST
THREATENING HAZARDS ON A
CONSTRUCTION SITE ARE THOSE
THAT WE CANNOT READILY YOUR
BILL. SUCH HAZARDS ARE OFTEN
THE RESULT OF CONTAMINATED SOIL
AND GROUNDWATER LEAKY
UNDERGROUND TANKS WHAT THE
IMPROPER MANAGEMENT OF WASTE
MATERIALS ARE ROCK PRODUCTS
AMONG OTHERS. SB THIRTY SEVEN
INCREASE. ADDRESS IT IS
INCREASINGLY GROWING PROBLEM
WHEREBY CITIES EXEMPTS HIGHLY
CONTAMINATED SITE ENTIRELY
COMPLETELY REVIEW. THIS BILL
WOULD SIMPLY CLARIFIED THE
PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE TO
PROVIDE ALL EXEMPTIONS
INCLUDING THE COMMONSENSE
EXEMPTIONS CANNOT BE GRANTED
THE PROJECTS THEY ARE NAMED ON
A CONSOLIDATED PARTICULARS. AT
THE PROUD SPONSOR OF THE BILL
WE BELIEVE SB THIRTY SEVEN
RECRUITING A PROACTIVE APPROACH
TO PROTECTING WORKERS THANK YOU
NEED ANYTHING CREEPY PRECARIOUS
ENVIRONMENTS. WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU NOW MODERATOR DO HAVE
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY WHO
ARE ONLINE. ONE EIGHT. PLEASE
USE YOUR GARAGE SINCE EIGHTEEN
CALPERS HOMELESS YOU DON'T WE
CAN'T HEAR ANYTHING FROM YOUR
SITE ONLY THE WITNESSES.
NOTHING'S COMING ACROSS FROM
FROM THE CHAMBERS. OKAY. HI WE
ARE DEAD AIR FROM THE CHAMBERS.
LEAD WITNESS. THAT MAKES. SENSE
AND WHAT THE LEAD WITNESSES
HAVE ARE PROVIDED THEIR
COMMENTS ALREADY THE TO LEAD
WITNESSES. THIS IS JUST A FEW
MINUTES. WE'RE GOING TO RECESS
FOR A FEW MINUTES TILL- FROM
THE FIGURE OUT VIA. WITH THE
INTERRUPTION AS.
I AM SECRETARY
WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. BATES HERE AS HERE
TELLING YOUR VALUE HERE
GONZALEZ AND SALAS HERE SKINNER.
AND STERN BURKE OWSKI HERE HERE.
AND QUORUM. BECAUSE WE HAD THE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES FOR OUR
LEAD WITNESSES WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK TO THEM AND GIVE THEM
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REAP
TESTIFYING CENTER CORTESE I
THINK THAT IT'S ONLY FAIR SO WE
WILL START WITH HONEST TO OUR
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR THE LEAD WITNESS
ARMIS CARTEL C. TO. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SECRETARY OF THE WORKING
GROUP FOLLOW YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHELSEA TO AND I AM A
SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH THE CENTER
ON RACE POVERTY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT RCMP. THIRTY YEARS
EUROPEAN MARKETS WITH LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND ACROSS THE
STATE TO ENSURE THAT THESE
COMMUNITIES CAN THRIVE. IN A
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT. A HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT STARTS WITH A
HEALTHY AND SAFE HOME AS THREE
HAZARDS THAT'S WHY WE ARE PROUD
TO STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THIRTY
SECONDS. UNDER QUESTIONING
MENTIONED SB THIRTY SEVEN
VERIFY THAT PROJECTS INCLUDING
HELPING LOCATED. ON CAMERA AND
SHALL NOT BE EXEMPT FROM REVIEW
AND THE COMMONSENSE EXEMPTION.
THIS BILL NECESSARY IN ORDER TO
PREVENT FURTHER ABUSE OF THAT
EXCEPTION ANOTHER EXCEPTION BY
LOCAL AGING. IN ORDER TO BUILD
HOUSING AND OTHER PROJECTS.
HELLO SEACOR REQUIRES PROJECT
COMPONENTS TO CAREFULLY ANALYZE
PUBLISH PUBLICLY DISCLOSE AND
MITIGATE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
OF THE PROPOSED PROJECT. THE
SECRET PROJECT IT IS SPECIALLY
IMPORTANT WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT LOCATING CENTER USES LIKE
HOMES CONTAMINATED. HAZARD
MATERIAL. HOWEVER THANKSGIVING
BERMAN REVIEW AGENCIES HAVE
TAKEN AWAY FROM THE PUBLIC IN
FUTURE RESIDENTIAL CARE RIGHT
TO LEARN ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT AND HEALTH
RISKS OF DEVELOPING A
CONSEQUENCE. ACTIVISTS HAD ALSO
TAKEN AWAY THE PUBLIC'S ABILITY
TO ENSURE THAT MAXIMUM CLEANUP
IS DONE BEFORE A DEVELOPMENT IS
APPROVED. PROJECT PROPONENTS
NEED THE CHECKS AND BALANCES
BUILT INTO THE SEQUEL PROCESS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY DO NOT
COST A REIMBURSABLE HEALTH
IMPACTS TO THE FAMILIES WHO
WILL LIVE IN THESE
DEVELOPMENTS. PROTECTING NO
PROJECT ESPECIALLY HOUSING
SHOULD BE BUILT ON TOXIC LAND.
THANK GENERAL QUESTIONS THE FOR
BRING THE SPELL AND GREEN
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT SPEAKER. MISTER WALKER ARE
YOU ON THE LINE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REPEAT YOUR
TESTIMONY. FOR PLEASE ON YOU.
FOR OPERATORS MISTER THREW
WATER ON THE LINE. ONE MOMENT
PICTURE SO HE CAN REPEAT HIS
SAW TESTIMONY. YES GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE.
JAMES DIRECTOR HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL LABORS
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO- PROVIDE MY
TESTIMONY I LIKE TO THANK AND
COMMEND SENATOR CORTESE PARTLY
TO SHIP ON THIS CRITICAL AND
TIMELY PIECE OF LEGISLATION-
THE WAIVERS REPRESENT OVER
SIXTY THOUSAND UNION WORKERS
STATE WHY DO WE HAVE A STRONG
PRESENCE IN THE HEAVY
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. I'M TURN
OUR WORLD OUR ROADS AND
HIGHWAYS IMPLEMENTING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR MULTI FAMILY
AND MIXED USE PROJECTS. THANK
YOU BOTH OUR WORKERS IN THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES. OF OUR
JOB SITES REMAINS A TOP
PRIORITY A PRIORITY THAT CANNOT
BE COMPROMISED. SB THIRTY SEVEN
HOLDS A LOOPHOLE IN THE SEAPORT
REVIEW PROCESS THAT OTHERWISE
PLACE TO THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF WORKERS AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AT RISK. BY EXPRESSLY
PROVIDING THAT ANY PROJECT THAT
IS INCLUDED IN THE CORTESE
LIST. WHICH IS CREATED
DISTRIBUTED AND POSTED BY THE
SECRETARY TO CALIBRATE SHALL
NOT BE EXEMPT FROM SEQUEL
REVIEW. CURRENTLY KEYCORP
PROHIBITS CERTAIN EXEMPTIONS
FOR THE THOUSANDS PROPERTIES ON
A STATE WIDE ROSTER OF HAVE A
HAZARDOUS WASTE SITE CALLED THE
CORTESE WITH. CATEGORICAL
EXEMPTIONS ARE THE ARE ONLY
SUPPOSED TO GO TO PROJECTS WITH
NO SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT OR TO HUMAN HEALTH.
THE PROHIBITION AIMS TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC. CAN WORKERS THANK
YOU TO OCCUPANTS FROM EXPOSURE
TO DANGEROUS SUBSTANCES SHE
COMMONSENSE EXEMPTION HOWEVER
HAVE BEEN EFFECTIVELY EXPLOITED
BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN RECENT
YEARS. EXEMPTION COURAGE FAST
TRACK PROJECT APPROVAL AND
ALLOW CITY TO AVOID STATE
REVIEW. DESPITE THE FACT THAT
SUCH EXEMPTIONS ARE TO APPLY
ONLY TO THOSE PROJECTS THAT
PRESENT NO POSSIBILITY OF
SIGNIFICANT HAZARDS. IF YOU
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFULLY
BYPASSING THEORY VIEW THROUGH
THIS MECHANISM. HE FORTUNATE TO
HEAR THAT MOST OF THE THREATEN
HAZARDS ON A CONSTRUCTION SITE
ARE THOSE THAT WE CANNOT
READILY SEE OR FEEL. LIKE HAS A
DROP IN THE RESULT OF
CONTAMINATED SOIL AND
GROUNDWATER LEAKING UNDERGROUND
TANKS BUT THE IMPROPER
MANAGEMENT OF WASTE MATERIALS
ARE ROCK PRODUCTS AMONG OTHER
THINGS. THREE THIRTY. DISAGREED
I DON'T GOING. TO THIS IS THAT
WATER WE ARE HERE AT YOUR LIMIT
AND WE HAVE A SEVERAL THAT WANT
TO TESTIFIED THAT THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEARING WITH US WITH. OUR
TECHNICAL DEAL DIFFICULT. AND
YOUR COMMENTS ARE ON THE
RECORD. I NOW WILL LOOK TO
ANYONE IAN NO THIS ROOM THAT
WAS USED TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTY SEVEN. I SEE NO
ONE APPROACHING THE STAND WILL
GO TO ROOM TWENTY. FORTY AND I
DON'T SEE ANYONE IN TWENTY
FORTY SO WE WILL. GO GO TO
THOSE WHO ARE OTHERS WHO MAY BE
ON THE TELECONFERENCE LINE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF SB THIRTY SEVEN
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE ARE
AWAITING. OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT WE DO THANK
YOU. YES WE DO THANK YOU TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT TO TESTIFY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOR OUR ONE
FILED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT AND WE'LL GO DO
OUTLINED FORTY FOUR MADAM CHAIR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PINE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE ON MUTE. THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN COURT. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MATT KREMIN SHALL BE
HAPPY CALIFORNIA THAT A
COOPERATIVE OPERATING ENGINEERS
WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND AGAIN WE SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS THANK YOU TO
CRAPPIE BUT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU HAVE WE
HAVE NO OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT LET US GO TO
THOSE WHO MIGHT BE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE I DO NOT
SEE ANY LEAD WITNESS LIFTED OFF
ON THE OPPOSITION SO LET'S GO
TO- THE THOSE IN. ROOM. FORTY
TWO OH THREE I CAPPING NUMBERS
ON GROUSE GROCERY ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTY SEVEN
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
DO NOT SEE ANYONE ON A ONE MAN
TWENTY FORTY SO LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
THIRTY SEVEN. THE TOUCHED BY AN
OPPOSITION SB THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. MADAM CHAIR NO
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUING UP.
THANK YOU MODERATOR THAT'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY COMMENTS OFF FINISH ONE
TASK- MADAM CHAIR I WILL- LIKE
TO MOVE THE BILL I HEARD
SOMETHING STERN TESTIMONY I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SEQUEL WHO PREVIEW. YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE- EXPERTS
TESTIFIED THAT WILL HAVE THE
MAXIMUM CLEAN UP POSSIBLE ON
EACH SIDE IN THAT NO PROJECT
GOES FORWARD ON A TAX ON
FORMALLY TOXIC SITES AND WE
KNOW THERE'S DIFFERENT LEVELS
THE SEQUEL IF YOU JUST ALLOW
IDENTIFIES WHAT THE- DIRECT AND
INDIRECT PROCESSES DEPENDING
WHAT THE USES OF ITS SECOND.
INDUSTRIAL USE IT'S NOT CLEAN
TO THE SAME GRADE AS HOUSING
AND IN ONE. OF THE PUBLIC TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AND THE
SAME ON THE OTHER WITNESS ABOUT
THE RISK OF WORKERS ON THE JOB
SITE THAT'S NOT INCLUDED IN THE
SEEK REVIEW THAT'S AN OSHA
WANTS TO REVIEW HAS BEEN GONE
AND IDENTIFIED WHAT. THE YOU
KNOW SO A CHILL LOGICAL IN SOIL
THINGS ARE SO WITH THAT I WILL
MOVE- THE MEASURE AND THE HAVE.
REMEMBER BEING LOST WHEN YOUR
DAD PASSED THIS BILL SO.
FINISHER DOLLY. THANK YOU THERE
ARE CHAIR SO- I LIKE YOUR BILL
BUT I DO HAVE A COKE I DO HAVE
A QUESTION THAT THE COMMONSENSE
RULE I ACTUALLY CAME IN IT WAS
A CASE OF VISOR FOR A LONG TIME
AND WE HAD. THE OPPORTUNITY USE
THIS TO WHAT WE HAVE IN MANY
THE RULE CARRIES ALMOST TALK
ABOUT THE REALLY SMALL COUNTIES
ARE TRYING TO CLEAN UP- TELESIS
CITY UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANKS
I KNOW THERE'S A- POT OF MONEY
THAT. IS AVAILABLE FOR THAT FOR
EVEN THOSE PROPERTIES THAT.
NOBODY OWNS BASICALLY THEY'VE
THEY'VE BEEN PUT IN THE SYSTEM
FOR A LONG TIME AND WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO CLEAN THOSE UP AND SO
THAT. THE BILL THE ORIGINAL
BILL WAS TO ALLOW THAT COMMON
SENSE TO SAY HEY. YOU KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO DO THE WORK FOR
THE COST OF. WE HAVE NOT HAVE
TO DO SO MUCH ENVIRONMENTAL
WORK ACTUALLY GETS MORE WORK
DONE AND THAT WAS THE REASON
THAT THERE WAS A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO IT RIGHT THAT KATE.
WOULD NOT DISPENSED MUCH MONEY
ON TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S
GOING ON WE CAN JUST GO CLEAN
IT UP. SO IS THERE IS THERE. I
WOULD I WOULD READ THROUGH
EVERYTHING I HAD AVAILABLE TO
ME- I'M ASSUMING A LOT OF THOSE
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN OUT OF THE
WAY NOW AND WE'VE DONE. A LOT
OF WORK ON THOSE OVER THE YEARS
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN. SOMETIME IS
THERE IS A TWO SIX ON LIKE HOW
MUCH IS LEFT OUT THERE THAT WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT PRETTY MUCH
MOST COUNTIES KNOW WHERE THEY
HAVE BROWN FIELDS. WHERE THEY
HAVE. YOU KNOW THERE WAS SOME
BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT NOW THE
LAWS CHANGE AND IT'S BECAME
TOXIC THAT THEY WERE AWARE
BEFORE SO DO YOU HAVE ANY
INFORMATION ON THAT BECAUSE- I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT. LEAVING SITES THAT WE
COULD GO CLEAN UP. IN THERE WAS
THAT COST DIFFERENTIAL IN THEIR.
THANK YOU FOR. NOT SURE WHERE
WE GO THANK YOU THOSE ARE
EXCELLENT POINTS THE- THE
ORIGINAL BILL. WAS REALLY SET
OUT TO IDENTIFY SOMETHING HAD
NEVER BEEN IDENTIFIED BEFORE
WHICH IS WHERE OUR THEIR
UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANKS THAT
MAY OR MAY NOT BE LEAKING TO
STE WHERE ARE THEY- SUPPOSED TO
THE NEED TO BE. MAPPED AND
IDENTIFIED THUS THE NAME LIST
OR THE TURN LIST RIGHTS OF THIS
LISTING WHAT'S THE LISTING CAME
OF COURSE- THEN THE WHOLE
INDUSTRY DEVELOPED IN- STATE
FUNDING. CAME ABOUT TO ASSIST
IN CLEANING UP ANY OF THOSE AT
IN FACT HAD BEEN LEAKING- THAT
PROCESS GOES ON I DON'T KNOW
PRECISELY HOW MANY REMAIN HOW
MANY HAVE BEEN CLOSE OVER THE
YEARS BUT OBVIOUSLY NOT A GOOD
WORK HAS BEEN DONE. HOW MANY
WOULD REMAIN OPEN TO THIS DAY
WE WOULD PROBABLY DEPEND PART
ON HOW HOW RECENTLY THEY WERE
DISCOVERED IN ADDED TO THE
LIST- THAT SAID- THE ISSUE ERE
IS THAT IT'S SORT OF A- IT'S
SORT OF A- THERE'S LESS.
LOOPHOLE IF YOU WILL I'M NOT
SURE IF YOU KNOW IT IT'S AT ALL
OF FAIR LOOPHOLE BUT- WHERE-
THE COMMONSENSE EXEMPTION WHICH
REALLY ISN'T ABOUT COMMON SENSE
IN THE LATE LAYPERSON'S TERMS
ABOUT TO TELL THEM APART THAT
SAYS WHEN THERE'S NO FURTHER
POSSIBILITY. OF IN THIS CASE
CONTAMINATION THEN GO AHEAD AND
CLOSE AT A LOCAL AGENCY CAN
CLOSE IT- THAT IS
EXTRAORDINARILY- IN
CONTRADICTION. TO DTS SEE
SITTING ON THAT SITE ST THERE
STILL IS. HAZARDOUS WASTE ON
THE SITE THAT'S WHY WE HAVEN'T
CLOSED SO IF THE TNC IS SAYING
WE HAVE NOTYET- DEAN THIS.
SITE READY FOR CLOSURE BECAUSE
OF THE HAZARDOUS MATERIALS
UNDERGROUND. BUT A LOCAL AGENCY
SHOULD BE COMING ALONG.
OVERRIDING ON THE BASIS THAT
THERE'S NO POSSIBILITY THAT
THERE'S HAZARDOUS MATERIALS SO.
THIS IS JUST TRYING TO. STOP
THAT FROM HAPPENING DOES A
REMOTE REQUIRE OF COURSE THAT
IS A FULL ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
REPORT BE DONE THAT'S AS WE ALL
KNOW FROM OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
DAYS- AND A SIMPLE NEGATIVE
DECLARATION COULD. COULD BE
USED BUT AT LEAST YOU STILL
HAVE YOU THEN HELP THE PUBLIC
HEARING PROCESS PEOPLE WERE
NOTIFIED ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO
SUPPORT COULD TESTIFY. THIS
THIS COMMONSENSE EXEMPTION IS
ESSENTIALLY HE BATES ALL OF
THAT THERE'S NO PUBLIC INPUT
THERE'S NO PUBLIC PROCESS IT IS
THE DETERMINATION. SO WE'RE
TRYING TO STOP THAT FROM
HAPPENING I DO THINK IN THE
FUTURE- SO LEGISLATION PROBABLY
SHOULD BE BROUGHT TO TRY TO
EXPEDITE THE CLOSURE OF THOSE
SITES THAT HAVE BEEN HANGING
AROUND. THAT ARE AS CLEAN AS
ARE GOING TO GET- A ADDITION BE.
BY. I AM TRYING TO GET A NICE
WAY TO SAY APPLE PIE. MESSING
WITH- THE- THE PROCESS IN A
BACK HANDED WAY IT SHOULD BE
DONE BY LEGISLATING PERHAPS
WHAT THE NEW STANDARDS ARE IN
TERMS OF CLOSURE. THIS BILL
DOESN'T ATTEMPT TO DO THAT STEP
ONE IS CLOSE A LOOPHOLE. WELL I
PURSUED THAT AND I WILL I'M
GONNA SUPPORT YOUR BILL I THINK
YOU'RE TRYING TO GO IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION I JUST DON'T
WANT TO. GET THAT CATCH TWENTY
TWO WHERE YOU HAVE AND IT'S NOT
JUST UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANKS
ITS INDUSTRIAL BRETT WE HAVE. A
LOT IN THE RULERS WE HAVE YOU
KNOW OLD LUMBER MILL SITES THAT
NOBODY AND BASICALLY THEY JUST
WALKED AWAY FROM A LONG LONG
TIME AGO AND THEN THE COUNTY
STOCK BUT TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
A CAN WE REPURPOSE AS WHAT CAN
WE DO WITH IT. AND SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T. WE
DON'T. PUSH THEM OUT WE'RE
TRYING TO GET THEIR NAME BUT I
ALSO DON'T WANT. WE KNOW WHAT'S
THERE. I MEAN AND WE WHEN WE
ALSO THE THING IS WE MAJOR. IN
PARTS PER BILLION AND WE USED
TO DO PARTS PER MILLION SO USE.
IT THOSE THOSE THINGS THOSE
LITTLE NUMBERS MAKE UP A LOT OF
DIFFERENCES WHEN YOU'RE TRYING
TO GET A SITE. BACK INTO USE OR
MAYBE MAYBE SOME OF THOSE
PROPERTIES ARE PRIME PROPERTIES
BUT THEY JUST HAVE. SOME OF
THOSE ARE SO I'M I'M I'M- I'M-
THE BILL COMING FORWARD. A AND
I JUST WANT TO HOPE THAT YOU
KNOW IT ACTUALLY DOES WHAT WE
WANT TO DO NOT- PUT IT WHERE WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO GET SOMETHING
DONE WHERE SHOULD MAKE SENSE
OF. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. THE ANNOUNCED
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL
THE ROLL I'M SORRY SENATOR
CORTESE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
IT ALMOST SOUNDED LIKE A CLOSE
BUT DO A FORMAL ONE YES IT I
JUST WANT TO THANK- AGAIN THANK
YOU FROM THE CHAIR THANK THE
COMMITTEE- THANK YOU FOR THE
GOOD QUESTIONS- IT'LL BE MORE
WORK TO DO AFTER WE CLOSE A
SIMPLE AND I'M COMMITTED TO
BEING PART OF THE SOLUTION ON
THAT THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THE BILL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB THIRTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR CORTESE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALAN BATES HI H.
I. DALLI DALLI I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HI SKINNER. STERN TURN
ON KERN HIGH MAKOWSKI LCI.
THERE ARE TWO BILL HOUSE FIVE
VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN-
FOR THE LATE COMERS. THANK YOU
AND NOW YOU CAN MOVE TO YOUR
NEXT FIELD SENATOR PURCHASING
WHICH IS SB FOUR SEVENTY FIVE.
JULY TWO BEGAN. YES THANK YOU
AGAIN- MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS
SP FOUR SEVENTY FIVE WOULD
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD CARD TO ADOPT
NEW GUIDELINES FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGIES. TO
IDENTIFY NEAR TERM BEST
PRACTICES FOR REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
PROVIDE GUIDANCE FOR HOW TO
INTEGRATE CLIMATE RESILIENCE
AND SOCIAL EQUITY IN THE PLANS.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE-
NPOS MATCH POINT PLAYING
ORGANIZATIONS IN EACH REGION TO
IDENTIFY IMPLEMENTATION ACTIONS
TO ACHIEVE NEAR TERM GHG
REDUCTIONS TARGETS SET BY CARB.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE US THE
STEINBERG BILL AIM TO REDUCE
GHG EMISSIONS FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. BY
REQUIRING THE SAME REGIONAL
NPOS ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO ADOPT
LAND USE STRATEGIES AND
PRIORITIZE TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS THAT REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES IN LONG RANGE
PLANS KNOWN AS SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGIES SCS FOR
SHORT. THE HOPE OF SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE OR SEVENTY BY
REQUIRING NPOS TO DOT PLANS THE
CHIEF LONG TERM GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION GOALS DIFFERENT LAND
USE AND TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENT DECISIONS WOULD
ULTIMATELY BE MADE RESULTING IN
CHANGES. IN TRAVEL BEHAVIOR
THAT WOULD DRIVE DOWN EMISSIONS
PARTICULARLY FROM TAIL PIPES
FROM PASSENGER VEHICLES
ESPECIALLY. UNFORTUNATELY
CHANGES IN LAND USE CONTROL
BEHAVIOR HAVE NOT OCCURRED AS
QUICKLY AS MANY HOPED THE
GREATEST A GREATER FOCUS ON
NEAR TERM ACTION IS NEEDED.
ADDITIONALLY SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE SINGLE FOCUS ON GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION CREATES
CHALLENGES FOR LOCAL REGIONAL
AGENCY SEEKING TO MAKE PROGRESS
ON OTHER IMPORTANT STATE GOALS
SUCH AS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CLIMATE RESILIENCE. CREATING
TENSION WITH OTHER STATE LAWS.
THE REALITY IS THE TYPES OF
LAND USE POLICIES THAT MIGHT BE
CRITICAL TO PROTECTING THE
COMMUNITY FROM CLIMATE RISK.
AVOIDING ECONOMIC DISPLACEMENT
ARE NOT ALWAYS ALIGNED WITH
THOSE OF MINIMIZE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS STATE LAW NEEDS
TO PROVIDE GREATER GUIDANCE AS
TO. HOW A REGIONAL MATCH PALM
PRINT PLANNING ORGANIZATION
SHOULD APPROACH THESE DIFFICULT
TRADE OFFS AND IDENTIFY WIN WIN
SOLUTIONS. SB FOUR SEVENTY FIVE
WOULD REQUIRE CARP TO FORM A
STATE REGIONAL COLLABORATIVE
FOR CLIMATE EQUITY AND
RESILIENCE. TO IDENTIFY BEST
PRACTICES AND QUANTIFY THE
CLIENT BENEFITS OF COMMON
STRATEGIES TO ACHIEVE LONG
RANGE GHG REDUCTION TARGETS AND
RECOMMEND GUIDOLIN GUIDELINES
FOR NPOS. TO INTEGRATE STATE
GOALS RELATED TO CLIMATE
RESILIENCE AND SOCIAL EQUITY
INTO THEIR S. YES.THIS BILL
ALSO REQUIRES THE STATE ENERGY
RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION. TO SET
REGIONAL BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION TARGETS. FOR
TWENTY THIRTY IN TWENTY FORTY
FIVE CONSISTENT WITH THE
STATE'S TARGETS FOR REDUCING
EMISSIONS OF GREENHOUSE GASES
AND AUTHORIZE NPOS TO DEVELOP
AN ADDENDUM TO THE SCS. THAT
ENUMERATES LOCAL BUILDING TO
CARBONIZATION POLICIES. IT
PASSED OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE.
UP IN THIS IS A CERTAINLY AN
IMPORTANT CROSSES POINT AS
BEFORE SEVENTY FIVE WILL BE
SENT TO SENATE TRANSPORTATION-
BUT MY INTENT THERE IS HOLD THE
MEASURE AS A TO YOUR BILL. THE
END A COMMIT TO WORKING WITH
SURE ALAN ALONG WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEES ON A
CLAVICLE COLLABORATIVE PATH
FORWARD ON THIS ISSUE. APPEAR
TO TESTIFY PROVIDE- TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN TERMS OF ANY
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS IS
REBEKAH ALONG WITH THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION WHICH IS THE MPO
FROM THE BAY AREA- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EYEBALLS
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR A MISS
LONG IS SLIGHT LEAD WITNESS-
MODERATOR DO HAVE MISS LONG ON.
ON THE TELECONFERENCE LINE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD MR ON YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
FINANCIAL BACK ALONG AND I'M
THE MANAGER GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
THE ASSOCIATION OF BAY AREA
GOVERNMENTS. TOGETHER AND
CHEESY IN A BAG ARE JOINTLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT YEAH. SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA WE ACROSS
CENTER COURT TECHNIQUE FOR
INTRODUCING US BEFORE SEVENTY
FIVE WHICH WOULD UPDATE THE
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD LAWS THAT
ESTABLISH THE REQUIREMENT FOR
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
STRATEGY SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE.
THIS LANDMARK LAW WITH
NOTEWORTHY FOR LINKING OUR
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING FUNDING
AND AND USE DECISIONS TO THE
STATE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
GOALS. AND KEEPING WITH THE
COURT OF THE LAW AT THE TIME
AND HEAVILY INVOLVED IN PASSAGE
UNFORTUNATELY AS A R. B. TO.
SACRAMENTO INTERACTING WITH IF
YOU WERE TWENTY H. EIGHTEEN SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE IT'S.
FALLING SHORT OF GOLD ON A
NUMBER OF FRONTS. ALTHOUGH
PLANS MEETING G. H. REDUCTION
TARGETS ON PAPER. IN THE REAL
WORLD TRY ARE MOVING IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION WHAT VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED HER PERSON
GROWING. RATHER THAN FLOWING.
AT BEFORE SEVENTY FIVE AIMS TO
ADDRESS THAT BY FOCUSING ON
NEAR TERM ADMINISTRATION OF
PROJECTS AND POLICIES. WITH A
PROVEN RECORD OF REDUCING
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AND
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
RATHER THAN THE CURRENT
APPROACH WHICH IS OVERLY
FOCUSED ON ACHIEVING A MAGIC
NUMBER IN A LONG TERM
TRANSPORTATION MODEL.
CRITICALLY BEFORE SEVENTY FIVE
WILL REQUIRE REGIONAL AGENCIES
LIKE MINE. YOU IDENTIFIED NEAR
TERM ACTIONS THEY WILL TAKE TO
ACHIEVE STRATEGIES THAT ARE
PROVEN TO REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS.
AND THEN HOLD US ACCOUNTABLE
FOR ACTION. FINALLY AND BEFORE
SEVENTY FIVE TAKES THE CRITICAL
STEP IN INTEGRATING SOCIAL
EQUITY AND CLIMATE RESILIENT
AND THE OTHER. IN THE AREA
TWENTY FIFTY ARE CURRENTAS THE
US UNDER DEVELOPMENT IN TO
EXPAND PROSPERITY FOR ALL BAY
AREA RESIDENTS AND MAKE OUR
COMMUNITY MORE RESILIENT IN THE
FACE OF THE CLIMBING. A
CHANGING CLIMATE THAT THREATENS
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF HOMES
AND BUSINESSES YOU CAN SEE
LEVEL RIGHTS AND WILDFIRES.
WELL WE HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
TACKLE THAT IN OUR DRAFT PLAN
CURRENT LAW PROVIDES
CONFLICTING DIRECTION AND
INSUFFICIENT FLEXIBILITY HOW TO
APPROACH TRADEOFFS ACROSS THESE
MULTIPLE IMPORTANT GOAL.
INCLUDING I ASK YOUR SUPPORT TO
MOVING SB FOUR SEVENTY FIVE FOR
TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH CENTER COURT
HEADTEACHER ALLEN MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE. THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD AND OTHER KEY
STAKEHOLDERS ON FINAL BILL THAT
WILL BE THERE ARE PROGRESS
TOWARD A COMMON GOAL. WHILE
ALSO HELPING REGION'S INTEGRATE
THE GOAL TO SOCIAL EQUITY AND
RESILIENCE AND TRANSPLANT.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY THAT. THANK YOU I
DON'T SEE ANOTHER LEAD WITNESS
SO WE WILL LOOK TO ANYONE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF
SB FOUR SEVEN FIVE I DON'T SEE
ANYONE HERE. A NEW ONE IN
TWENTY FORTY SO BRING IT BACK
TO- COMMITTEE. SENATOR GONZALEZ
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. SESSION
I WISH. ALL RIGHT YEAH. THOSE
WHO WISH TO KNOW WHAT. RIGHT
YEAH. THOSE ARE WHO ARE THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR SEVEN FIVE. MODERATOR
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- TO SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB FOUR SEVEN
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO
PARTICIPANTS ARE CURING UP
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU THEN WE
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION- ANY.
PERSONS IN FORTY TWO OH THREE I
DON'T SEE ANY COMING FORWARD TO
OPPOSE FOR NINE IN TWENTY FORTY.
BEYOND THAT FOR ANY OF THOSE ON
THE LINE MODERATOR WHO'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO SHOW
YOUR OPPOSITION FOR SB FORTY
SEVEN FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. GET TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR SBFORTY FIVE
FOUR SEVEN FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU. SO NOW WE WILL COME BACK
TO COMMITTEE AND SENATOR
GONZALEZ THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR- AND SENATOR CORTESE I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- FOR PUTTING THIS FORWARD
AS WELL AS YOUR LAST BILL IT
AND GET A CHANCE TO SAY- THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THAT FORWARD
AS WELL AND I KNOW YOU ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
CENTER ALLEN AND- ARE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AS
WELL WERE LOOKING FRWARD TO
THAT SO. WHAT I APPRECIATED
MOST MOST ABOUT YOUR APPROACH
IS THAT IT'S COLLABORATIVE AND
INCLUDES OUR LOCAL- YOU KNOW
NPOS WHICH I THINK IS-
CERTAINLY WELL RESPECTED IN A
FROM THEM SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT WE CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS THANK YOU SENATE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. THIS
SENATOR DOLLY. THE WORD SOME
SOME OF THE LOCALS DON'T HAVE
IN PO'S LIKE SO WHEN I CLICK
SAKE AUGUST FOR THE SACRAMENTO
REGION BUT A LOT OF THE VERY
SMALL RURAL COUNTIES THEY HAVE
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSIONS ARE
HOW WOULD THAT BE IF HOW THIS
BILL AFFECT THEM. BECAUSE AS OF
NOW THE BILL IS THIS ONLY
TRYING TO GO IN- IN THOSE AREAS
WERE SES'S ARE ARE BEING
DEVELOPED BY- BY HIM PEELS ARE
BY REGIONAL ENTITIES- DIED IN.
HERE TRYING TO BRING IN IN
THESE OTHER ELEMENTS- WE HAVE
WORK TO DO THAT'S WHY A WILL
WILL SORT OF HOPSCOTCH HERE TO
A PLACE WHERE WE CAN GET OF
INTO COLLABORATIVE MODE IN
TERMS OF THE TRANSPORTATION
SIDE A LOT OF THIS WORK IN THE
PAST HAS BEEN TRANSPORTATION
BUT MEANWHILE WE GOT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOR EXAMPLE. MAYBE
NOT YOUR COUNTY CERTAINLY MY
COUNTY SOME WHITE AND SOME
OTHER COUNTIES ADOPT. OF REACH
CLOSER DECARBONIZATION POLICIES
WHICH UP SEPARATE LEGISLATION
IS ASKING THEM TO PUT INTO
THEIR THEIR LOCAL GENERAL
PLANNED SO THAT THESE REGIONAL
ENTITIES THAT ARE DOING THESE
SES'S CONCEDE THAT INCLUDED-
THE BENEFIT OF ANY GHG
REDUCTION FROM THESE OTHER
ACTIVITIES LIKE BUILDING-
BUILDING REDUCTIONS BUILDING
GHG REDUCTIONS SO. IT'S- WE'LL
HAVE TO LOOK ALONG THE WAY YOU
KNOW FOR DIRT DURING THIS
COLLABORATIVE APPROACHES TO. AS
TO HOW TO GET THIS KNITTED
TOGETHER UP AND DOWN THE STATE
BUT THIS BILL DOESN'T ATTEMPT
TO IMPOSE. ANY NEW REQUIREMENTS
WHERE THEY DON'T CURRENTLY
EXIST- IN IN GEOGRAPHICALLY OR
IN GOVERNANCE JURISDICTIONS
WHERE THEY DON'T CURRENTLY
EXIST IT'S TRYING TO BUILD OFF
OF THREE SEVENTY FIVE NOT. FOR
IT ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WITH.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE IF. IT IF
YOU AN AREA WHERE HAVE LIKE. A
COG RIGHT IN YOU. AND IN IT
WORKS THERE BUT THREE SEVENTY
FIVE WAS A STATEWIDE LAW THAT
DIDN'T REALLY EXIST VERY MANY
SO LOT OF COMMITTEES THAT THIRD
LOOK FOR SOMEWHERE IN SOME
COMMUNITIES ARE JUST NO WAY
AROUND GETTING AWAY FROM
TRAVELING YOU HAVE TO TRAVEL A
FEW. TO GET THE COMMUNITY OR IT
IS THERE'S NO PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION THERE'S NO.
REGIONAL GOVERNMENT QUITE
FRANKLY THERE'S THEIR SMALL
COMMUNITIES IN THREE SEVENTY
FIVE WAS IT WAS IT WAS A BATTLE
TO YOU TO DO YOUR YOUR GENERAL
PLANS. AND MEET THE CRITERIA
THREE SEVENTY FIVE BECAUSE THE
ONE SIZE FITS ALL REALLY
DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK FOR. LOT OF
CALIFORNIA A LOT OF THE VERY
WIDE OPEN RULE PLACES IT REALLY
DOESN'T WORK IT MAKES SENSE TO
DO IT. IN PLACES WHERE YOU
HAVE. CITIES COUNTIES AD IN
AND TRANSPORTATION THAT THEY
ALL NEED TO TALK AND THAT AND
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE LIKE I
REPRESENT. SACRAMENTO COUNTY
WHICH HAS A COG BUT I ALSO
REPRESENT SISKIYOU COUNTY THAT
HAS. A TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION BUT DOESN'T HAVE. A
REGIONAL GOVERNMENT I MEAN THAT
THAT THAT HAS TO COORDINATE
WITH ALL THESE OTHER- PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. TYPE THING SO
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN A CONCERN
BECAUSE ONE THREE SEVEN I WAS
ACTUALLY. REMEMBER THREE
SEVENTY FIVE IS A BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THEN AND- AND WE
HAD TO DEAL WITH THAT WE DID
OUR GENERAL PLAN AMENDMENTS IN
OUR COUNTY REALLY DIDN'T DIDN'T
FIT INTO OUR COUNTY DIDN'T MAKE
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE OUT THERE
TO YOU CAN'T. YOU CAN'T ACHIEVE
THE GOALS. ON YOUR BUILDING
PLANS- THAT WERE SET IN A THREE
SEVENTY FIVE. SO THAT'S WHAT I
AM I AM I KNOW THIS BECAUSE
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS FROM
WHAT I HEARD YOU SAY- SO THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT WE NEED TO BE
TALKING ABOUT ON TRANSPORTATION
AS WELL BECAUSE- IT IS A
CHALLENGE TO ME DAD AND THERE'S
JUST NO POSSIBLE WAY TO GET
THERE SOMETIME SO. I'M A LAYOFF
THE BILL MY ONE WATCH WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THAT BUT I
DEFINITELY WANT TO BE ENGAGED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE- NO DO
RIGHT FOR THE AREAS THAT WHAT
MAKES SENSE IN AREAS THAT DON'T
MAKE SENSE WE GET THESE CLOSE
WE CAN. BUT THE ALLOW THEM SOME
EXEMPTIONS- THANK YOU CENTER
FLOOR I'M A COLLABORATOR AND
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOUR
ENGAGEMENT GOING FORWARD SO WE
CAN GET IT RIGHT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OF SENATOR MCCASKILL MOVE THE
BILL JUST A QUICK COMMENT
SENATOR CORTESE ACTUALLY I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE IS A GOOD DIRECTION MY
CONCERN IS ALWAYS GIVING MORE
POWER TO A R. B. THAT COULD N
FACT FIND OF SOME OF THE
REGIONAL STRATEGIES PRESENTED
BY OUR NPOS TO BE NOT IN%
COMPLIANCE AND THEN IMPACT
THEIR ABILITY TO GET THE FUNDS
THEY NEED TO DO THE VERY THING.
HE WANTING THEM TO DO HERE-
WHAT I'M GONNA DO I'M GONNA
SUPPORT IT TODAY BECAUSE IT
COMES A TRANSPORTATION AND I
KNOW BETWEEN NOW AND THEN
YOU'RE GOING TO BE WORKING ON
IT THEY THINK IT'S A STRONG
STATEMENT YOU PUT THOSE THE
RIGHT DIRECTION REGARDING THIS-
THIS INCREASE THIS HOUSING
DENSIFICATION THAT SEEMS TO BE
AT THE TOP OF THE PRIORITY LIST
AND IT DOESN'T FIT NECESSARILY
WITH WHAT. A. R. B. MIGHT BE
REQUIRING US SO WE'VE GOT I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
CONFLICTS WITH OUR NPOS TRYING
TO DO BOTH THINGS. SO THAT
GIVES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE
DISCUSSION AND WE'LL SEE WHERE
I CAN BE AN TRANSPORTATION BUT
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU HAVE THE
VOTES TODAY SO. TO HELP YOU OUT
HELP YOU GET OUT OF HERE OKAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR A PRIEST
AGAIN APPRECIATE THAT THE PHONE
GAUGING OF THE COMMITTEE- AND
I'M- JUST RAINY AT A. R. B. FOR
ME SOMETIMES SO YOU GUYS. I
BRING IT UP I'VE BEEN ON HE
QUEUES SINCE I GOT HERE AND I
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN MY PROBLEM
BRING IT BACK TO US. WITH THE
GUYS THAT ARE REPRESENTING THE%
PEOPLE OUT THERE AND WE KNOW.
OUR OWN COMMUNITIES OF SENATOR
DOLLY POINTED OUT IT'S JUST
CAN'T BE COOKIE CUTTER ALL THE
TIME SO. IN ANY EVENT- MADAM ON
SECRETARY YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL.
I AM NUMBER TWO SB FOUR SEVENTY
FIVE BY SENATOR CORTESE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT- FIRST
THE RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON TRANSPORTATION ALLEN. BATES.
FIVE EIGHT I DALY. KELLY NOT
VOTING GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
SKINNER STERN TURN ON- AND I BY
CASKEY HIGH STI. THANK YOU
SENATOR CORTESE I THINK WE
HAVE- FOR VOTES AND WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR THOSE WHO ARE
NOT HERE THANK YOU CAN VENTURE
AND COMMITTEE THEN WILL MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER THREE SENATE BILL
FIFTY NINE AND I SEE SENATOR
CAFIERO HERE.
PLEASE PROCEED.
WELCOME SENATOR CAFIERO THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU ADD
CHAIRWOMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
WHO NGAGE IN EXTENSIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH MY OFFICE
AND THE SPONSORS TO NARROW THE
BILL WHICH WILL ALLOW EXISTING
LICENSED CANNABIS OPERATORS. TO
CONTINUE TO LEGALLY OPERATE
WHILE THEIR APPLICATIONS FOR
ANNUAL LICENSORS. ARE BEING
EVALUATED. SB FIFTY NINE. IS A
CRITICAL PRIORITY FOR THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY AND THE
EVOLUTION OF THE LEGALIZATION
AND REGULATION OF CANNABIS IN
CALIFORNIA. ABSENT THIS
EXTENSION OVER EIGHT THOUSAND
CANNABIS LICENSEES WOULD BE
FORCED TO SHUTTER OPERATIONS
WHEN THE PROVISIONAL LICENSE
PROGRAM EXPIRES AT THE END OF
THIS YEAR. ACCORDING TO A
RECENT REPORT ISSUED IN MARCH
83% OF CANNABIS LICENSEE
LICENSES ARE PROVISIONAL WHILE
ONLY 17% OUR ANNUAL LICENSES.
SPECIFICALLY SB FIFTY NINE
EXTENDS THE REPEAL DATE OF THE
CANNABIS PROVISIONAL LICENSE
PROGRAM BY SIX YEARS. FOR ALL
EXISTING CANNABIS OPERATORS IN
POSSESSION OF A STATE ISSUED
PROVISIONAL LICENSE. ALL NEW
CANNABIS APPLICATIONS WILL BE
ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR A
PROVISIONAL LICENSE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL SIX MONTHS UNTIL
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO IN
OTHER WORDS FOR ANOTHER YEAR
UNLESS THOSE APPLICATIONS ARE
SUBMITTED BY SOCIAL EQUITY
APPLICANTS IN A LOCALLY
APPROVED. SOCIAL EQUITY PROGRAM.
SB FIFTY NINE MEETS THE SPIRIT
AND THE INTENT OF THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION WHICH DEVELOPED THE
PROVISIONAL LICENSE PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE A STABLE RELIABLE PATH
FOR CALIFORNIA'S CANNABIS
INDUSTRY. TO MAINTAIN
OPERATIONS WELL TREAD
TRANSITIONING INTO THE NEWLY
REGULATED MARKET PLACE. SB
FIFTY NINE ALSO HELPS ACHIEVE A
KEY POLICY OBJECTIVES. TO
REDUCE THE UPFRONT CAPITAL
EXPENDITURES NEEDED TO ENTER
THE INTERNET INDUSTRY ALLOWING
CANNABIS EQUITY OPERATORS THE
TIME TO BUILD UP CAPITAL NEEDED
TO MOVE INTO THE ANNUAL
LICENSING STRUCTURE. WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF IT SB FIFTY NINE
OR AMY JENKINS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND THE
INTERNATIONAL CANNABIS FARMERS
ASSOCIATION AND MENDOCINO
COUNTY SUPERVISOR TED WILLIAMS
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MODERATOR ARE LEAD WITNESSES ON
THE LINE. MAY CALL THEM PLEASE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AMY
JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND THE
INTERNATIONAL CANNABIS FARMERS
ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING THIS
CRITICAL LEGISLATION AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
THOUGHTFUL OUT THAT. LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA'S LEGAL CANNABIS
INDUSTRY GENERATED THREE POINT
SEVEN BILLION. HOW TO BAIL
EMPLATE 570-009-0070 FULL TIME
WORKERS AND GENERATED OVER A
BILLION IN STATE TAX REVENUE
DESPITE THE INDUSTRY'S
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY THE LEGAL
INDUSTRY STATE A PENDING CRISIS
THAT. WITHOUT AN EXTENSION OF
THE PROVISIONAL LIKE WITH
PROGRAM A DEFENDER NOTED
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY TWO
HUNDRED EXISTING PROVISIONAL
LIKE. THOSE WILL CALL AT A
COMPLIANCE. I THINK PEOPLE
ASKED THE LEDGES SHOULD
CONSIDER A EXT OF THAT PROGRAM
LIKE MANY ISSUES INVOLVING
CANADA'STHE ANSWER IS
COMPLICATED UNDER EXISTING LAW
APPLICANTS BURKE PROVISONAL
LIGHT. DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY
ARE AS LOCALLY AUTHORIZED TO
ENGAGE IN COMMERCIAL CANNABIS
ACTIVITY THANKS TO THE LIGHT
THEY ARE PLAYING FOR AND BE
ACTIVELY WORKING TO ACHIEVE ALL
ENVIRONMENTAL COMPLIANCE. ONLY
WHEN THE APPLICATION PROCESS BE
INCOMPLETE AN ACCOUNT OF THE
OPERATOR MOVES OUT OF THE
PROVISIONAL LICENSE AND RECEIVE
AN ANNUAL STATE LIKE THAT AND-
IT LIKE MANY OTHER BUSINESSES
IN CALIFORNIA. CANTICLES OF THE
PROJECT MARCH TENTH OF
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW HERE
ACTIVE OF WHERE THE BUSINESS IS
LOCATED WHETHER OR NOT THE
APPLICANT IT APPEARED TO
PERFORM SUBSTANTIAL
MODIFICATIONS TO THE PREMISE.
WHETHER THE PROPOSED ACTIVITY
IT CULTIVATION RETAIL OR
MANUFACTURING IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
GENERAL PLAN. INSTEAD EVERY
APPLICANT MUST GO THROUGH A
SITE THAT THE CANAL OF THAT.
THE SIX YEAR EXTENSION OF THE
PROVISIONAL LICENSE PROGRAM FOR
EXISTING APPLICANTS AS PROPOSED
IN SB FIFTY NINE ONE SURE THAT
LOCAL JURISDCTIONS A LOT OF
THE STATE OPPOSITIONPRIME TO
COMPLETE APPLICATION RUBIOAND
THAT SHE- ENVIRONMENTAL
COMPLIANCE. FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
YOU PLEASE SUPPORT. SB FIFTY
NINE TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. OKAY SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GOOD MORNING VICE
CHAIR BATES AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILLIAMS IS TRICKS TO
PROVIDE HER COUNTY OF MENDOCINO
THIS BUDGET IS CRITICAL TO THE
FUTURE MENACING AS LEGAL
CANNABIS INDUSTRY AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN MY COUNTY PASSED AN
ORDINANCE WHICH PROVIDES A
MINISTERIAL. PATHWAY LABELING
X. CALL TO TRANSITION TO THE
NEWLY REGULATED MARKETPLACE
UNFORTUNATELY OUR ORDINANCE WAS
PASSED AND IMPLEMENTED BEFORE
THE STATE COMPLICATED
REGULATIONS WHICH TRAIN ALL
CANNABIS APPLICATIONS AS
PROJECTS SUBJECT TO PROJECTS
SPECIFIC SEQUENCE ELSE THIS
PROJECT SPECIFIC SEQUIN ALLEN
SAYS IS GENERALLY CONDUCTED BY
THE FIRST AGENCY TO ISSUE A
DISCRETIONARY PERMIT CANNABIS
THIS BURDEN FALLS ON A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. AND GENERAL USE
PERMIT TAKE ABOUT A YEAR TO
PROCESS EACH STAFF PLANNER HAS
THE ABILITY TO PROCESS BETWEEN
FIVE AND SEVEN PER YEAR THE
PROCESS FLOW FOR REVEALING IS
PERMITTED IN CREDIBLY TIME
CONSUMING ONCE THE LOCAL AGENCY
RECEIVES A COMPLETE APPLICATION
FOR USE. IT MUST DISTRIBUTE TO
LOCAL AND STATE AGENCIES RUBIO
INCLUDING LOCAL PUBLIC WORKS
PUBLIC HEALTH PUBLIC SAFETY
DEPARTMENTS NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES STATE AGENCIES INCLUDING
CAL FIRE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FISH WILDLIFE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD WATER
QUALITY WATER RIGHTS DIVISIONS
EACH AGENCY REVIEWS THE
APPLICATION AND RESPOND WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS TO REDUCE
POTENTIAL FOR SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS THIS
PROCESS OFTEN TAKES AROUND ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS. THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE MADE A
LOCAL AGENCY WILL SHARE THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS WITH THE
APPLICANT HAS BEEN RESPONSIBLE
FOR MANAGING THE PROJECT
APPLICATION INCLUDED REQUESTED
MEDICATIONS OR MODIFICATIONS
THE REVIEW AND REFERRAL PROCESS
IS COMPLETE THE APPLICATION IS
HEARD BY THE ZONING
ADMINISTRATOR OR THE PLANNING
COMMISSION AS PART OF A NOTICE
PUBLIC HEARING IN COUNTIES
WHERE HUNDREDS OR THOUSANDS
CAMPUS APPLICATIONS HAVE BEEN
ACCEPTED. THE TIMELINE FOR
PROCESSING CAN BE THREE TO FIVE
YEARS FOR MOLESTING AS
MINISTERIAL PERMITTING SYSTEM
IS NOT QUALIFIED PERMIT HOLDERS
FOR ANNUAL LICENSES HI COUNTY
HAS SUCCESSFULLY COLLABORATED
WITH STATE ON A PATHWAY DANIEL
ANSWERED. QUESTION A 10% OF OUR
ELEVEN HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT HOUR.
MAY BE SICK. GERMANO PERCENT
WILL LIKELY BREAK SOME OF
MEDICATION. OR CONDITIONING
WHICH CAN ONLY BE A CALL UNDER.
USE I'M ALREADY THE PATH OF A
NEW ARE NOT I MEAN I YOU TO ONE
THE LOCAL. BUSINESSES AND THE
RADIO MARKET BY. IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURING THAT ANY SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS ARE
CROSSED. ESTIMATES ARE CRACKED
BY COUNTY WOULD NEED
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED FORTY
SKILLED PLANNERS TO PROCESS
EXISTING APPLICATIONS OVER A
TWELVE MONTH PERIOD. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A STAFF OF FOUR
RIGHT NOW TO ASK MY DOCTOR ON
ITS FLEET AUTHORIZED BY S. B.
FIFTY NINE. LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
HUMBOLDT WAIT MODERATE ANGELES
SANTA BARBARA MINIMIZING OTHERS
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO PROCESS THE
BACKLOG OF APPLICATIONS WHICH
WILL FORCE BUSINESSES TO EXIT
THE REGULATED MARKET PLACE
TRANSOCEANIC OVERSIGHT.
CANNABIS CULTIVATION HAS BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF MENDOCINE
OVERALL ECONOMY THEREFORE I
COUNTY VIEWS SB FIFTY NINE IT'S
IMPERATIVE TO FULFILLING THE
VISION OF A LEGAL AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY COMPLIANT
CANNABIS INDUSTRY I URGE YOU.
TO SUPPORT SB FIFTY NINE TODAY.
OKAY ARE. WE'VE GOT. THAT ARE
TO THE- TO THE TO THE JOINTS OF
SO- AND IF THE FIRST PER TAKES
A TIME THERE'S LAST TIME FOR
THE NEXT PERSON PART LET'S GO
NEXT TO- IN PERSON. TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT AND ONCE DIED ON
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. I
DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE OR IN THE.
YEAH NOBODY OVER IN TWENTY
FORTY YEAH AND IT WILL HAVE ON
THE PHONE LINES WHAT SORT OF
SUPPORT DO WE HAVE. FISHEL'S
WORK FOR SB FIFTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND
WE WILL LINE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON THE US
ARMY DOES ON BEHALF OF CRESCO
LABS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MEMBERS ASHLEY WALKER WITH NOT
THE MEN ON BEHALF OF THE
MONTEREY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MOVING ONLINE SIXTY YEAR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KERN. THE OF
YELLOW IN SUPPORT OKAY. FIND
SIXTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
NUMBER THREE FIFTY THEN TOOK
GOVERNMENT ONE OF THE KIDS ON
BEHALF OF BOTH NATURE AND
SACRAMENTO AND BODY IN MIND IN
THE SAN DIEGO AND LONG BEACH
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ONE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS
RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF OF CMG
KHALIFA I AM VERY STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS CRITICAL BILL
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY YOU ARE
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CAPTAIN
PAYMENT ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING FIFTY EIGHT
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ONE SIXTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN OF THE CELEBRATORY
COMING UP THE UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS I WANT TO
THANK YOU- YOUR STAFF AND
CENTER COUPLE EURO FOR
DISCUSSIONS WE'VE HAD. WHERE
SUPPORT TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF AMENDED THERE ARE SOME
NUMBER OF ISSUES TO BE RAISED
IN TERMS YOU KNOW WE THINK THAT
THE SIX YEARS. MIGHT BE TOO
LONG AS THE PROVISIONAL LICENSE
PROVIDE SOME OPERATORS LOOPHOLE
NOT TO NOT ONLY SHOULD NOT A
NOT ME TO SPEAK REQUIREMENTS
BUT ALSO TO NOT ABIDE BY OTHER
CONDITIONS THAT THEY HAVE FROM
THEIR LICENSES. FOR THOSE ROOMS
FOR SUPPORT OF AMENABLE LOOKING
FORWARD TO CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS
AND AGAIN I APPRECIATE
CONSCIOUS HAD WITH YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND. WITHIN A COUPLE
YEAR THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS BREAK LIABILITY
WITH APEX GROUPS ON BEHALF
SECURELY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. Q. I AM ONE MOMENT
WE HAVE A COUPLE MORE QUEUING
UP. CHECK. ONE MOMENT THERE
WITH OUR OPERATOR. AND WE WERE
LINE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SIXTY THREE ARE OPEN.
ONE SIXTY THREE PLEASE ON MUTE
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO OUR
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. THEY ARE
NOT RESPONDING WILL ALIGN SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALICIA
PRINGLE ON BEHALF OF D. AND
ALSO THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND I'M SURE
THERE ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP. THANK YOU LET'S GO
NOW TO OPPOSITION I KNOW WE'VE
GOT- JEANINE COLEMAN WHO'S ON
THE LINE FROM THE ORIGIN
COUNCIL. I WILL START WITH
JEANINE. AND THEN- JERRY KYLO
FROM UNITED CANNABIS BUSINESSES
ASIAN. TH TH THANK YOU IT
MORNING MISTER CHERN NUMBERS MY
NAME'S JEANINE COLEMAN I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ORIGIN
COUNCIL WE ADVOCATE ON BEHALF
OF LIFE CANNABIS OPERATORS
UNDERTAKING A PATHWAY TO
LICENSURE. WITHIN CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORIC ENERGY. EXACTLY OUR
REGIONAL PARTNER INCLUDE THE
TRINITY AGRICULTURAL THE
MENDOCINO CANNABIS ONE NUMBER
CAN GROWERS ALLIANCE. THE
NEVADA COUNTY CANNABIS PLANTS
AND THE BIG PERFORMERS.
REPRESENT FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS
THE VAST MAJORITY OF WHICH ARE
TRADITIONALLY LIFE AND SMALL
CANNABIS FARMS DEPENDING ON AN
EXTENSION OF THE PROVISIONAL
PROGRAM FOR THEIR SURVIVAL
WITHOUT AN EXTENSION
CATASTROPHE WOULD BE ALL.
CALIFORNIANS REGULATED CANNABIS
SUPPLY CHAIN AS A RESULT OUR
ORGANIZATIONS REGISTERED
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL'S ENERGY.
HOWEVER EVIL TWELFTH AMENDMENT
OF CONSTITUTION OF THE BOARD OF
AMENDED POSITION. BUT WE WERE
VERY CONCERNED WITH THE
PROPOSAL TO CLOSE PROVISIONAL
LICENSING A NEW APPLICATION
BEGINNING JULY TWENTY FOURTH
YOU. WILL EXPONENTIALLY
INCREASE BARRIERS TO ENTRY DUE
TO THE COST AND TIME FRAME.
CHEATING ALL AND LICENSURE
WITHOUT THE ABILITY FOR YOU
OPERATORS FAILED AND THOUSAND
PROVISIONALLY LICENSED
OPERATIONS AND EARNINGS WHILE
WORKING TOWARD ENLIGHTENED
THING. SMALL FARMERS AND FIRING
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS WILL BE
EFFECTIVELY. LOCKED DOWN LIFE
INSURANCE. AND LIFE YOU CAN
CALCULATE RELATED FARMERS
FUNDAMENTAL GUIDING ON THE
PRODUCTION AND REMEDIATING AND-
IMPACT CAUSED BY JACKIE OF
UNDER. PRODUCTION PROVISIONAL
LIKE WORK ENSURE THAT. ON THE
PATH TO SPEAK WHAT COMPLY AND I
UNDER A ENVIRONMENTAL RIGHT.
YEAH FOR LIKE WILL BRING DID
NOT SIMPLY- OPEN EVERY WELL
LIKE IF YOU. ON JANUARY FIRST
EIGHTEEN. AS ONE EXAMPLE THE
BAKER REGION OF MONTEREY IS
WORKING TO FINALIZE THEIR
ORDINANCES FOR COMMERCIAL
OUTDOOR CULTIVATION. THIS IS
THE CULMINATION OF FOUR YEARS
OF EFFORT AND THE FIRST VIABLE
PATHWAYS THE STORY MULTI
GENERATIONAL HOMESTEAD FARMERS.
THE FOURTEENTH LIKE TO SHARE.
THE LEFT IN THE PLEDGE
CONSIDERED THE OF PROVISION
PROGRAM WAS INITIALLY NINETEEN.
WHAT FOLLOWED WAS AN ONGOING
GLOBAL. AND THE LARGER COMPLEX
OF WILDFIRES IN HISTORY
CALIFORNIA. IMPACTED ALL OF OUR
MEMBER REGION FUNDAMENTALLY WE
ARE SIMPLY ASKING TO HAVE
BACKED THE TO YOUR PROVISIONAL
LICENSINGON RAM PROVIDED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. WHICH WAS
LARGELY LOST THE CATASTROPHIC
EVENT YOUNGER CONTROL THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO CALL.
THANK YOU I THINK WE NEXT HAVE
FIRM. JERRY KYLO. THANK YOU
HELLO PRESIDENT BY THE UNITED
CAN WITH BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN A SUPPORT AS AMENDED
PETITION BECAUSE WE KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO ALLOW SIX
MORE YEARS FOR CURRENT
PROVISIONAL LICENSE HOLDERS
THAT TIME TO ACHIEVE THEIR
ANNUAL LIFE AND BUT TO CLOSE
THE DOOR IN THE FACE OF NEW
APPLICANTS AND WHERE WE DIVERT
FROM THE LANGUAGE IN THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT AS A TWELVE
BILLION DOLLAR A YEAR INDUSTRY
AND IT'S BEEN IN OPERATION FOR
DECADES IN THE AMOUNT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE WE ARE TRYING TO
CONVERT TAKES TIME SO FAR WE'VE
CONVERTED FOUR BILLION ABOUT
TWELVE INTO THE REGULATED
INDUSTRY TO DATE SO WHY ARE WE
MAKING THE OTHER EIGHT BILLION
OF DIFFICULT. THERE'S A REASON
WHY 80% OF THE CURRENT LIKING
TO THEIR STILL PROVISIONAL BUT
NO ONE KNOWS HOW LONG IT'S
GOING TO TAKE TO COMPLY WITH
THE EVER CHANGING REGULATIONS
AT EVERY LEVEL OF THE
APPLICATION LIKE THE PROCESS
AND WHY THIS BILL EXPAND OUT
THE CURRENT IN A LIKELY PROFIT
ANOTHER SIX YEARS BUT IT IS
NEEDED TO STABILIZE AN INDUSTRY
WITH THE TARGET KEEPS MOVING
CITY OF LA WE'VE HAD PROP WO
FIFTEEN AT BEFORE TWENTY PRE%
IPO PROPERTIES MEASURE AM PROP
SIXTY FOUR BYTES OF ANY
CHANGES. WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
WE'RE DOING TO REGULATE THIS
PLANT ALL THE DEEPLY ROOTED
CONNECTIONS TO LOCAL ECONOMY
LET'S NOT SIT HERE AND PRETEND
THAT REDUCING TIME IS THE
ANSWER TO THE THREE DECADE LONG
PROBLEM IN COVERT HAPPEN CAMPUS
BUSINESSES GONNA PPP LOUNGE THE
FAMILIES FIRST GRANTS NO SBA
LOAN NO TAX REDUCTIONS THE
PERMIT FOR ALL AND NO CHANCE TO
USE THE ADMINISTRATION TO YEAR
EXTENSION ACCORDED THEM ON AT.
THREE NINETY SEVEN IN A PROGRAM.
IT'S STATE LAW GOVERNMENTS .COM
PUBLIC. AND I. AT NORMAL GOT.
OF COURSE SEVERAL NEEDS MORE
TIME WHY SHOULD CANADA TREATED
TO DIFFERENTLY THAN OTHER.
BUSINESS THAT. NEEDS TO BE A-
WITH MORE OPERATE. RETAIL
CANNABIS. AND ANY OTHER CITY.
WE DON'T HAVE A SINGLE. LICENSE
AND THESE RETAILERS BY LAW HAVE
BEEN A CONTINUOUS OPERATION FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS. AND FROM HOW
THEY STILL OPERATE. TO THE
STATE ON PROVISIONAL LICENSE
THAT. WE HAVE TO ORDER MORE
SOCIAL EQUITY OF LICENSES. THAT
HAVE BEEN WAITING FOR TWO YEARS
TO GET THEM TO THE LOCAL
APPLICATION PROCESS. AND
HUNDREDS OF APPLICATIONS FOR
NON PUBLIC STORE PRINT.
DELIVERY LIKE INTO. AN EIGHT
HUNDRED PHASE TWO AND PHASE
THREE APPLICANTS THAT WERE
GIVEN A FRAMEWORK FOR THE
ENTRANCE INTO THE LEGAL SYSTEM.
THEY'RE STILL ON A WAITING
LIST. EACH ONE OF THESE
APPLICANTS HAVE INVESTED AT
LEAST FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
RENT ON AN ADDRESS. LAWYERS TO
DETERMINE COMPLIANCE
CONSULTANTS DURING THE
APPLICATION. ACCOUNT TO PRODUCE
A BUSINESS PLAN. AND FRIENDS IN
HARD MONEY LENDER. ON THE
PROJECT. HOW CAN WE TAKE AWAY
THE CRITICAL ON RAMP TO THE
MULTI MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT. THE APPLICANT OF ME
IN THE FUTURE THE CAMPUS WITH
THE- CITY VALLEY NEED EVERY ONE
OF THE FEW TAXPAYERS TO COME
ONLINE. IN. OUR NEW HUGE BUDGET
DEFICIT. ALITY EVERYTHING AND
CAL. THAT DISCUSSED REGULAR
CANNABIS IN CREATING. JUST
LOOKING FOR THEIR AND WITH ONLY
MARKET. RELYING ON THE VIABLE.
OF THE- IS OPEN AND TO RETAIN
EACH COMMUNITY FOR THE TIME AND
EFFORT THEY HAVE TAKEN. TO COME
UP WITH GREAT LOCAL POLITICS
AND WE CANNOT GUARANTEE A TIME
LINE FOR AN ANNUAL LICENSE. AND
HOW CAN WE RESTRICT ONE.
CANNABIS HISTORY THIS TRULY
ESSENTIAL INDUSTRY AND EVERY
EFFORT SHOULD BE MADE TO BRING
EVERYONE ONLINE. PERSONALLY
I'VE BEEN WAITING EIGHTEEN
YEARS IN THE LEGAL CANNABIS
INDUSTRY FOR MY ANNUAL LIFE
AND- SKEWS ME IF I DON'T THINK
ANOTHER SIX MONTHS. ADEQUATE
FOR OTHER SUBJECTS WE'RE JUST
GETTING STARTED. PLEASE SUPPORT
SB FIFTY NINE IS AMENDED. TO
ALLOW TWO MORE YEARS FOR NEW
ENTRANTS TO AVAIL THEMSELVES.
PROVISIONAL LICENSE WHILE.
WAITING AN ANNUAL LICENSE THANK
YOU. AREN'T YOU. I'M NOT SEEING
ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFYSUPPORT.
I IN PERSON OR IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SO IT'S GOING TO PHONE
LINES IT'S HARD TO TEST MY
OPPOSITION. I WAS GOING TO
TWELVE MONTHS IF ANYONE WANTS
TO ADD OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS
THAT JUST LIKE THE LAST VOTER I
MEAN. THE LAST PERSON WANTS THE
BILL TO GO. I EVEN FURTHER SO
AND SO THERE WE ARE SO LET'S
LET'S ON. LET'S SEE IF ANYONE
WANTS TO RAISE CONCERNS
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW-
OPPOSITION TO. SB FIVE NINE
PLEASE PRESS STAR OR ONE FALL
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZEROS
SHOW OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTY
NINE AND WE WERE LINE SIXTY
THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOUR OPEN. SIXTY THREE. FIVE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU ARE MUTED. AND THEY ARE NOT
RESPONDING. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
PARTICIPANTS. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
TO SHOW OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTY
NINE. ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
MR STERN GETTING NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS CUED UP BY SIXTY
THREE IF YOU'D LIKE TO TRY
AGAIN GO AND ONE ZERO. MAYOR
NOT QUEUING UP. NOBODY IS
KILLING OUT MICHELLE K. ARE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. OKAY WELL
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND- THIS IS READ A
WORK IN PROGRESS AND I THINK
YOU'RE HEARING THAT REFLECTED
IN SO MANY OF THE COMMENTS
INCLUDING THE OPPOSITION- AND
OF COURSE YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WE'VE HAD HERE IS
THAT WE'VE GOT OPPONENTS. OF
THE BILL WHO FEEL AS THOUGH IT
DOESN'T GO FAR ENOUGH IN OTHERS
THINGS GOES TOO FAR SO THAT'S
ALWAYS THE TRICK HERE- BUT I
WILL HAVE MORE COMMENTS TO MAKE
ABOUT THE BILL IN ITS PROCEEDS
PROGRESS SO FAR BUT LET'S START
WITH THEM WITH THE SENATE
ALLEN- BUT AS AN ADULT. WELL I
WOULD FIRST. THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR. TO BE ALWAYS TAKE ON THE
TOUGH STUFF IT SEEMS LIKE. AND
YOU KNOW WHEN I WAS IN THE
SIMPLY I WAS ON THE WORKING
GROUP WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND- IN. MY LEVEL OF
FRUSTRATION IS ABOUT THE SAME
AS THE LAST CALLERS ON IT NOT
NOT ONLY BECAUSE WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO HELP THE
COUNTIES ET WHERE THEY'RE
GOING IN THE- JURISDICTIONS-
AND THEN. IN OUR DISTRICT. I
MEAN WE JUST DID- SEVEN ONE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN DOLLY JUST DID A
TOUR TO SISKIYOU COUNTY WITH
THE NATIONAL GUARD AND- INVITED
THE- RESOURCES PEOPLE AND DGSE
TO SEE THE THOUSANDS. AND
THOUSANDS OF GROWS THAT ARE
ILLEGAL THAT WE ARE IN AN
INUNDATED WITH. TRAGIC
SITUATION AND TO TRY TO GET
THAT RECTIFIED IN THE LICENSING
PROCUREMENT PROCESS AND THE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE ON LICENSE
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE ROGUE OUT
THERE IS. I DON'T KNOW SIX
YEARS IS A LONG TIME TO. ALLOW
THIS TO CONTINUE DO YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE IN THE PROCESS
YOU YOU'RE IN THE PROCESS AND
YOU DO YOU GET TO CONTINUE ON
TO OPERATE. AND I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THE PEOPLE THE-
FOLKS WHO ARE BEEN WAITING FOR
THEIR LICENSE WHO ARE TRYING TO
LEGITIMATELY BRING. ANY ILLEGAL
PROCESS INTO A LEGAL PROCESS
FOR THE FOR FOREVER. SO I DON'T
I GUESS I'M CHANGES JUST AS
RUSTRATED AND I DON'T KNOW IF
THIS IS GOING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEMS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
ISSUE- SO WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON LIKE GETTING. THE
LICENSE IS DONE IN A MORE.
EFFICIENT MANNER IS IT WOULD
THAT BE HELPING THE COUNTIES OR
THE CITIES WITH RESOURCES. I
MEAN YOU HEARD THE GENTLEMAN
FROM THE SUPERVISOR MISTER
WILLIAMS FROM MENDOCINO WHO
SAID THEY HAD FOUR PEOPLE ONLY
NEED A HUNDRED. WE'RE GOING TO
BE BACK HERE AGAIN AND THERE
AND THERE'S- LITERALLY
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ARE JUST
SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT THE HECK
WITH I I'M JUST GONNA GO OUT
THERE. AND MAYBE PAY THE FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS UP FRONT TODAY
AFTER I THINK IT WAS FIVE
THOUSAND FOR REMEMBER CORRECTLY
FOR THE PERMIT TO GET STARTED.
AND THEN JUST. NEVER GO TO THE
COUNTY. SO WIDE I GUESS I'M
JUST FRUSTRATED AND- I DON'T
KNOW IF THIS IS A SOLUTION. TO
THE PROBLEM BECAUSE- IT JUST
CONTINUES TO GO ON WE DON'T
SEEM TO COME UP WITH A- BETTER
WAY OF GETTING IT MORE
EFFICIENTLY DONE. OKAY CENTER
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THANK YOU SENATOR
CARRIER AS WELL I THINK MY I'M
ALIGNING MY COMMENTS WITH
SENATOR DOLLY AS WELL AND JUST-
YOU KNOW THE LOCALS THAT NEED
MORE TIME AND SO CAN YOU
RESPOND A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
THE SIX YEARS IN THE SIX MONTHS
AND IF THERE'S YOU KNOW ANY
ROOM THERE FOR- DISCUSSION ON
ON EITHER. BUT LET ME JUST
MAKE- THE VERY CLEAR- THE BILL
WAS AMENDED IN RESPONSE TO SOME
COMMITTEE- COMMITTEE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED IN SO- IT
SHORTENED THE PERIOD OF TIME TO
BE ABLE TO APPLY FOR A
PROVISIONAL LICENSE TO ONE YEAR
IT'S AN EXTRA SIX MONTHS BUT
IT'S WHEN YOU'RE FROM THIS
JULY- SO THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE-
THE OPPOSITION- FROM THE
ORIGINS COUNCIL AND FROM THE-
UNITED KEPT CANNABIS
ASSOCIATION. UP TO GET TO THE
ISSUE THAT- SENATOR DOLLY
RAISED UP HERE HERE'S THE
CHALLENGE IS THAT- I THINK THE
SUPERVISOR OUTLINED IT THE BEST
THAT I'VE EVER HEARD WHICH IS
THAT THE LEAD AGENCY IS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE WAY THIS
THAT THAT THAT THE LEGALIZATION
PROCESS WAS SET UP IT PUT IT IN
THE LAPS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
DECIDE WHAT KIND OF GROWS DO
YOU WANT TO HAVE WHAT KIND OF
FACILITIES YOU WANT TO HAVE
OPEN WHAT KIND OF
MANUFACTURING- YOU SHOULD DO IN
YOUR COMMUNITY AND SO- SO THE
CHALLENGES IS THAT WE THROUGH
THIS. YOU KNOW YOU HEARD
MENDOCINO COUNTY A THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS INTO THEIR LAP AND
SAID OKAY NOW DO SEQUEL ON ALL
OF THIS THE CHALLENGES IS
THERE'S PROBABLY SOME SOME
ACTIVITY. LIKE THE- THE RETAIL
THAT DOESN'T REQUIRE A FULL
SECRET WHERE YOU CAN DO A VERY
MUCH LIKE ALCOHOL OUTLETS YOU
CAN DECIDE THROUGH AN ORDINANCE
WHERE YOU WANT THOSE TO GO BUT
WE'VE PUT SEQUEL ON EVERYTHING
IN THIS BILL DOESN'T TOUCH
SEQUEL I DIDN'T WANT TO GO INTO
THAT I YOU KNOW WHAT SICK WAS
GREAT AND IT TELLS US WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IN ORDER TO COMPLY
WITH. WITH THE RULES TO PROTECT
PEOPLE AND THE ENVIRONMENT AND
SO TO ANSWER THE QUESTION. IF
WE COULD PROBABLY GET THERE IN
FOUR YEARS BUT WE HAVE TO PUMP
A WHOLE BUNCH OF MONEY INTO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND WE'D ALSO
HAVE TO PUMP MONEY INTO OUR OWN
BECAUSE IS FISHING GAME ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO GO OUT IN
OTHER WORDS- THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS HAVE TO GET
REVIEWED AND IF THEY DON'T GET
THROUGH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PROCESS AND THEN OVER TO OUR-
STATE PROCESSES THEN WE NEED TO
FIND. THE LEGALIZATION AND PUT
RESOURCES INTO IT AND MAYBE THE
WAY TO DO IT IS TO TAKE THE TAX
REVENUE IN THE SAME IS
DEDICATED TO THIS- BUT WE BUT
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT THAT THAT IT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE MORE MONEY THIS THIS IS
JUST GOING TO TAKE TIME. AND
THEN ASSUMING. THAT WE PUMPED A
LOT OF MONEY INTO IT. WE NEED
WE'RE GONNA NEED THE THIS THE
SEQUEL EXPERTS CAN WRITE THE
REPORTS TOO SO. IT IS A IT'S A
NOT A PROBLEM. WITH THIS ONE
JUST. GIVING US SOME MORE TIME
WAS WHEN I WAS LOOKING FOR.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
CENTER COPIER AND I KNOW YOU'RE
GOING TO BE CONTINUING TO WORK
ON THIS I ABSOLUTELY AT THANK
YOU. ABSOLUTELY THIRTY DOLLARS.
WHAT IS HAVE A FALL BACK HAVE A
QUESTION THIS TIME SO I'M A
FARMER. WE THIS ISN'T THIS IS
ACT THIS IS AGRICULTURE ME I
KNOW YOU REPRESENT A DISTRICT
WHAT. WHAT I WANT TO GROW
WHATEVER I WANT TO GO I DON'T
HAVE TO DO SECRET WHY CAN'T WE
JUST GOING TO THE REGIONAL
LIKE. FARM RULES I KNOW THERE I
KNOW THAT THERE'S PROCESS
SEEING IN THAT BUT FOR THE FOR
THE ACTUAL GROW PART OF IT THAT
THEY HAVE TO BE DO THE SAME
THING THAT EVERY OTHER
AGRICULTURE. COMMUNITY WOULD DO.
IT SEEMS LIKE TO ME THE LOCAL
UP THERE DOING SEQUEL. BUT I
DON'T HAVE TO DO SECRETIVE. TO
GROW. THE THINGS I'M GROWING
WHAT WHAT WHAT WHERE'S THE
DISCONNECTION BETWEEN WHAT
AGRICULTURE DOES AND WHAT
CANNABIS IS DOING. I THINK
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION THE
CHALLENGES IS THIS IS WHAT WAS
SET UP IN THE- IN THE ORIGINAL-
BALLOT MEASURE THAT WAS PASSED.
AND SO AND SO IT WAS PART OF
THAT PART OF THE PROCESS IS
THAT WE GET IN ANALYSIS AND
PARTIALLY I BELIEVE. BECAUSE
PEOPLE THAT WERE DOING THE E.
LOCAL GROWS WERE DOING IT IN A
WAY THAT ABSOLUTELY DESTROYED
THE ENVIRONMENT. AND THAT HAD
NO REGARD FOR GOOD GOOD FARMING
PRACTICES THEY WEREN'T.
NECESSARILY WELL IT WAS IN A
LEGAL PRODUCT SO THEY DID IT
WHEREVER THEY COULD DO IT ADD
UP ALTERED STREAM BEDS. DID YOU
KNOW ALL KINDS OF PESTICIDES
APPLICATION AND SOIL MEANT AND
ALL KINDS OF THINGS THAT WERE
GOOD. I THINK THAT'S A
CHALLENGE WELL I'M I'M TELLING
YOU THAT THAT'S HAPPENING ON
STEROIDS IN MOST OF MY
DISTRICT. THE NORMAL FARMER
THIS DOWNSTREAM FROM WHOSE
LOSSES WATER IT'S GETTING
CONTAMINATED THEY'RE KILLING
FISH IS HAS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE EVERY TIME HE
DOES SOMETHING FOR DIVERSION.
GOING AFTER HIM AND THE POT
GROWER UP STRICTER WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A CIVIL WAR OUT THERE
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT TO COME UP
WITH SOME BETTER PROCESS. THAN
WHAT WE HAVE NOW BECAUSE THE
ILLEGAL PEOPLE ARE. JUST
RUNNING RAMPANT AND PEOPLE WHO
ARE TRYING TO FORM LEGALLY ARE
GETTING HAMMERED BY DF THE
DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE IN
UNIT FOR A WATER QUALITY AND
ALL THOSE THINGS SO. WHAT WE
NEED TO GET IT UNDER THE GUISE
AYE AYE GIVE SUMMIT COULD I CAN
LOOK AT PROP FIFTY FOUR OR
SIXTY FOUR WHICH OF WHICH NINE
AND FIGURE OUT WHAT IT'S.
ACTUALLY SAID BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE TO ME. WE SHOULD ALLOW IT.
IT TO BE FARM ANY OTHER
COMMODITIES FORMED. AND
REGULATED THE SAME AS WELL
EXCEPT FOR THE DISTRIBUTION
SIDE OF IT WHICH WOULD THEN
WOULD BE. SOMETHING LIKE WE
HAVE WITH A. B. C. WITH ALCOHOL
ON THE IN THE- RETAIL SPACE.
YEAH BT LET ME LET ME JUST
DEGREE WITH THE SENATOR YOU
KNOW THE UFC RIGHT THIS IS SET
OUT IN SIXTY FOUR. I THINK WAS
DONE IN A TIME WHEN THE A THIS
WAS A BITTERLY BRAND NEW
INDUSTRY WAS STILL ILLEGAL AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT WE NEED TO DO A
DEEP DIVE INTO THIS SPACE AND
DECIDE WHAT KINDS OF CANNABIS
RELATED PROJECTS. MERIT C. CORE
VIEW AND WENT DOWN I MEAN
THERE'S A LOT A LITTLE POT
SHOPS THAT JUST OPENED UP- FOR
YOU TO SMALL SMALL OPERATIONS
THAT ARE JUST DON'T. REALLY
SHOULD BE SUBSEA QUEST. ARE YOU
BROUGHT UP SOME GREAT CONCERNS
THE OTHER COURSE ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE HERE IS THAT THE REALLY
BAD ACTORS. ARE TYPICALLY UNDER
THE UNDER THE RADAR THE
OPERATING UNDERGROUND AND NOT
COMPLYING WITH THE SYSTEM AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY.
I MEAN IT IS ONE OF THE YEAH
WE'VE DELVED INTO THIS ISSUE
WHICH IS NOT IN A- POLICY
EXPERTISE FOR ME BUT- IN THE-
CONTEXT OF THIS BILL- YOU YOU
REALLY GET INTO SOME. DIFFICULT
PUBLIC POLICY. CONUNDRUM AS YOU
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE PUT A
REGULATORY SYSTEM IN PLACE IT'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO- ENCOURAGED
THE BEST BEHAVIOR AND NOT. AND
NOT PUSH PEOPLE ON THE GROUND I
THINK YOU HEARD THAT WITH SOME
OF THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
A LITTLE EARLIER I KNOW THIS IS
THE ISSUE WE HAVE WITH TAXATION
AND JUST THAT THE- THE BLACK
MARKET IN THIS IN THIS AREA IN
GENERAL SO- THIS IS A- THIS IS
A BILL THAT IS GOOD. THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY HILL FOR CAN
PROGRESS I DON'T THINK I DON'T
THINK THE AUTHOR WITH DAD. YEAH
CLAIMED THE BUSINESS BAKED AT
THIS POINT. YOU KNOW. WE'VE GOT
A LOT OF DIFFERENT. FOLKS WHO
ARE PRESERVING THIS
CONVERSATION LABOR.
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY- SMALL
GROWERS BIG GROWERS- SMALL AND
LARGE- RETAIL. OUR CITIES BREAK
IS A LOT OF CITIES HAVE NOW
COME UP WITH THEIR OWN. FIVE
REGULATORY AS A PROVISIONAL
LICENSE SYSTEMS AND SOME OF
THEM ONCE MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
SEEK THOSE LICENSES PLAY OUT-
YOU KNOW I WOULD SO I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TO DATE
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
AUTHOR IS VERY COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND TO SEE IF WE
CAN AND CAN'T- COME UP ITH
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO BE
LOGICAL BUT I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY THINKS OF THIS BILL IS-
READY TO. TO MOVE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK AT THIS POINT
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE
DONE. AND EVEN. AS A LOT OF
WORK BEYOND THIS BILL- YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS I HEAR
FROM SOME OF THE OPPONENTS IS
THAT WELL LET'S. EXTEND OUT THE
PROVISIONAL LICENSE PROGRAM FOR
A PERIOD OF TIME IT'S LESS THAN
SIX YEARS NOT BECAUSE- THEY
ARE. ENORMOUS SEQUEL ACOLYTES
OF BECAUSE THEY ACTUALLY WANT
TO HAVE A BROADER REVIEW OF THE
EXTENT TO WHICH WERE APPLYING
SECRETIVE VARIOUS. PROJECTS AND-
THE OTHER THING I THINK THE
REMOTE COMMUNITY TO GRAPPLE
WITH IS- THE FACT THAT THE IF
THE APPLICATION SEQUIN THIS
SPACE IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN-
WITH. THE CONSTRUCTION OF A-
MAJOR BUILDING IN FREMONT- LOS
ANGELES AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ACTORS THAT ARE- YOU DON'T EVEN
NEED A THAT ARE THAT ARE NOT
GUILTY IT WAS OFF THE GRID
SOMETIMES AND SO AB. SO- SO
THANK YOU FOR STEPPING INTO
THIS IS THAT WONDERFUL CAN OF
WORMS SENATOR I'M CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR YOUR YOUR
EFFORTS TO TRY TO. SOLVE SOME
OF THESE VERY KNOTTY ISSUES-
PUN INTENDED I SUPPOSE- AND-
BUT BUT BUT THIS IS THE WE HAVE
A LOT OF WORK TO DO ON THIS
BILL AND I CERTAINLY CONTINUE
TO EXPECT ROBUST COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT TIME ON THIS BILL IF
IT WAS FOR TODAY. ANYWAY SO
DEJECTED. OKAY DO YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS OR ANYTHING ON IT
SAYS I COUNTY I JUST HOPE THAT
WE DON'T FORGET TO CONSUMERS AT
THE END OF THE DAY TELL TELL ME
MARTIN SAID HIS SERPENT WE
WE'VE WE'RE WORRIED I MEAN. THE
TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS PROP
SIXTY FOUR SO PRESCRIPTIVE THAT
YOU JUST WANT TO PULL YOUR HAIR
OUT. HEY JUST SO YOU KNOW I.
MEAN I KNOW THE ADVOCATES THINK
IT'S THE GREATEST THING IN THE
WORLD. THIS IS. IS THAT PROMOTE
LEGISLATORS POINT OF VIEW
THERE'S SO MUCH NONSENSE AND
BENSALEM. SO MANY THINGS THAT
ARE AND WORKABLE THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO MAKE IT WORK BUT-
I'LL- ALL MOVED BILL LONG I.
UNDERSTAND SORT OF A WORK IN
PROGRESS STAY. HERE YES THAT'S
RIGHT- BIG WOULD YOU WOULD YOU
MENTION CONSUMERS'S OUR
PARTICULAR SHE THINK WE NEED TO
BE. WELL IT'S MOSTLY CONSUMERS
OUR SOPHISTICATED AT LEAST
SURVIVE THAT CAN'T SPEAK FOR
THE WHOLE STATE BUT BUT THE ONE
PRODUCT THEY WANT PRODUCT
THAT'S FRESH THEY ONE PRODUCT
FROM DIRECTLY HE SELECTED. THE
OF THE BEER INDUSTRY WHERE THEY
KNOW THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
GROWING THIS GROWING THE
PRODUCT AND THEY WANTED AND I
REGULATIONS HAVE SORT OF MADE
IT A ONE YEAR JOURNEY. AND YOU
KNOW THE PEOPLE THAT REALLY
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON THERE
WAITING FOREVER TO GET TO GET
TO GO THROUGH ALL THE LOOPS AND
MAKE SURE THE TAX RETURN AND
IT'S NOT A SURPRISE THAT A LOT
OF FOLKS ARE TO STAY IN THE
GREAT SOUND AND JUST ST
ASSISTANCE. JUST DOESN'T WORK
AND WE HAVE TO TRY TO GET SOME
MARRIAGE BETWEEN BETWEEN THOSE
FOLKS AND BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE
CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE DOING IT
THERE'S A LOT OF. YOU KNOW BIG
INDUSTRY DOES COMING IN THAT'S
WORK ON THAT AND THAT'S ANOTHER
ELEMENT OF HERE IT'S NOT
SPECIFICALLY BROUGHT UP
CONSISTENCY Q. BUT THERE'S
THAT'S ANOTHER ELEMENT THAT'S
GOING ON SO. IT ALL BUT CERTAIN
TO WORK CONCERT. SKINNER WELL.
I. IF MY PHONE'S NOT OKAY. IT
BEFORE AND IT DIDN'T TURN RED-
I CAN'T SPEAK FOR IF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FREMONT WAS IF
THIS WAS PART OF WHAT HE WAS
INTENDING BUT I'M GOING TO
ASSUME YES WHEN HE SAYS CONCERN
FOR THE CONSUMER AND THAT IS
THAT. WE THE VOTERS PASSED
SIXTY FOUR AND YES IT'S BUT YOU
KNOW I THINK CASH OVERLY
COMPLICATED BUT THE FEELING
PROBABLY WAS BY THE DRAFTERS
THAT IT NEEDED TO BE BECAUSE
THE PREVIOUS- OUR PROPOSITION
DID NOT SUCCEED AND SO YOU KNOW
OF THE PRIDE TRIED TO CROSS
EVERY T. AND DOT EVERY I TOO
MUCH. SO MEANWHILE THE VOTERS
OF SAID WE WANTED LEGAL WE
WANTED ACCESSIBLE WE WANTED
LEGAL. AND WE WANT YOU KNOW
WHEN WE'D LIKE A CALIFORNIA
INDUSTRY BUT WE HAVE TO THIS
DAY. THREE OUT OF EVERY FOUR
DOLLARS SPENT ON CANNABIS IN
CALIFORNIA IS IN THE ILLICIT
MARKET. SO WE WANT TO. DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO SUPPORT
THE LEGAL MARKET. AND THAT'S
HOW I TAKE WHAT SENATOR CAFIERO
YOU KNOW HER INTENTIONS. AND
SO. AND THAT'S WHERE I FEEL
LIKE WE DO NEED TO. BE- IF WITH
THE CONSUMERS IN MIND WILL BE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN BOTH
THE CONSUMER IN MIND AND THOSE
BUSINESSES THAT PLAY BY THE
RULES WILL BE DOING EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO SUPPORT THE LEGAL
MARKET. BECAUSE OTHERWISE OUR
ACTIONS ARE IN EFFECT- WRAPPING
UP THE ILLICIT MARKET. ALL
RIGHT ALL RIGHT SO V. ITEM HAS
BEEN MOVED IF AT CENTER LIKE TO
CLOSE ALL ADULT THAT IS MY
CLOTHES I THINK THAT'S THE BEST
STATEMENT THAT- THAT CAN BE
SAID WHICH IS THAT REALLY WHAT
WE WANT IS WE WANT TO BRING
EVERYBODY INTO THAT THE LEGAL
MARKET AND THE MORE THAT WE
MAKE IT HARD FOR THEM TO DO
THAT THAT. THE MORE WE'RE GONNA
END UP WITH CONFLICT AROUND THE
WHOLE ISSUE AND THE TO GET BACK
TO US SENATOR DOLLY IS THAT WE
SHOULD TALK ABOUT MONEY FOR
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE THE
QUESTION JEFF THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THERE ARE LEGAL
GROWS THAT ARE DECIMATING THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND WE NEED TO PUT
THEM OUT OF BUSINESS AND- BUT
GIVE PEOPLE A PATHWAY TO BE
ABLE TO BECOME LEGAL SO I
COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE I
MEAN IT IS A HUGE PROBLEM OUT
AND MANY PARTS OF STATE
NECESSARY AND I THINK THAT WE
HAVE A SHARED AGENDA TO.
PREVENT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEVASTATION IT'S BEING ROBBED
BY SOME OF THESE INCREDIBLY
RESPONSIBLE FARMERS- AND REALLY
HARMING OTHERS GOOD FARMERS SO
LET'S LET'S WORK TOGETHER ON
THAT I KNOW YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT
THE SUBJECT HERE AS WELL AND
pBUDGET CHAIR HAS FOUL SO- LET'S
LET'S WORK ON THAT AND DEAL
WITH THAT UNDERSTANDING ON
CERTAIN HABITS FOR THE BILL
TODAY IN. A SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
FIFTY NINE MY SENATOR KABBADI
EURO THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN HI I BATES. RIGHT BATES
I'D DALY. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
SKINNER. AYE SKINNER AYE STERN.
I CASKEY HI AWSKI. HI I'M THE
CHAIR WILL ENTERTAIN WILL CAST
HIS VOTE. IN SPITE OF IS THE
REGULAR. BEHAVIOR SO WILL WILL-
IT WILL TAKE YOU COULD YOU
SENATOR I WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OF AN FOR AND- FOR DOLLY TO
I'VE CHANGES MIND. THANK YOU SO
MUCH OKAY. GREAT ALL RIGHT
LET'S NOW LET'S LET'S- WHAT
WHILE WE CLEAN UP THE DESK AND
FOR SENATE DOT APPROACH LET'S
LET'S SAY BETWEEN A MOTION FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. OUR MOVE.
SO MOVED PICTURE PLEASE CALL US
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ITEM NUMBER
TEN ALLEN HI. BATES HI EIGHT HI
DALLY. KELLY CONTENT AND SEVEN
CENTS HI SALLY I'D GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I SKINNER AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN THANK YOU FOR. I ART
BY CASKEY. DISTRACTED BY CASSIE
I. IT'S GOOD IT'S YOU'RE STILL
CLINGING TO YOUR POSITION ON
THIS COMMITTEE SENATE- IT'S FUN
TO WATCH OKAY SO IT'S NO GOOD
ITEM SIXTEEN YEARS AND AS
MEMBERS THIS IS A- SENATOR
DODD'S BILL FOR FIFTY ONE TALK
ABOUT A WORK IN PROGRESS. HERE
WE ARE AGAIN- SO AS YOU MAY YOU
MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL. SUPPORT
WELL RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR
HELLO THIS IS GERMAN. SB FIFTY
ONE WOULD AUTHORIZE CAL RECYCLE
TO ESTABLISH A THREE YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM THAT WILL GIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONSIDER REFORMS
OF THE CURRENT CALIFORNIA'S
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PROGRAM THE CURRENT BOTTLE BILL
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED MORE
THAN THIRTY YEARS AGO IT
DESPITE ITS MANY SUCCESSES OVER
THE YEARS IT'S NOW FACING
UNDENIABLE CHALLENGES. THE
RECYCLING RATES OF FALL FROM
85% 200013276% IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WITH GLASS FALLING
DOWN 265% 66% SKEWS ME. THE C.
R. V. PROGRAM COSTLY RUNS IN
THE DEFICITS OF RECYCLING RATES
HAVE CONTINUED TO DECLINE DUE
TO THE CLOSURE OF RECYCLING
CENTERS. MAKING IT DIFFICULT
FOR CALIFORNIANS TO RETURN
THEIR USE CONTAINERS. THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS
ONLY HIGHLIGHTED THE EXT THE
EXTENT TO WHICH CALIFORNIANS DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO RECYCLING
CENTERS IN TIMES WHEN THEY NEED
THEIR DEPOSIT BACK. MORE THAN
EVER. S. B. FOUR FIFTY ONE
ADDRESSES THOSE ISSUES BY
DEVELOPING A FRAMEWORK FOR A
PILOT PROJECT. THAT WOULD ALLOW
THE PARTICIPATION OF MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS AND PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE PILOT
PROGRAM TO IMPLEMENT VARIOUS
METHODS WE HAVE LEARNED FROM
THE- EXPERIENCE OF OTHER.
COUNTRIES IN THEIR SIX US.
SPECIFICALLY THE PILOT PROGRAM
WILL ACHIEVE A MINIMUM 80%
RECYCLING RATE FOR BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS EXTEND THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR ALL BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS TO BE RECYCLED.
INCLUDING WINE AND SPIRITS
CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM OPERATOR
THAT WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE HANDLING. ALSO SEE METHOD
OF ALL BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
DESIGNER KERBSIDE COLLECTION
SYSTEM AND CREATE A SPECIFIC
BEVERAGE CONTAINER BEEN THAT
WILL HELP INCREASE CONSUMER
CONVENIENCE. GIVE CAL RECYCLES
ABILITY TO PICK UP BOTH
APPROVED THE THREE YEAR PLAN IT
ALL OUT OF THE RESULTS. THIS
TYPE OF PROGRAM IS WELL SUITED
TO HELP INFORM US ON HOW
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO BE A
LEADER IN THIS AREA. I'M ALSO
PROUD TO HAVE THE WINE
INSTITUTE REPRESENTING NOT ONLY
A VERY IMPORTANT INDUSTRY IN
OUR STATE BUT ALSO PRODUCT
MANUFACTURER IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. TO ACHIEVE OUR GOALS WE
NEED AN INDUSTRY TO BE
CONSTRUCTIVE. COLLAPSE WE NEED
INDUSTRY TO BE CONSTRUCTED
COLLABORATOR COLLABORATORS AND
PARTICIPANTS IN OUR EFFORTS.
I'M AWARE THAT THIS BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM STILL NEEDS A LOT
MORE WORK AND I'M COMMITTED TO
PIVOT SB FOUR FIFTY ONE TO MORE
SUBSTANTIVE AND IMPLEMENTABLE
BILL AS A CONVERSATION DEVELOPS
WAS STAKEHOLDERS- I'M ALSO
COMMITTED TO BRING THE BILL
BACK THIS BILL BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE- WHAT I AM IN THE
BILL WOULD MORE SUBSTANTIVE
LANGUAGE. WITH ME TODAY IS TIM
SCHMELZER FROM THE WINE
INSTITUTE. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. IN PERSON.
ARE YOU DOING I HAVEN'T BEEN
HERE AWHILE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- TIM SCHMELZER
WITH WINE INSTITUTE AND WE
REPRESENT OVER A THOUSAND
MEMBERS THROUGHOUT- CALIFORNIA
AND WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR FIFTY ONE THIS MORNING.
ONE INSTITUTE WELCOMES THE
GREATER FOCUS ON EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE RECYCLING CALIFORNIA.
AND OUR MEMBERS ARE COMMITTED
TO MAKING EFFORTS TO DO JUST
THAT AND TO BE IN RESPONSIBLE
STAKEHOLDERS AN IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION THIS WAY LEGISLATORS
HAVING. TO CREATE A TRULY
CIRCULAR ECONOMY REGARDING
PACKAGING AND THE CONTAINERS
THAT DELIVER OUR PRODUCTS TO
CONSUMERS. AS SEVERAL MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE NOW OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS THE WINE
INDUSTRY IS COMMITTED
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES BOTH
FINANCIAL AS WELL AS TIME AND
ENERGY. TO EXPLORING WAYS IN
WHICH WE CAN ASSIST CALIFORNIA
INCREASING TO INCREASE THE
RECYCLING OF OUR PRODUCT
CONTAINERS. ARE SUPPORT FOR
THIS MEASURE IS JUST ONE OF THE
WAYS IN WHICH WE'RE
DEMONSTRATING OUR COMMITMENT TO
THIS EFFORT. AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED SB FOUR FIFTY ONE WOULD
AUTHORIZE CALL RECYCLE TO
IMPLEMENT A PILOT PROJECT.
WHICH WOULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO
APPLY TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
TECHNOLOGY AS WELL AS LESSONS
LEARNED FROMACTUAL BEVERAGE
RECYCLING PROGRAMS IN OTHER
COUNTRIES. TO DEMONSTRATE HOW
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP APPROACH
WHICH INVOLVES PRODUCT
MANUFACTURERS AS WELL AS
STAKEHOLDERS CAN BE SUCCESSFUL.
WE BELIEVE. THE CRITERION FOR
FIFTY ONE FOR THE PILOT
PROJECT. CAN DEMONSTRATE
MEANINGFUL WAYS THAT WE CAN
INCREASE RECYCLING OF BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS IN CALIFORNIA. IN
ADDITION THE BILL BOTH
ESTABLISHES GOALS FOR THE
PROJECT IN A MEANS TO EVALUATE
ITS SUCCESS. WE ARE COMMITTED
TO BEING CONSTRUCTIVE
COLLABORATORS IN THIS IMPORTANT
STATE AND STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
GOALS AND THE PILOT PROGRAM AND
THAT THAT'S BEFORE FIFTY ONE.
WE INTEND TO BE FULLY COMMITTED
PARTICIPANTS IN THIS EFFORT.
FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON S. B. FOUR
FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU JIM. ALL
RIGHT. LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO VISIT SO
TEMAS ARE ONLY AND LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESS. DON'T SEE ONE HERE IN
PERSON OR IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WANT TO WEIGH INON THE BILL
AND SUPPORT COMMUTER THE PHONE
LINES ANYONE WANTS TO. EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
OUR S. B. FOUR FIFTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
ALSO WE DID HAVE ONE PERSON
THAT QUEUED UP. FOR THE LAST
BILL I DON'T THINK THAT GOT HER
DOES HAVE PROBLEMS THAT. WILL
OPEN UP WILL GO UP IN THEIR
LIFE HERE WE GO. A LINE SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
COMMITTEE STURNIDAE GEOSCIENCE.
WELCOME THE BURNING ALSO
APPEARED BUT JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS OUR POSITION ON THE LOS
SPOKE BUT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IT
WITH THE OPERATOR THANK YOU.
NEXT TO A LINE SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DISAPPEARANCE
SENATORS GET THE MILLION ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN BEVERAGE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR FIFTY ONE THANK YOU. FIND
FORTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN VERSUS TONY
GONZALEZ REPRESENTING TOM AND
YOURS MEREKA WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SB FOUR FIFTY ONE IN
CONCEPT AND SENATOR DODD
MENTIONED THERE ARE ISSUES THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AND- HOLD
TO BE FILLED- BUT ONE POINT
WE'D LIKE TO MAKE IS THAT THIS
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW TO
INTEGRATE. WINE AND LIQUOR INTO
A COLLECTION SYSTEMS FIVE
HAPPENING IN OTHER STATES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY OREGON
NEW YORK VERMONT AND OTHERS IN
JUST ONE ISSUE WOULD LIKE TO
LEAVE WITH THE COMMITTEE- FOR
NOW WITH THE BILL IF THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD INTO THAT- VIDAK:
CENTERS ARE SEEN AS THE ARE
REALLY THE ANSWER TO COLLECTING
WINE PRIMARILY THE ISSUE RIGHT
ONE INCLUDING A LIQUOR BOTTLES.
OF THE ISSUE IS CERTAINLY
IMPLEMENTATION AND BREAKAGE I'M
SO SORRY WE HAVE TO RECORD
RIGHT NOW AND I DO LOVE LOVED
LOVE TALK TOMORROW BYE BYE
CENTERS AYE AYE. WITH RESPECT
THIS WE'RE NOW UNDERSTAND
PEOPLE DECIDING THEIR THEIR
THEIR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
WITH THEIR NAME AFFILIATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR INPUT.
ANNEX WE WERE GO TO- SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON BEHALF
OF NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RIGHT GOOD JOB AND THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME OKAY ALL RIGHT- NOW
WE WILL GO TO ANY OPPOSITION WE
DON'T HAVE ANY LISTED LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION BUT AS
ANYONE WE DON'T ANY RETRO
POSITION I DON'T SEE IT ON YOUR
PERSON OR IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
I WANTED TESTIFYING OPPOSITION
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL.
BUT IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES. MODERATOR CHILL
THANK YOU TO SHOW OPPOSITION
FOR SB FOUR FIFTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS STAR FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
THE INITIAL OPPOSITION TO SB
FOUR FIFTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO I APOLOGIZE
ONE FILED BY ZERO. ANDTHE
FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO SHOWOPPOSITION TO S. B.
FOUR FIFTY ONE. I KNOW THERE'S
NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION SO AND-
BUT YOU SURE NOBODY IS GIVING
UP OKAY ARE YOU THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MODERATOR AND THANK
YOU MR- THAT FOR YOU SENATE
DOT. SO THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A
SPACE THAT TIME IT IS WASTE
MANAGEMENT I SPACE NUMBER OF US
HAVE TAKEN A LOT OF INTERESTING
I'VE ACTUALLY GOT SB THIRTY
FOUR COMING UP BY BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE AND- TODAY WE ARE
RECEIVE- WHEN WORKING WITH
SENATE WHAT KASKY ON ON HIS-
RELATING TO THE BOTTOM BILL SO
I JUST WANT TO SAY- FROM THE
OUTSET THAT I. YOU KNOW I'M
SUPPORT OF THE BILL MOVING OUT
OF COMMITTEE TODAY I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOU. TRYING TO THINK
OUTSIDE THE BOX. WITH REGARDS
TO A PROVIDING ALTERNATIVE TO
THE CURBSIDE COLLECTION
PROGRAM- BY THINK. ONE OF THE
THINGS IT'S BECOME SO
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR TO ME AS I'VE
GOTTEN DEEPER INTO THIS POLICY
MAKING AREA- CURBSIDE.
CONTAMINATION ISSUES. THE BIG
ISSUE. ARE YOU KNOW. WE'RE
SINGLE STREAMING EVERYTHING
GLASS AB. BIZ BOTH IT WILL IT
BOTH. GETS CONTAMINATED BY
IT'S- IT'S HARDER TO RECYCLE
GLASS GIVEN THE CURRENT
SITUATION. WITH WITH SINGLE
STREAMING AND IT ALSO THE GLASS
WHEN IT BREAKS UP AND UP
CONTAMINATING IN FACT BECOMING
A DANGER. TO BE HONEST- WITHOUT
WITH OTHER RECYCLABLE MATERIALS.
SO I'M I'M REALLY HOPEFUL THAT
YOUR BILL WILL HELP TO START
THE CONVERSATION ON HOW TO FIX
THAT. NOW A WE SEE EVEN SEE
FROM THE COMMENTS OF THE BIG
BILL AND YET THERE DOESN'T SEEM
TOBE A LOT OF STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT YET I THINKS PEOPLE
STILL TRY TO FIGURE OUT. WHAT
THE BILL DOES. STAFFREPORT.
TALKS ABOUT HOW THERE'S LOTS.
OF WORK TO BE DONE ON THE BILL
LOTS OF QUESTIONS. I THINK
UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES- YOU
KNOW WE WOULD ASK THE AUTOR TO
CONSIDER MAKING THE BILL IT TO
YOUR BILL- TO GIVE THE AUTHOR
MORE TIME TO WORK THINGS OUT
ENGAGE WITH A VERY
STAKEHOLDERS. AND OF COURSE I
THINK NOT ONLY IS IT POSSIBLE
IT'S PERHAPS LIKELY THAT IT
WILL BE A TO YOUR BILL- JUST
GIVEN THE ENORMITY OF THE
ISSUES YOU'RE TRYING TO. DEAL
WITH AND HOW IT INTERPLAY'S
WITH OTHER WORK THAT'S
HAPPENING THAT BEING SAID. YOUR
BREAK YOU'RE BRINGING UP
IMPORTANT IMPORTANT ISSUES AND
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
REASON WHY- IF THE STARS ALIGN
WE CAN'T GET MEANINGFUL POLICY
TOGETHER EVEN THIS YEAR- IN
THIS IN THIS SPACE. I'M NOT I
ALSO IMAGINE IT IS MORE THE
PROVISIONS GET FLUSHED OUT
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE MORE
STAKEHOLDERS. WAY AND BECOME
MORE. INVOLVED OBVIOUSLY THERE
IS ENORMOUS QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN THIS BILL
IN THE CURRENT BOTTLE BILL
pCHANGES THE BOTTLE BILL. WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO ON. YOU
KNOW UNDERMINE. OR ON INTENSELY
DISMANTLE. SPEAKING OF BOTH
EXISTING AND FUTURE EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE THIS IMPORTANT
RECYCLING PROGRAM FOR MANY
ENTITIES ITS CERTAINLY THE
MODELS NOT A PERFECT BILL WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THAT A LOT OF THIS
COMMITTEE- BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
GOOD THERE AND NOW WE DON'T
WANT TO UNDERMINE IT. AT THE
GOOD STUFF. SO I'M CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO- IN SUPPORT YOUR
EFFORTS VAIN. IN DRIVING THIS
CONVERSATION I KNOW I GUESS FOR
ME THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS
YOUR COMMITMENT TO YOUR STAFF
WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR STAFF.
AND THAT YOU AND I WERE
TOGETHER IN THE WORK OF THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE- THE
PILOT PROGRAM IS. FOR YOUPROPOSES COMPLICATED I THINK IT
NEEDS TO BE APPROACHED IN A
THOUGHTFUL MANNER NOT RUSH
THROUGH- QUICKLY AND SO IT'S
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING THAT I'M-
TIME I'M GONNA GO FOR THE BILL-TODAY- BUT- BUT YOU KNOW IT'S
EYES WIDE OPEN GIVEN HOW MUCH
WORK IS STILL YET TO BE DONE
IN- IN FLUSHING OUT. THE
DETAILS OF THIS BILL AND ITS
INTERACTION WITH OTHER BOTH
CURRENT. LAW AND ALSO
INTERACTION WITH OTHER BILLS
THAT ARE MAKING THEIR WAY
THROUGH SO. ARE THEY WITH THAT
COMMENT I LOVE TO OPEN UP TO
THE COMMITTEE AND GET PEOPLE
START TO QUESTIONS OR- ANYTHING
THEY WANT TO RAISE WITH THE
SENATOR. ASSEMBLY CASKEY. AND
ALSO SEE MYSELF WITH THE
CHAIR'S COMMENTS I WILL. MOVE
THE BILL TODAY KNOWING IT'S
WORK IN PROGRESS WANT TO
CONTINUE WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
WITH THE SPIRITS AND WINE- HUH
THE FOLKS AS WELL AS THE
BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION ON THIS
AND I'M MINDFUL OF. THE
ASPECTED SUB COMMITTEE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO THE BUDGET WILL
PLAY WITH CAL RECYCLE EFFECT OF
ANY- CHANGES SO WITH THAT I'LL
JUST. KEEP ON MARKET. THIRTY
SEVEN. AT THE END I SEE I KNOW
USE WHICH REST TO ME PRIVATELY
BUT I'D LOVE IF YOU KNOW IF YOU
WANT TO REITERATE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO- A PUBLIC TO OUR
OUR ROBUST ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR
COMMITTEE LOS. THAT COULD BE
GIVEN THE CLOSE OKAY WELL LET'S
LET YOU CLOSE AYE AYE. I HEAR
THE MOTION FOR SARAH CASKEY.
PUTS YOU CLOSE FOR SMOG
KNOWLEDGE THE COULD THAT REALLY
ASTUTE COMMENTS THAT DID THE
CHAIR IS MADE. IT ON THIS ISSUE
IT IS A WORK IN PROGRESS I
APPRECIATE THE CONFIDENCE THAT
THE COMMITTEE. HAS HAS SHOWN-
THE CHAIR SHOWN IN- I DO COMMIT
TO- YOU'LL BRING THIS BACK HERE
WITH ANY SUBJECT COMMENTS I
TOLD CHAIR THAT. HE CAN CALL AS
FAR AS I'M CONCERNED- YOU KNOW.
GIVE ME THIS CONSIDERATION TO
CONTINUE MOVING THIS AND
WORKING ON IT IS WORK BRING IT
BACK HERE IF WE- ARE ABLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND MAKE SOME- YOU
KNOW AMENDMENTS THAT- REALLY
MAKES SENSE FOR THE PEOPLE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR-
THANK YOU CENTER THANK YOU. I
STARTED CALL THE ROLL ON A FOUR
FIFTY ONE I DO NUMBER SIX AS
BEFORE FIFTY ONE BY SENATOR
DODD THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN HI HI DAVID FIVE EIGHT
FOUR EIGHT HI DELHI. AND NOW I
IT'S ALL. I DOLLARS HIGH
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE STERN
TONIGHT KERN I WHITE HOUSE BY.
OKAY AND WE EVEN HAVE A SUMMER
CASKEY. VOTE OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR- PRETTY SURE.
AND EVEN I I'VE I HAVE THE
CHANCE TO GO OVER THE MADERA
BOTTLING FACILITY GALLO WHERE
THEY WITH A- WHERE THEY THEY
MELT THE- AND LEAVE OUT THE
GLASS DOWNSIZING EXPERIENCE
OCCURRED TO ANYONE TO DO IT-
BUT I LOVE THE FACT THAT YOUR
YOUR- YOUR- YOUR YOUR BILL
NUMBER IS FOUR FIFTY ONE WHICH
IS ASSOCIATED WITH. FIRE AND-
FAHRENHEIT INTO HEAT SO. YES
YES YES THERE'S A BOOK ALL
ABOUT IT SO ANYHOW WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING WILL MOVE I THINK
YOU SENATOR LET'S GO TO CENTER
ARCHULETA LET'S GO TO SB SIX
SIXTY TWO. NOT GONNA TALK ABOUT
ANOTHER TOPIC. HYDROGEN
HYDROGEN CENTER TO LET HIS
FAVORITE. FAVORITE ENERGY
SOURCE. ARE YOU MAY PRESENT
WHEN READING CENTERS HERE. I'VE
I'VE GOT A LETTER THAT- I'D
LIKE TO GET TO EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU BEFORE I BEGAN.
BECAUSE IT PERTAINS TO YOUR OWN-PERSONAL DISTRICTS. AND ALSO
REMOVES AND- VERY IMPORTANT
OPPOSITION. AND I'LL WAIT A
SECOND IF YOU DON'T MIND MISTER
CHAIR. BEFORE I BEGIN.
AND
THERE'S SOME ITEMS IN THE BACK
AS WELL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN ALLEN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT SENATE BILL FOUR
SIX SIX TWO I'M SORRY SIX SIX
TWO. SENATE BILL SIX SIX TWO IS
A VERY IMPORTANT BILL I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR AT LAST A FEW
YEARS AND IT TAKES THE FIRST
STEP TOWARDS ALLOWING UTILITY
INVESTMENT IN HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE. MORE
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL ALLOWS
INVESTOR OWNED GAS UTILITIES TO
INVEST IN THE DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE OF HYDROGEN
TRANSPORTATION FUEL. IN ORDER
TO ACCELERATE THE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE TRANSFER TOTIENT AT
TRANSPORTATION ONLY IF THOSE
PROJECTS DO NOT RESULT IN COST
SHIFTS IN CUSTOMER RAGE OR
RESULT IN A NET INCREASE TO
ENERGY SECTOR EMISSIONS. BEFORE
GOING ANY FURTHER I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK CHAIRMAN ALAN AND HIS
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL AND WORKING
WITH ME I APPRECIATE IT THANK
YOU SO MUCH VERY MUCH. I ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS MENTION OF THE
BOTTOM PAGE SIX THE ANALYSIS
AND COMMIT TO WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO WORK OUT ANY REMAINING
ISSUES. IN TWENTY FIFTEEN. WHEN
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY THE
CLEAN ENERGY AND POLLUTION
REDUCTION ACT WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW BY GOVERNOR BROWN. IT
MARKED A FUNDAMENTAL SHIFT. IN
HOW THE STATE WOULD INVEST IN
ELECTRIFY IN OUR ROADS. IN FACT
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY
MANDATED THAT ELECTRICAL
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES INVEST
IN THE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR PLUG IN BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. HOWEVER NO SIMILAR
PROGRAM EXIST FOR INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO
SUPPORT HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. HYDROGEN
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES
LIKE ALL ELECTRIC VEHICLES USED
ELECTRICITY TO POWER AN
ELECTRIC MOTOR. HOWEVER IN
CONTRAST TO OTHER ELECTRIC
VEHICLES FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES PRODUCE ELECTRICITY
USING A FUEL CELL POWERED BY
HYDROGEN RATHER THAN DRAWING
ELECTRICITY FROM ONLY A BATTERY.
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ARE STILL AN EMERGING
TECHNOLOGY. BUT FOR THE
TECHNOLOGY TO GROW CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO FOCUS ON TWO MAIN
PRIORITIES. ONE BRINGING DOWN
THE PRICE OF HYDROGEN FUEL AND
TO MAKE IT HARDER TO FEEL MORE
READILY AVAILABLE THIS BILL
SENATE BILL SIX SIX TWO WHAT
DIRECTLY ACCOMPLISH THE SECOND
GOAL OF MAKING HYDROGEN MORE
READILY AVAILABLE. BY ALLOWING
GAS INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES TO
BEGIN TO INVEST IN HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE WE CAN BEGIN TO
ELECTRIFY SECTORS THAT HAVE
TRADITIONALLY BEEN HARD TO
ELECTRIFY FOR EXAMPLE BUS TRUCK
FLEET SUPPORT SHIPS AVIATION
AND OTHER HEAVY DUTY SECTORS TO
NAME JUST A FEW. SOME CONCERNS
WERE BROUGHT UP- HEADING INTO
THIS COMMITTEE AND I HAVE
AGREED TO ACCEPT AMENDMENTS
RESOLVING THEIR CONCERNS. AS
MENTIONED ON PAGE SIX OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS TWO WEEKS
AGO IN STATE ENERGY COMMITTEE I
ACCEPTED TWO VERY IMPORTANT
AMENDMENTS ONE A PROVISION
WHICH WAS ADDED. THAT MANDATES
THAT THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION COULD NOT
APPROVE A PROJECT THAT WOULD
NOT RESULT THAT WOULD RESULT IN
COST SHIPS OR CUSTOMER RAGE.
THIS MEANS THAT ONLY IT
ENTITIES WHO WOULD BENEFIT FROM
THE NEW HYDROGEN PROJECTS WOULD
PAVE FOR THE HYDROGEN PROJECTS
AND TO. ANOTHER ADDITIONAL
PROVISION WAS ADDED THAT
MANDATED THAT THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
COULD NOT APPROVE ANY PROJECTS
THAT COULD RESULT IN NET
INCREASES IN EMISSIONS TO THE
ENERGY SECTOR AND FINALLY. AS
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING REMARKS
TODAY I AM ACCEPTING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS THAT
ENSURE THE HYDROGEN GOING INTO
THIS NEW INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT
MEETS OR EXCEEDS THE STATE'S.
CURRENT GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND AIR POLLUTION
REDUCTION STANDARDS. DOING THIS
WILL ENSURE THAT HYDROGEN
MOVING THROUGHOUT OUR STATE IS
A STATE HOLE AND NOT CARBON
INTENSIVE. WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS WE BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE ADDRESSED THE MAJORITY OF
THE PRONE OF THE OPPONENTS
CONCERNS. AT THE END OF THE DAY.
ALL THIS BILL DOES IS ALLOW GAS
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES TO
INVEST IN HYDROGEN DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE IF IT WILL HAVE
A DE A DIRECT BENEFIT TO THE
TAX BY THE RATE PAYER INVOLVED.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. WITH BE ON THE PHONE
TODAY I HAVE TIM SASINE BOARD
PRESIDENT OF THE WESTERN STATE
HYDROGEN LANCE AND ROXANA BECO
MAHDI EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
WESTERN STATES HYDROGEN
ALLIANCE BOTH- HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. AND HELP ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR- SO YES LET'S GO TO
LET'S GO TO MISTER SYNCING
FIRST. THANK YOU CHAIR ALAN AND
BUT YOU MEMBERS COMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHULETA FOR
YOUR TIRELESS WORK TO BRING
ADMISSION FREE TECHNOLOGY TO
THE PEOPLE OF OUR STATE. MY
NAME IS CONTESTING AND I'M
YEARS FOR PRESIDENT OF THE
WESTERN STATES HYDROGEN
ALLIANCE WHERE HYDROGEN
EQUIPMENT YOU CAN ALSO
MANUFACTURES SEEKING TO
ESTABLISH A FAIR AND OPEN
MARKETPLACE FOR HYDROGEN HAS AN
EMISSIONS FREE ENERGY CARING
ALTERNATIVE. TO FOSSIL FUELS
AND GREAT EXPANSION.
TRANSPORTATION WAS IDENTIFIED
BY CALIFORNIA AGENCIES EARLY ON
AS A MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR TO GHG
EMISSIONS AND BASED ON THE
INITIAL SUCCESS OF PASSENGER
CAR YOU VIS. INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES- THE CPEC SOUGHT TO
ACCELERATE DECARBONISATION OF
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY FREE. BY
USING REPAIR FUNDS TO BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE CHARGE TRUCKS
BUSES ANOTHER FLEET VEHICLES
THEY ANTICIPATED AND USERS
IMPLEMENTING. THESE ARE THE
VERY UP. THAT HYDROGEN IS SHOWN.
ALREADY IN SERVING. AS A BEING
SHOWN DRAMATICALLY CALIFORNIA'S
INNOVATIVE CLEAN TRANSIT
ROLLOUT. RENDON AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA NOW OPERATE JONES-
BUSES BUT LEADS OF TEN BUSES
ARE MORE THREE MORE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF PURCHASING FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC BUSES IN FOURTEEN OF
THE FIRST EIGHTEEN TRANSIT
AGENCIES SUBMITTING THEIR ICICI
ROLLOUT PLANS. INCLUDE ARE OPEN
TO FUEL CELL ELECTRIC BUSES
WHICH WILL CONSTITUTE ABOUT A
QUARTER TO A HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSLATE. THAT
INTO YOUR CELLS ARE
COMMERCIALIZED IN TRANSIT TO
DATE AND TRACKING WE'VE JUST
COMPLETED A VERY SUCCESSFUL TO
YOUR DEMONSTRATION OF A CLASS
EIGHT FUEL CELL DRAYAGE
TRUCKING COMMERCIAL OPERATION
WITH YOU GET SIDE ORDERS OF
LONG BEACH AND LA. IBM POWER
YARD TRUCKS ARE ARRIVING THIS
SUMMER AT THE PORT OF LONG
BEACH INITIALLY THE FUEL SO YOU
GET THE RIVER TRUCKS ARE RIDING.
SACRAMENTO THE SUMMERS WHILE.
DISTINGUISH COMMITTEE MA'AM
THERE'S A LINGERING LINGER
CRISP. THAT MOST. EFFECTIVE
JEREMY TECHNOLOGIES ARE THOSE
WITH THE BEST SO CALLED WELL TO
WHEEL ATTRITION FEES. WHEN THE
WELL CHANGES FROM A FINITE
RESOURCE BURIED IN THE GROUND
AS WITH FOSSIL FUELS. TO THE
LIMITLESS RESOURCES OF WIND
SOLAR GEOTHERMAL AND EVEN WAY
POWER. OUR OBJECTIVE MUST
CHANGE. BUT WE MUST SEEK TO DO
PARTICULARLY WITH
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION.
IF THE FIND THE LOWEST COST
METHODS FOR GATHERING AS MUCH
CLEAN ENERGY AS POSSIBLE FROM
THESE CLEAN RESOURCES.
DIRECTING THAT ENERGY TO WHERE
WE NEED THE WORK DONE DISTRICT
PEOPLE AND BUSINESSES. WITH
MINIMAL ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ECONOMIC IMPACT. RELYING SOLELY
ON THE POINT THE POINT
ELECTRICAL GRID
INTERCONNECTIONS IN MASSIVE
LITHIUM ION STORAGE FACILITIES.
WILL LIMIT OUR ABILITY TO
HARNESS THIS ENERGY WHICH MAY
COME FROM JUST AND OTHER TO
REMOTE WIND FARMS. AND MANAGE
OUR DISTRIBUTION OF THIS ENERGY
IN OUR DANCE URBAN IMPORTANT
VITAMINS AND TO REMOTE LITTLE
CONSUMER. SUCH AS AGRICULTURE
IN RAIL. I DIDN'T LIKE LIKE HAS
NO. CARBON IN IT YOU. IS ONLY
HOW OLD THEY ARE PER AT THAT
YOU H. U. QU. CAL MUST HAVE
ACCESS TO THE BROAD NUMBER OF
ZERO CARBON SUPPLIES SOURCES
AND MULTIPLE DISTRIBUTION
FACTORS THAT HYDROGEN AFFORDS.
ARBITRATION EFFORTS SUCH AS
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
MUST BE INCLUSIVE OF HYDROGEN
SO THAT OUR MOST RELIABLE
LOWEST COST AND LEAST IMPACTFUL
APPROACHES CAN BE AVAILABLE.
AND THEREFORE URGES COMMITTEE
DID SUPPORT SB SIX SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. TEN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW AVE SOME
STATEMENTS FROM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR- IF SHE CAN GET ON THE
LINE. YEAH THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHAIR ALAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ROXANNE BACK
ON HOLIDAY AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
WALKING DEAD HAS NO LIFE THE
FUNDS ARE AT THE PICNIC. CARE
I'M HERE THE HOW CAN REYES
IRONMAN AT AMAZON AND BARNES
ENGINEER FORMER. EMPLOYEE I
THINK IT'S HE WOULD PROFIT
PENSION OF THE LATEST FULLY
PREPARED BY THE-
TRANSPORTATION- RESEARCHERS ARE
FINANCED NATIONAL LABORATORIES
AND UNIVERSITIES HAVE CONCLUDED
THAT BATTERIES ALLOW. HOUR
LIMITATION CANNOT SERVE AS A
ONE FOR ONE REPLACEMENT FOR
BOXES TRUCKS TRAINS AND PLANES.
I THINK THE DIVISION OF THE
STRUCTURE WILL ABSOLUTELY BE
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE A
DALMATIAN FEEL HIGHER CHEN. TO
LARGE FEEL CONSUMERS LIKE
EQUALITY IMPORTANT TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO NAME A FEW.
CURRENTLY THE HOUSING USED IN
TRANSPORTATION APPLICATION IS.
TWENTY EIGHTY EIGHT REPORT I
THINK. HE FURTHER IF THAT'S
WHAT YOU ARE CARBON COUNTY AND
LOCAL PARK YOU'RE CLINICS FOR
THAT CRITICAL THEIR OWN MISSION
FIELD. I HUMBLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE IN ORDER TO TAKE ONE
MORE SIGNIFICANT STEP TOWARD
REPLACING DIESEL. FUEL AND JET
FUEL USAGE IN THE STATE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU OKAY
LET'S. I DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE
IN PERSON OR IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WHO WANT TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. I ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINES LIKE. TO
WEIGH IN AND SUPPORT. MODERATOR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IT LOOKED.
SHOW SUPPORT FOR S. SIX A TWO
TWO ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE GATHER
THE INFORMATION FOR THE FIRST
TIME A. ARE YOU ARE YOU WAITING
FOR I'M SO SORRY. YES ARMONK
THEY'LL GET THE NUMBERS FOR THE
FIRST LINES. YOU HAVE
CONSTRUCTING SOLUTIONS. YEAH
I'LL COME FROM NINE TWENTY
THREE. SO YOU BASICALLY PUMP
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME. A
SECOND IT'S H. TWO YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK GOOD MORNING THIS IS TIM
CARMICHAEL- IT YOU HAVE TO GO
TO WHICH- SOCALGAS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX TWO. YOUR
NEXT PAYMENT IS FROM LINE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BERMAN
NOTES. OFFICE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN BUSINESS
COUNCIL GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX TWO AND
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE ALL TOGETHER ADDITIONAL
LINE NUMBERS. AB ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ANDREW LEEDOM
GENERAL COUNSEL AT AEROTEK AND-
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THAT SB.
SIX SIX TWO. IN ADDITION. I'M
NOT SURE HOW MUCH THIS TIME.
YOU ARE AT LET'S NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION- I DON'T HAVE ANYONE
WHO IS REGISTERED FOR LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS- BUT THERE'S
BEEN SOME LATE OPPOSITION IT'S
COME IN- THE BILL SO. LET'S GO
TO. I DON'T SEE ONE IN PERSON
EITHER HERE IN TWENTY FORTY
LET'S GO TO. THE PHONE LINES TO
SEE IF ANYONE WANTS TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION CONCERNS. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MY FIRST
PANEL COME FROM LINE NUMBER
SEVEN BEFORE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MERGER MEMBERS BURNING
DAWSON WITH YOUR COMPANY-
EXPRESSING OPPOSITION FOR OUR
ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS OUR
TESTERS- WE JUST HAVE A FEW CAN
TURN AROUND THREE SIX SIX TWO A
PERSONAL UTILITY CUSTOMERS
ABOUT THE COST OF BUILDING
SERVER INFRASTRUCTURE CRIED
UNTIL- WE HAVE. AS THE DIGITAL
CONCERNS AROUND THE USE OF
HYDROGEN. FUEL CELLS AS IF WE
BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE NOT
ALLOWING STATES TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE GROWTH OF
EARLY IF POSSIBLE- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND NOT COMMITTEE. TO
RECTIFY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BUT MANY MANAGEMENT ON BEHALF
OF THE AGRICULTURAL ENERGY
COMPARED TO THIRTY ASIAN AND
OPPOSITION WITH CONCERNS ABOUT
THE CAR. BEEN ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WELL SO LET'S NOW
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMUNITY
CENTER SKINNER. THANK YOU.
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THE BILL
THANK YOU- CHAIR- FOR THE
HEARING IN FOR I THOUGHT THE
ANALYSIS WAS- WAS VERY GOOD AND
I. SO MY COMMENTS AND THEN I
MAY HAVE A QUESTION IS. D. I
THINK THE ANALYSIS- GIVES A
GOOD BACKGROUND ON. THE. THE
CARD IS THE STATE OF OUR TO
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK THE ROLE
THAT HYDROGEN COULD PLAY BUT
ALSO THE FACT THAT STILL
HYDROGEN IS RIGHT NOW AS THE
OPPOSITION HAS RAISED BEING
PRODUCED- THROUGH FOSSIL FUEL
SO IT'S MORE WHAT WE CALL GRADE
HYDROGEN HOWEVER THE NOTICES
POINTS OUT THAT WE HAVE THE- WE
ARE MOVING. TOWARDS A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE WE WOULD
HAVE MUCH GREATER CAPACITY. TO
PRODUCE HYDROGEN FROM NON
FOSSIL SOURCES WHICH OF COURSE.
WOOD NOT ONLY FROM A LIFE CYCLE
POINT OF VIEW MAKE THAT ENERGY
SOURCE FUEL HAVE WHAT HAVE YOU
BECAUSE THEY BENEFIT OF
HYDROGEN IS THAT IT CAN BE
APPLIED IN MANY DIFFERENT IT'S
VERY VERSATILE- ENERGY SOURCE.
BUT THE BENEFIT BEING THAT NOT
ONLY WOULD IT HAVE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT IN TERMS OF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS REDUCTION BUT
ALSO HELPING US MOVE OFF OF
DIESEL AND DUST DEALING WITH
ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT AIR
POLLUTING HEALTH IMPACTED AIR
POLLUTING SOURCES THAT WE HAVE.
AND NOW LIKE ANYTHING DEVIL'S
IN THE DETAILS. IT WERE RIGHT
NOW. NOT FULLY AT THE PLACE
WHERE WE HAVE. THAT ADVANTAGE
AND IT COST EFFECTIVE THE GREEN
HYDROGEN HOWEVER. IF WE BY WELL
I'LL PUT IN THE POSITIVE WAY
BYE OUR SENDING WITH THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE RIGHT MARKET
SIGNALS WE CAN HELP STIMULATE
AND JUMP START THAT HAPPENING
AND THAT'S AND OF COURSE THE
ALL ALL OF THEM THE MARKET
SIGNALS THEY HAVE TO BE
MULTIPLE ONCE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS TO BE THERE
TOO SO THAT'S A MARKET SIGNAL.
AS WELL AS THE OTHER MARKET
SIGNALS THAT WE THAT WE THE
STATE CALIFORNIA SEE A REAL
ROLE FOR THIS FUEL SOURCE ENACT
THOSE VARIOUS MARKET SIGNALS
CAN HOPEFULLY A LINE SO THAT
THE INVESTOR COMMUNITY AND THE
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
INVESTOR AND- AN ENTREPRENEUR
COMMUNITY PUTS THESE THINGS
TOGETHER. NOW THE- OPPOSITION
RAISING THAT YOU KNOW WE MAY BE
JUMPING TO FAST IN AND BY DOING
SO WE WOULD END UP- SUPPORTING
OR OR MOVING TOWARDS MORE OF
THIS FOSSIL FUEL BASED HYDROGEN.
AND PEAK BECAUSE THEY'RE
RAISING THE DIFFERENCE IN THE
ANALYSIS SHOWS IT IN PRICE
BETWEEN SAY THE ELECTROLYTIC
PRODUCED HYDROGEN VERSUS THE
GREAT HYDROGEN. NOW THOSE WERE
VERY COMPARABLE ARGUMENTS THAT
WE HEARD WHEN FOR EXAMPLE I
CARRIED THE BILL ON ENERGY
STORAGE MANDATE WHICH WAS BACK
IN TWENTY TEN. AND AT THAT
POINT EVERYONE SET OUT THIS IS
IMPOSSIBLE IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE
THERE WILL BE NO THERE WE DON'T
HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
TECHNOLOGIES. THANKS AND IT
COULD BE FIFTEEN TWENTY YEARS.
CALIFORNIA IS NOW THE LEADER IN
ENERGY STORAGE TECHNOLOGY
ENERGY STORAGE IS THE COMPLETE
GAME CHANGER THE PRICES GONE
DOWN BY A PHENOMENAL. AND HAD
WE NOT ACTED THAT MAY NOT HAVE
HAPPENED SO THESE PREDICTIONS
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET
SOMEWHERE TO FIFTEEN YEARS YEAH
IF WE DON'T. IF WE DON'T SEND
ANY SIGNALS WE MIGHT NOT GET
THESE CRISES THAT WE ARE FACING
BOTH THE HEALTH IMPACTS OF AIR
POLLUTION AND THE CLIMATE
CRISIS ARE SO SERIOUS THAT WE
NEED TO SEND THE RIGHT. MARKET
SIGNALS SO- I. THE ANALYSIS
DIDN'T NECESSARILY DETAIL ANY
AMENDMENTS SO I GUESS SORRY I
WOULD DIRECT THIS THE CHAIR I
WANT TO SEE THE CHAIR IF YOU
FEEL. THAT THAT THIS THE WAY
IT'S CONSTRUCTED NOW. IS GOING
TO SEND THOSE SIGNALS. BUT AND
NOT AS I INTERPRETED THAT WE
HAVE WE'RE FEELING. WE ARE
FEELING THAT IT IS IN GOOD
ENOUGH SHAPE TO SEND THOSE
SIGNALS WITHOUT HAVING TO BE A
NEGATIVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
OF. OF FLOODING THE MARKET WITH
GREAT HYDROGEN. ON AND I COULD
ASK THE AUTHOR BUT I GUESS I'M
ASKING THE CHAIR SINCE- YEAH
I'VE- BEEN TO HAVE THE IVR
RECOMMENDATION AND- YEAH I KNOW
AND I'M I'M QUITE FRANKLY- YOU
KNOW I KNOW I KNOW SO
ORIGINALLY THERE WERE NO
STIPULATIONS IN THE BILL. ABOUT
WHERE THE HAD ORIGINALLY COME
FROM THE SOURCING- AND THEN
OVER AN ENERGY- THEY PUT IN
THIS BACKSTOPS LANGUAGE. TALK
ABOUT- AND- YOUR NO NET
INCREASE IN EMISSIONS. SO WE
WANT TO I MEAN WE QUITE FRANKLY
WANT TO AMEND THE BILL TO MAKE
IT TIMES BETTER FROM EMISSIONS
PERSPECTIVE AND YOU KNOW THE IS
THE SOURCING ISSUE THAT YOU'RE
JUST RAISING- YEAH I THINK
THERE'S SOME PRECEDENT OUT
THERE FOR REQUIRING THAT X.
PERCENTAGE OF. OF THE HYDROGEN.
UNIT DELIVERED TO BE RENEWABLE
WE YOU KNOW. SO WE'VE BEEN
WE'VE BEEN. TALKING A WORKING
WITH AUTHORS OFFICE ON THIS YOU
KNOW DOT HAS BEEN BEEN VERY
MINIMAL CONVERSATION SO FAR-
AND- TO IS IT THERE WE HAVEN'T
REALLY LANDED ON ONE WE HAVEN'T
LANDED OKAY EXACTLY WHICH YET-
BUT BUT BUT I WANT I WANT TO
FIRST I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
RAISING THIS BECAUSE I YOU KNOW
AND I'M I'M YEAH I KNOW DAVID
CENTER CERNER SHARES HIS
CONCERNS AND- BECAUSE BECAUSE
BECAUSE ARMY OTHER MEMBERS AS
WELL. I'M BECAUSE THE WAY IT'S
CERTAINLY THE WAY WAS INITIALLY
FRAME THAT EVEN IN ITS CURRENT
FORM I DON'T THINK GOES FAR
AND- YOU FAR ENOUGH TO ADDRESS
THE- VERY VALID ISSUES YOU'RE
RAISING AYE AYE YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE ISSUES OF COURSE. CENTER
SKINNER IS THAT. YOU'VE GOT A
BILL IN THIS SPACE AS WELL AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE.
THAT IS THE CHALLENGE WE HAVE
WITH DODD BILL TO LIKE WE GOT
THESE DIFFERENT VEHICLES
MILLION HOW DO WE MARRY THEM
AND ENSURE THAT THEIR- IN. THE
MOVING FORWARD IN THE SAME
SPIRIT SO I. ASSOCIATE MYSELF
WITH THE COMMENTS AND I GUESS I
JUST WANT TO. SAY TO THE AUTHOR
THAT TIME IF WE DO MOVE IT OUT
OF COMMITTEE TODAY THIS IS
GOING TO BE. AN IMMENSELY
IMPORTANT. ISSUE FOR US TO
RESOLVE BEFORE. WE HAVE. YOU
KNOW THE BEFORE WE RECOMMEND IT
MOVING TO THE FLOOR AND- MOVING
ALONG WILL I- AM I APPRECIATE
THAT AND- I REALIZED I REACHED
IT BUT I. AT THE PROPER TIME
I'M READY TO MOVE THE BILL AND
I GUESS I. AS MUCH AS I RAISE
THOSE CONCERNS I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T. PUT
THERE WE HEARD IN SIMILAR THE
BILL THAT WE HEARD BEFORE AND
CANNABIS THAT WE DON'T PUT IN
SUCH RIGID. SAY AMENDMENTS THAT
WE CALL FOR LACK OF A BETTER
TERM CUT OUR NOSE OFF TO SPITE
OUR FACE AND THAT PERHAPS IT IS
MORE. INTENT LANGUAGE LIKE
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY- MUCH OF THIS
WOULD STILL BE IN THE HANDS OF
OUR VARIOUS REGULATORY AGENCIES
YOU KNOW MAYBE THE INTENT
LANGUAGE OF THAT YOU KNOW TO
HELP TO WHATEVER- INVESTMENTS
ARE MADE A REGULATIONS THAT.
THE FACTOR OR DO THEIR BEST TO-
TO- TO MIRROR OUR OTHER
STATUTORY GOALS RIGHT IN THAT
WAY. THE REGULATORY AGENCY
BECAUSE WE KNOW EVEN IF WE IF
WE TAKE LIKE OUR CLIMATE GOALS
WE KNOW THAT WE ARE. WE HAVE
THESE GOALS AND BUT WE'RE
MOVING WE KNOW THAT THEIR ALSO
IN NOT INCREMENTAL PER SE BUT
WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS EACH YEAR
WE'RE NOT EXPECTING TO DO THEM
OVERNIGHT. AND SO IF WE DON'T
IF WE PUT IN SOME INTENT
LANGUAGE PERHAPS VERSUS VERY
RIGID LANGUAGE IT MAY HELP.
ACHIEVE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO-
TO PROTECT AGAINST WITH-
WITHOUT MESSING UP OUR MARKET
SIGNAL AND NOW I KNOW I THINK
YOU'RE QUITE FRANKLY I MEAN I'M
GLAD WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE I THINK OUR- OUR-
THOUGHTS ELISE INITIALLY WAS
THAT YOUR BILL IS GOING TO
BECOME AN IMPORTANT VEHICLE FOR
TIGHTENING UP THE CREATORS AND
DEFINITION. OKAY AND NOW LOOKS
LIKE THERE'S BEEN AN- BROWN'S
BUDGET WELL I DID SAY IT'S AN
ELEMENT OF FLUX I SUPPOSE SO I
THINK WE'RE I THINK KIDS NOT TO
MIX THEM BECAUSE IT'S NOT FAIR
TO BUT I THINK IT'S AN WERE
MAKING A LOT OF PROGRESS AND I
THINK IT'S IN GOOD. IT'S
GETTING IN MUCH BETTER SHAPE IN
TERMS OF- SAY THE CONCERNS OF
MUCH OF OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY. SYNTHESIZE IF WE'RE
REFERRING TO MY BILL I THINK WE
WERE MAKING PROGRESS IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE IN MUCH BETTER
SHAPE IN. RELATIONSHIP TO THAT
PERSPECTIVE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY. THAT'S MY HOPE
THAT'S MY COMMITMENTS AND SO
WE'LL SEE THAT WHEN WE YOU KNOW
WE'LL WE'LL WE'LL CROSS THAT
BRIDGE WHEN WE COME TO IT. WELL
THAT'S COME OUT ON THURSDAY AND
I WILL. I GUESS I WOULD LOVE TO.
GET US ALL TALKING BEFORE THE A
GREAT TODAY OR TOMORROW ABOUT
THAT- BECAUSE IT WAS IT WAS AN
IMPORTANT. THE KIND OF OWNER
COMPLEMENTARY OUT YES WELL YEAH.
SO AS CENTER STERN. HIS NAME TO
A CASKET I'M SORRY MR I'M SORRY
OKAY CENTER STERN THEM ALL I
WAS ASKING I'M SORRY HE
ADMITTED. SORRY THE MANAGER
YEAH I KNOW AHEAD PLEASE GO
AHEAD OKAY. I'M THANKS FOR THE
DISCUSSION ARE IN THANK YOU
SEEN OUR TRUCKS YOUR LEADERSHIP
SPACE- I LET ME BUT I WANT TO
BUILD ON THE LAST COMMENT AND
JUST GET CLARITY ABOUT HOW THE
BILL WOULD WORK. AS AMENDED OR
OR OR NOT AMENDED I I'M SEEING
ANY ANALYSIS IT'S SAYING.
COMMITTEE SHOULD DIRECT THE
AUTHOR TO ENSURE ELIGIBLE
PROJECTS DELIVER HYDROGEN THAT
MEETS OR EXCEEDS ITS GHG
EMISSION INDOOR AIR POLLUTION
REDUCTION STANDARDS. IS THAT AN
AMENDMENT OR IS THAT A- THE
FOOD IS FUTURE COMMITMENT JUST
TO GET SOME CLARITY. IF I MAY
ASK SURE YEAH THE ENTIRE
ADJUSTED WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE
IS COMMITTING TO AMENDMENTS
COMMITTING TO THE FUTURE TO
COMMITTING TO PUT THESE THINGS
TOGETHER BECAUSE IF I WOULD
LIKE TO AGAIN- THE SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR INPUT IS SO VALUABLE BUT
AGAIN THEY'RE DIFFERENT CYCLES
ARE ELEMENTS TO THIS WHOLE
THING ABOUT HYDROGEN THERE'S
PRODUCTION ITSELF THAT WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT HOW IT'S PRODUCED
AND IN WHAT DIDN'T EXACTLY WITH
PRODUCTION IS THAT OF COURSE
THERE'S THE DISTRIBUTION AND
THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT. THEN AS WE GO
DOWN THE ROAD IF THE FUELING IN
THE RETAIL SO THERE'S LOTS OF
ELEMENTS DOWN THE ROAD TO MAKE
THIS THING HAPPEN FOR THE
SENATE BILL SIX SIX TWO IS THE
FIRST STEP TO OPEN UP THE DOORS
AND AS I'D GIVEN YOU- SOME OF
THE LIST OF SOME OF THE CITIES
THAT. YOU HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ALREADY STARTED
WE NEED TO GO FORWARD TO MAKE
THAT EVEN LARGER AND IF I MAY
MSTER CHAIR JUST TO POINT OUT
THAT YOU KNOW WE THINK OF BILLS
THAT PERTAIN TO OURSELVES AND
TO OUR DISTRICT WILL LISTEN TO
THIS IN MY DISTRICT ALONE. WE
HAVE THE SEVEN TEN FREEWAY IN
THE SEVEN TEN FREEWAY OBVIOUSLY
CENTER GONZALEZ YOU KNOW THAT
WELL PACKAGE COMES OUT FROM THE
PORCH IN ALL THE TRANSPORTATION
IT GOES INTO MY DISTRICT THE
FIVE FREEWAY WHEN WE THINK OF
ORANGE COUNTY EVERYONE HAS BEEN
TO DISNEYLAND AND KNOTT'S BERRY
FARM THAT'S THE FIVE FREEWAY
THE SIX OH FIVE THE CUTS ACROSS
THE SIXTY FREEWAY THE NINETY
ONE FREEWAY THAT GOES TO THE
AIRPORT. AND THE ONE OH FIVE
FREEWAY THESE ARE ALL FREEWAYS
ARE IN MY DISTRICT SO MY
CONCERN ABOUT OUR ENVIRONMENT
AND THE WAY WE MOVE OUR
TRANSPORTATION IT'S VITAL AND
IN MY DISTRICT I ONLY HAVE
THREE STATIONS IN HAWAIIAN
GARDENS POINT PARK IN LA MIRADA
IN YET. I'VE GOT SIX FREEWAYS
SO YOU CAN IMAGINE WHAT THE
GROWTH. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
HAVE SO WE'RE A LONG WAY WE
FROM PUTTING THIS ALL THE- SO
WHEN WE AT THE QUALITY OF THE
AIR. WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
QUALITY OF WHAT WE'VE DONE TO
PROTECT THE AIR AND WHAT WE'VE
DONE. IN CENTER SKINNER WHEN
YOU TURN THE CLOCK BACK TEN
YEARS AGO AND YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT IF WE HAD NOT. DONE WHAT
WE'RE DOING WE WOULDN'T BE HERE
RIGHT NOW. SO THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE CREATE TODAY THAT. THE
AND THE WORK WE DO TOGETHER
IT'S A KICK OF CLOSED DOORS SO
WE CAN HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
ENERGY SOURCE. THAT WE CAN ALL
BE PROUD OF. AND THAT'S THE
WHOLE PURPOSE OF THIS IN AND
WE'VE LOOKED AT. THE COST
SAVINGS AND REMEMBER IT DOESN'T
GO OUT. TO EVERYONE IN GENERAL
JUST WHO USES IT. AND THAT'S
THE DIFFERENCE SO ONE DAY AS AS
I HAD MENTIONED TO CENTER
GONZALEZ I'VE INVITED HER TO
COME IN AND BUY TO ALL. TO COME
TO CAL STATE LA THAT'S IN LOS
ANGELES RIGHT OUTSIDE OUR
DISTRICT THEIR ENTIRE FLEET AT
CAL STATE LA. IS WITH HYDROGEN.
THE POLICE CARS THE COMMUNITY
CARS EVERYTHING THEY HAVE A
HYDROGEN STATION THERE. AND
IT'S AMAZING HOW THEY'RE ABLE
TO DO THAT RIGHT SO WE FOLLOW
SUIT I THINK WE'RE GOING TO DO
THAT. SO DO WE HAVE WORK YES WE
DO AND I AM WILLING TO WORK
WITH THE CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE.
TO DO WHATEVER WE CAN TO
CONTINUE. THE EFFORTS TO MAKE
THE SENATE BILL SIX SIX TWO-
AND HAVE IT ONE DAY COULD GO TO
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK OKAY I MEAN
IT IN OUTLOOK- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOUR OFFICE
IS AGREED TO THE FOLLOWING
LANGUAGE EDITION. SHE IS
SUPPOSED TO THIS IS TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO CENTER STERN'S
QUESTION IF YOU LOOK AT PAGE
SIX OF THE BILL- SECTIONED I
SEE. C. RIGHT NOW THE LANGUAGE
HAS THE COMMISSION SHALL NOT
APPROVE ANY PROGRAM OR
INVESTMENT PURSUANT TO THIS
SUBDIVISION THAT WOULD RESULT
IN EITHER OF THE FOLLOWING
CAUTIOUSLY CONSUMER RATES A NET
INCREASE IN EMISSIONS FROM THE
ENERGY SECTOR AS THE TERM OF
THE STATE ARE YOU RESOURCES
SUPPORT AND ANY ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE THE SALE OR USE OF
HYDROGEN AS TRANSPORTATION FUEL
THAT DOES NOT MEET RENEWABLE
IMPLEMENTATION AND EMISSION
REQUIREMENTS IN EXISTING
APPLICABLE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS. SO THAT AND IN
GENERAL I IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT YOUR OFFICE HAS AGREED TO.
BUT TO. TO ENSURING THAT THAT
DID THE- DID THIS BILL
ULTIMATELY IN VISIT THE
LANGUAGE HERE IT IS AN
AMENDMENT EMITS A CONCEPTUAL
AMENITY REALLY TO THIS LANGUAGE
I JUST I JUST ARTICULATED.
CENTER STAR IN BUT THE IDEA
THAT- DEAD DEAD- TO HEAR THAT
THIS BILL HAS TO ENSURE THAT.
THE PROJECTS THAT ARE DELIVERED
MEET OR EXCEED EMISSIONS AND OR
POLLUTION REDUCTION STANDARDS-
NOW THAT BEING SAID. YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO TALK TO
CENTER STERN ABOUT
STRENGTHENING THAT LANGUAGE AND.
AS TO GET CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THAT
LANGUAGE DOES THAT WAS ALL JUST
WHAT WE'RE VOTING ON TODAY I
TOTALLY APPRECIATE THESE ARE
EVOLVING CONVERSATIONS I JUST
WANTED TO. BE SUPER CLEAR ABOUT
WHAT THE COMMITTEES WERE VOTING
ON I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF.
ISSUES AND FREEWAYS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OTHER BILLS
BUT SO WHAT WE'RE VOTING ON
TODAY. I'M JUST READING THE
BILL ALONG WITH YOU I DON'T SEE
THAT. THAT LANGUAGE ISN'T IN
THE BILL WHAT YOU JUST READ
THAT'S A LANGUAGE THAT'S
LANGUAGE FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THE RIGHT AS IT'S FROM THE
COMMITTEE AND- THE AUTHORS
AGREED TO THAT- AND- QUITE
FRANKLY I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
BEING IN THE IN THE IT I DON'T
I DON'T KNOW WHY THIS
INFORMATION WAS PROVIDED TO THE
MEMBERS- BEFOREHAND SO- I KNOW
IT I KNOW THAT I KNOW THE
AGREEMENT JUST HAPPENED BUT
NEVER THE LESS I APOLOGIZE.
OKAY THAT'S VERY HELPFUL MR
SURE YET SO THERE ISN'T IT SO
THIS BILL WOULD BE MOVING THE
MOTION WOULD BE TO MOVE THE
BILL AS AMENDED. BUT THEN WHAT
I'VE HEARD FROM CENTER TO LET
IS ALSO A COMMITMENT TO FURTHER.
DISCUSSIONS- AT N. YEAH AND I
AND I WOULD JUST I WOULD SAY IN
THOSE FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ALL I
WOULD ASK IS THAT. YOU WILL
CONSIDER- THE DETAILS ON THE
ANALYSIS THAT POINT OUT THAT I
HEARD THAT THE PROPONENTS SAY
THAT. NINETY SOME ODD PERCENT
OF THE HYDROGEN PRODUCED IN
CALIFORNIA IS DONE RENEWABLY I
DON'T KNOW HOW THEY DEFINE
RENEWABLY GET THE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT THAT. THE STATE
REQUIREMENTS ONLY THAT FORTY
PERCENT. OF THE HYDROGEN AT
LEAST TO QUALIFY FOR L. CFS.
HAVE A RENEWABLE THE ONLY 40%
BE RENEWABLE- SOME JUST I'M I'M
UNCLEAR LIKE IF WE'RE IF WE'RE
BEFORE ALLOWING THE GAS COMPANY
TO AND- TO SEEK BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF RATE BASED
INVESTMENTS FOR. FOR FUEL
THAT'S 60% GAS NATURAL GAS
BASED THE COULD COME FROM
FRACKING FROM OTHER STATES AND
PROBABLY WOULDN'T COME FROM
FRACKED GAS FROM OTHER STATES.
I GOT A PROBLEM WITH THAT BUT
I'M I'M HEARING THAT YOU'RE
GOING A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
DIRECTION IN LIGHT OF ALSO THE
WORK IS SENATOR SKINNER'S DOING
SO. I'M I WANT TO GIVE YOU ALL
SPACE TO DO WORK AND FLAG THAT
CONCERN ALL. ALMOST ALL STAY
WITH THE CHAIR AND VOTE I DID A
TO KEEP THIS MOVING BUT I- YEAH
I SIGNAL THE SAME TO CENTER
SKINNER ON HER GREEN HYDROGEN
BILL BUT- MY BIGGEST CHALLENGE
YEARS. TO DEFINE SOMETHING IS
ZERO EMISSIONS WHICH THIS BILL
DOES. STATES RIGHT UP FRONT.
YOU KNOW ZERO MISSION THAT ZERO
EMISSION TRANCE TRANSPORTATION.
IS HYDROGEN FUEL VEHICLES I
WOULD SAY ONLY IF THE HYDROGEN
FUEL IS ZERO EMISSION. AND IF
IT'S. NOT YOUR MISSION IT SORT
OF BECOMES A- MISNOMER IN THE
DEATH. FOR CALLING ZERO THAT
MIGHT BE 60% FOR GAS. BUT
DOESN'T QUITE WORK ANYHOW I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK
YOU ARE DOING ON THIS- THANKS
FOR INDULGING MY COMMENTS NOT
BE YOU'RE YOU'RE RAISING YOUR
RAISING- AB. KEY ISSUES- AND OF
COURSE. YOU KNOW THE CHALLENGE
HERE IS. TALKING TO
STAKEHOLDERS FOLKS THE
MINISTRATION AIRPORT OTHERS-
AND YOU KNOW THESE BILLS ARE
pAND- SO I THINK WE'RE MAKING
SOME GOOD PROGRESS ALONG THE
LINES OF YOUR CORE CONCERNS
SENATOR BUT- YOU KNOW WHAT WE
WILL MAKE SURE THAT ALL THAT
INFORMATION IS SHARED WITH YOU
AND IF YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL
THOUGHTS- WE WELCOME. WE
WELCOME. WE WELCOME THEM AS WE
TRY TO FIGURE OUT THE PROGRESS
OF THIS BILL KNOWING 4% OF WHAT
KASKY CONCERNED DOLLARS IT'S AN
EXHAUST. THE REQUESTED THOUGH I
WAS SAID MY COLLEAGUES AS
CENTER STERN HAD. HIT THE NAIL
ON THE HEAD RIGHT HERE RIGHT
NOW IT SEEMS THAT THE RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN HE SAID IN ORDER TO
THE TO GET THE LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD. THE MARKETPLACE IS
GOING TO IT. THAT'S TOO
ATTRACTIVE OF A IS A STATE
SUBSIDY NOT TO MAKE IT 40%
RENEWABLE I GUESS THE QUESTION
FOR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND- JUST FOLKS OUT THERE SAID.
LOWENTHAL FIFTEEN YEARS AGO SET
A RENEWABLE HYDROGEN RENEWABLE
STANDARD HYDROGEN AT THIRTY
THREE POINT 3% IT IS CRACKED UP
TO THIRTY EIGHT PERCENT. WE
KNOW IF YOU WANT TO GET THE LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD YOU. NEED
TO GET FORTY. IN THIS. WE WANT
TO KILL THE GOAL GOOSE BECAUSE
WE CAN STIPULATE THAT HAVING
HYDROGEN VEHICLES. ARE MUCH.
MUCH BETTER FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
AND DIESEL VEHICLES AT DELL
BEING REPLACED I THINK IT'S THE
DETAILS OF HOW DO WE-
INCENTIVIZE IS. MY COLLEAGUES-
FROM. BERKELEY AND- INDICATED
THAT HOW DO WE HOW DO WE-
INCENTIVIZE A CREEPING UP OF A
RENEWABLE CONTENT. WITHIN THE
USE IT WITHIN THE PROCESS OF
CREATING- HYDROGEN THAT DOESN'T
JUST. MAKE THE MARKET GO FLAT
SO. WE'LL PAY ATTENTION THIS IS
COMING BEFORE SUBCOMMITTEE TO
WITH THE ZEV MANDATE. THAT
INCLUDES HYDROGEN- FOR US TO
WILL. THAT SUBCOMMITTEE WILL
HAVE A CHANCE TO LOOK AT IT
ALSO SO. I THINK CENTER SKINNER
MOVED MATTER YEAH WE ALSO HAVE
A COUPLE CENTERS ON A ONE TO.
CENTER DOLLY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRED SO LOOK I
YOU'VE BEEN DOING A LOT OF WORK
IN THIS SPACE WITH. HOW DO
NIAGARA I THINK THERE'S A TOTAL
NEED FOR CALIFORNIA THINK WE'VE
MISSED THE MARK- BY FOCUSING SO
MUCH ON YOU KNOW. SEMATARY
STORAGE HELL TO SAY AND WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT. I'M IN THE
TRANSPORTATION IS WE RUN DIESEL
TRUCKS AND- TO DO BATTERY%
TECHNOLOGY THERE'S GOING TO BE
I THINK. SOMEONE VERY DIFFICULT
TO MOVE THE PRODUCTS AND GOODS
THAT WE NEED TO SO I THINK I
JUNE IS THE ANSWER I THINK
THERE'S A REAL NEED FOR THAT-
BUT IN THIS BILL AND I VOTED
FOR. I SAW THIS AND I THINK WE
SAW THIS AND ENERGY ENERGIA AND
I VOTED AGAINST THE BILL OF THE
THEM THEN THE REASON I VOTED
AGAINST BILLS THAT. I WANTED
WHAT YOU DID TO EXPLAIN HOW THE
RATE PAYERS- WOULD NOT BE
IMPACTED BY THIS BILL I BELIEVE
THEY WILL BE. AND IF I READ
ONLINE AS THE SEE WHAT SECTION
I MEAN HERE BUT- BASS HE SAYS
COST SHIFTING CUT- TO THE
COMMISSION SHALL NOT APPROVE
ANY PROGRAM OR INVESTMENT
PERSONAL INTO THE SUBDIVISION
THAT WOULD RESULT IN EITHER. OF
THE FALL EITHER THE FOLLOWING.
KASHIF DIDN'T CUSTOMER RATES.
AND WE HEARD SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION THAT CAME IN-
TALKING ABOUT COST SHIFT IN THE
TYPICAL. HOMEOWNER IN
CALIFORNIA IS RATES ARE
DIFFERENT THAN THE INDUSTRIAL
RATES WHICH THOSE OF US IN AG
INDUSTRY- PAY A HIGHER RATE- TO
THE AISLE USED IN THE NORMAL
HOUSE TO SO CAN YOU TALK ABOUT
HOW THE- RATE STRUCTURE WOULD
BE FOR THESE IOUS. SENATOR I'M
GONNA TURN TO THE TECHNICAL
ADVISORS- IF THEY CAN JUMP IN I
WOULD APPRECIATE IT- BECAUSE IT
I WANT TO BE ABSOLUTELY SURE
THAT THAT WE GET ON THE RIGHT
THE SAME PAGE. AND IF I CAN ASK
YOU HAVE. THANK THANK YOU
SENATOR THIS IS ROCK FAN OF
ECONOMICALLY AS THERE IS HARSH
THERE WILL BE NO COST SHIFTING
OF THOSE THAT WILL BENEFIT FROM
THIS PROJECT WILL BE PAYING FOR
IT IN THE RATE SO IT WON'T BE-
SPREAD ACROSS ENTIRELY BATES.
SO THE SO THE PER THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE INVESTING IN THIS
TECHNOLOGY GOING TO PAY FOR IT.
NOT YEAH THAT IS COMMON
PARTICIPATING YOU KNOW I NEED
FOR A PROJECT ON MINOR OTHER
KINDS OF PROJECTS WHERE DOES
THAT ARE BENEFITING FROM IT ARE
PAYING FOR IT WITHIN THEIR RATE.
I'M CONFUSED THEN OF HOW YOU'RE
GOING TO CREATE THE RESOURCES
TO GET IT DONE. THE I. O. U.'S
ARE WHY ARE WE GOING TO THE P.
YOU SEE THAT. IF THEY DON'T
HAVE TO INCREASE THE RATE THEY
COULD JUST SIMPLY GO. INVEST IN
THE TECHNOLOGY AND DO IT ON
THEIR OWN. SENATOR I UNDERSTAND
THAT I THINK IT'S OF ALL THAT
THE IRAQIS CORY AND HAVING A
COMMON DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE NO THAT ARE IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR I THINK WE
MAKE- DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S JUST A
QUICK A QUICK ABOUT THE WAY. TO
HAVE A BROAD NETWORK THAT IS-
ACCEPTABLE TO ALL. THANK YOU.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING OF THEM
FROM THE SITE AGAIN CLIENTS AS
WELL- IT ANOTHER PERSPECTIVE TO
LOOK AT IS TAKING A GAMBLE- BUT
THE COURTS OF SAN PEDRO THEY
WANT TO BECOME ZERO EMISSION
AND SO THE CHOICES HOW DO WE
WANT TO DO THAT YOUR LETTER
CATION THROUGH GRADES AND
BATTERIES OR TWO HYDROGEN SO
WITHOUT SB SIX SIX TWO- THE
ALTERNATIVE BECAUSE THE
TERMINAL OPERATORS WOULD BE TO
ALLOW THE BREAK TRADERS TO PAY
FOR A GREAT EXPANSION INTO THE
COURTS AND UPSTREAM GREAT
EXPANSION TO SUPPORT THOSE TENS
OR HUNDREDS. OF MEGAWATTS THAT
WOULD NEED TO BE CERTAIN. IT
WILL NOT KNOW IT BACK COULD BE
DONE MARCH. GEN AVAILABLE
HYDROGEN INDUSTRY OF A GLOBAL I
TO COURT PARTICULARLY WHEN WE
IS CONCERNED. AND WHEN THE
UPTIME REPORT AND HAVING ENGINE
SURVIVE WITH A HIGH PERCENT
RELIABILITY CONCERNED SO IT CAN
NAY EBELING THE ANALYSIS TO BE
DONE COULD HYDROGEN SERVE THAT
VERY LARGE ELECTRIFICATION
BORROWED MORE. ECONOMICALLY
BENEFICIAL EIGHTY AND STILL
ACHIEVE ZERO CARBON EMISSIONS.
OKAY IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE WERE- ERIC IS ERIC
AVAILABLE BY PHONE AS HE CAN
GET ON THE PHONE BECAUSE IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAD
YOU THERE IS A- WE DIDN'T TOUCH
THE RATE. LANGUAGE BUT IT WAS
WORKED ON AND YOU SEE YOU SEE-
THERE WERE SOME AMENDMENTS
ADDED ON RELATING TO RATE
PAYERS- BUT YOU DON'T WANNA DO
THAT WE DID NOT COME IN
DESCRIBING DISCUSSION SENATOR
DURING ENERGY TOO MANY. THE
BOAT. MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS
THAT WE'RE NOT THERE'S NO WAY.
THE RATEPAYERS MAKE YOU CAN'T
AFFORD LIKE CHRISTINE
CALIFORNIA'S IT IS WE HAVE 42%
HIGHER THAN ANY OTHER STATE AND
I JUST THE WAY I READ THIS
BEFORE AN ANALYSIS I HAVE IT
SAYS RIGHT HERE THAT THE RATES
ARE GOING TO BE. THAT REPAIRS
WILL PICK UP. IT WILL BE PART
OF THE COST AND SO THAT MEANS
THAT IF THAT'S THE CASE THEN
THAT MEANS THAT SOMEWHERE RATES
ARE GONNA GO UP AND SO I'M
TRYING TO GET MY MIND AROUND
HOW THIS ACTUALLY WORKS THE
POLICY OF IT HOW HOW IT WORKS
IS. IF THE RATES ARE GONNA GO
UP. I'M TRYING TO JUST FIGURE
OUT WORKS I LOOK UP I WOULD IF
YOU IF WE HAVE A LOT OF EXCESS.
ENERGY AT CERTAIN TIMES OF THE
DAY WE HAVE THE DOCTOR BUT WELL
TALK ABOUT IT WE TALK ABOUT
ENERGY COMMISSION AND I WANTED
THAT TO GO FLAT THAT'S MY GOAL
IF WE COULD. TAKE THAT ENERGY
THAT WERE BASICALLY SHE
COULDN'T AGREED THAT DOESN'T DO
US ANY GOOD AND MAKE HYDROGEN
OUT OF IT HEY WE SHOULD BE
DOING THAT AND I THINK THAT
EVERYBODY ON THIS COMMITTEE WE
TALK ABOUT IT. BUT WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW THAT WORKS THE
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE WHERE DO
WE SITE THESE PROJECTS WHERE DO
WE HAVE ACCESS. EXTRA EXTRA
ENERGY DURING DOES THAT HOURS
OF THE DAY THAT WE ALL KNOW THE
DUCK CURVE IS MESSED UP WE NEED
TO TRANSFER THAT TO THE VALLEY
OF THE DOCK AND YOU KNOW WILL
REALLY BE DOING SOMETHING GREAT
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT AND I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW I
THINK HYDROGEN IS A HYDROGEN IS
A KEY TO THAT. I THINK THERE'S
I THINK WE NEED TO BE A
COMBINATION OF ALL DIFFERENT
TYPES OF STORAGE PROJECT BUT I
HAVEN'T SEEN THE POLICY HAD
THAT COMES THROUGH THE SAYS HEY
OKAY LOOK. IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WE HAVE THIS MANY
MEGAWATTS OF EXTRA POWER WHEN
THE SUN SHINING AND THE WINDS
BLOWING. THIS IS WHERE WE
SHOULD START TO PLAN AND BUILD
A HYDROGEN I HAVEN'T SEEN IT
YET SO FOR ME IT SEEMS LIKE IT
ALWAYS GOES BACK. TO THE RATE
PAYER AND- BECAUSE- BEING BEING
PICK UP THE COST OF. MAKING OUR
ENERGY. MORE RELYING OKAY SO
THAT'S WHAT I'M ASKING IS
TRYING TO TELL ME HOW THAT'S
GONNA WORK AND I DON'T SEE IT
IN THIS. OKAY DO THAT TO BE
FAIR THE SIMPSONS GOING BACK TO
PAGE SIX THE FAMOUS PAGE SIX OF
THIS BILL- THE AMENDMENT THE
CITY IF YOU LOOK IN THE ITALICS
IS ACTUALLY IN THE BILL- YOU
TALKED ABOUT. MEMBER I TALKED
ABOUT THE LANGUAGE ABOUT
POLLUTION. BOB IN ADDITION
THOUGH IT SAYS THE COMMISSION
SHALL NOT APPROVE ANY PROGRAM
OR INVESTMENT PURSUANT TO THIS
SUBDIVISION THAT WOULD RESULT.
THIS IS C. THREE. SUBBASAL NOT
APPROVE ANY PROGRAM THAT
RESULTS IN COST SHIFTS IN
CONSUMER RATES. RIGHT RIGHT SO
BUT WHAT DO YOU ARE YOU FEELING
LIKE THAT'S NOT WHAT'S YOUR
WHAT'S YOUR CONCERN. WELL THAT
THIS IS THIS WAS A MAMMOTH
THREE THOUSAND WOMEN IN ENERGY
COMMITTEE. THIS CAN. WHAT IS
NEEDED I WAS N THAT WAS THAT
WAS THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT
ENERGY IMPOSED- LISTEN PRINT
AFTER. FIVE I KNOW CENTER STERN
HAD AND SOME COMPSON SOME
THOUGHTS ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
EJECUTIVAS OVER THERE AND TO BE
FRANK HONESTLY I I'M ACTUALLY
CONSIDER YOU GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THE GREEN HYDROGEN BILLS
COMING UP ON THE THAT SKINNER
SKINNER STILL I I'M ACTUALLY
WONDERING WHETHER WE MIGHT WANT
TO DISCONTINUE THIS BILL TO
THURSDAY SO WE GET SOME OF
THESE ISSUES CLARIFIED. YOU
KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE A NUMBER THE
ISSUES RELATING TO CENTER
SKINNER SPELL ARE STILL BEING
CRYSTALLIZING THEY'RE DIRECTLY
RELATED TO SEASON IN THIS BILL
AND SO I'M BEGINNING TO BELIEVE
THAT MIGHT BE THE RIGHT COURSE
OF ACTION LET'S GO TO YOU
CENTER STERN. TO THE ENERGY
NOBODY INTERRUPT YOUR COM. I
WAS JUST I WAS JUST GONNA POINT
OUT THAT IN ENERGY COMMITTEE.
CENTER DR THE AMENDMENT CENTER
ARCHULETA TOOK. PREVENTED-
INVENTED THE ANY OF THESE COST
BEING BORNE BY ALL RATE PAYERS.
I MEAN YOU COULD SHIFT COSTS
SAVE THE PORT BUILT SOME OF
THAT HUNDRED INFRASTRUCTURE
THEY COULD PUSH THOSE COSTS ON
TO THOSE WHO AREN'T BENEFITING
FROM IT SO THAT'S WHAT THE
CAUTIOUS LANGUAGE DOES IF I
COULD. JUST CLARIFY THAT FOR
THE COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION
IT IT OUT IT MAKES IT CLEAR
THAT THE BENEFICIARY- HADES AS
OPPOSED TO THE GENERAL RATE
BASE NOW THAT STILL IS
TECHNICALLY RATE BASING IT TO
SOME EXTENT BUT- ANYWAY. OUR
CENTER AND SALAS FOR PERSONAL
SKINNER YES THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND- I KNOW SENATE
ARCHULETA WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS QUITE A BIT IN AND THANK
YOU FOR INVITING ME TO GO SEE
AT CAL STATE LA AND YOU KNOW I
HAVE A HYDROGEN FUEL- CHARGING
AND STATIONS IN MY BACKYARD IN
THE PORT AS WELL BUT I THINK
YOU KNOW WHAT I WAS GONNA SAY
THIS IS NOT COMING TO
TRANSPORTATION SO I WANTED TO
LEAN IN HERE BUT- KIND OF SURE
THE SAME. IS THE SAME- CONCERNS
AS WELL OF COURSE- WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE LANGUAGE THE
BILL LANGUAGE EVOLVES WITH
THEIR CURRENT NEEDS OF COURSE.
AND IT INVOLVED EVOLVES WITH
ARE ARE. YOU KNOW COMMUNITY
NEEDS TO- IT. NEEDS TO SPECIFY
AND I WASN'T SURE EITHER
WHETHER IT ACTUALLY IS
SPECIFIED AND I THINK. WE'VE
DISCUSSED THAT UP THEIR TELEX
ON THE ON THE BOTTOM HERE. THAT
INCLUDES. THOUGH THE WORDS
REDUCTION- VERSES THE NO NET
INCREASE. AND THAT WAS BROUGHT
UP AS WELL AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
ALTHOUGH THAT WASN'T THE
PURVIEW OF ENERGY COMMITTEE IT
WAS JUST BASED ON THE- COST. OF
THE COST SHIFT ISSUE- SO I KNOW
YOU'LL CONTINUE WORKING ON
THIS- BUT I KNOW THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF DISCUSSIONS THAT WE
STILL NEED TO HAVE BUT I'D LOVE
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU
SPECIFICALLY AS CHAIR
TRANSPORTATION AS WELL. YEAH
OKAY. THANK YOU I SO I WANT TO.
LET'S GET EVERYONE'S COMMENTS.
BUT I THINK WE'RE GONNA PUT
THIS OVER TO THURSDAY IF YOU
WE'VE GOT. IT YOU KNOW I. DID
JUST A NUMBER OF THINGS I WANT
TO GET CLARIFIED AND I WANT TO.
BUY I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR. DOING SUCH A
DEEP DIVE. THERE'S JUST A
NUMBER OF LOOSE ENDS AND THE
GOOD NEWS IS WE'VE GOT CENTER
SCARES BILLS COMING UP ARE. THE
START OF NEXT HEARING IS
LITERALLY THIS WEEK SO IT'S NOT
GOING TO HARM- YOU KNOW THE
ABILITY OF YOUR BILL TO. TO
MOVE. YOU KNOW. YOU KNOW BUT I
JUST THINK THERE'S A NUMBER OF
LOOSE ENDS WE NEED TO GET TIED
UP. ABOUT IT BUT LET'S LET'S.
LET'S LET'S HEAR FROM SOME MORE
MEMBERS THAT WILL HELP TO
INFORM. OUR COMMITTEES
NEGOTIATION AND CLARIFICATION
AS THE WEEK GOES ON. I CENTER
SKINNER FALL BY CENTER BATES.
THE. ONLY THING I WAS GOING TO
ADDRESS THAT. WHY CERTAINLY. AT
ALL OF US HAVE. WHAT CONCERNS
ARE RATES. WE CAN HAVE HOWEVER
THAT THAT WAS THE PURVIEW OF
THE ENERGY COMMITTEE AND DAY
DID ACT SO AGAIN YOU KNOW IF
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE SEIZE
STILL SKEPTICAL ABOUT WHETHER
THE ACTION WAS ADEQUATE-
OBVIOUSLY DEAD BUT THAT'S NOT
THE PURVIEW OF. WELL WHAT. KIND
OF WORDS THE ENERGY COMMITTEE
DEALT WITH THAT PART SO FAR
PRT IS MUCH MORE IN DQ PART SO
IN I PERSONALLY FILLED LIKE THE
WAY THE AMENDMENT THAT
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED WHICH- I
WOULD JUST WASN'T SURE FROM MY
STAFF SPEAKING AFTER THAT
WHETHER THE COMMITTEE WAS
ASKING THAT IT BE TAKEN BUT I
THINK WITH THE DATA MANAGEMENT.
THAT THE BILL IS IN A GOOD
SHAPE. SO I- I WOULD RESPECT
THE CHAIRS WELL IT WILL BE A
DESIRE TO MOVE IT TO THURSDAY
HOWEVER. I'M READY TO VOTE
TODAY ON IT WITH AMENDED. YEAH
I THINK I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
WE'RE OFFERING OUR MEMBERS SO
MANY QUESTIONS I DO THINK THAT
pHAPPENED INCLUDING THIS
AMENDMENT THAT WILL. ALLOW A
LOT OF THE CONCERNS BUT I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE. THAT ALL THESE
ISSUES ARE BEING BROUGHT UP TO
THE MEMBERS ARE GIVEN ADEQUATE
TIME TO REVIEW EXACTLY WHAT OUR
COMMITTEES TO AND YOU CAN SEE
THE LANGUAGE. IT IS ANY
ADDITIONAL- THINGS YOU WANT TO
ADD IN OR OR OR BRING INTO THE
DISCUSSION IN ADVANCE OF
THURSDAY THAT WE CAN JUST GET
EVERYONE ON THE SAME PAGE EVER
FEELING MORE COMFORTABLE. WE
CAN ALSO SEE HOW IT EVOLVES AND
IN COORDINATION INDEED AS AS
YOU'RE ENGAGING IN YOUR
NEGOTIATIONS ON YOUR BILL. SOME
APPS BUT- SENATE RATES ARE JUST
WANTED TO SAY ON SENATOR
ARCHULETA I'M- HE SUPPORTIVE OF
YOUR EFFORTS TO MOVE IN THIS
DIRECTION ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS
HE IN CONGESTED TRAFFIC AND SEE
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE ALL NEED
TO GET YOU KNOW OUR CAR PLUGGED
IN BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN SITTING
HERE FOR FOUR HOURS WAITING FOR
THE- TRAFFIC TO CLEAR SO YOU
KNOW YOU'RE STARTING DOWN THE
RIGHT PASSED. IT'S JUST THE
RATE SHIFTED SO SIGNIFICANT ONE
AT EVERY LEVEL OF SO THAT NEEDS
TO BE CLARIFIED AND THEN I WILL
BE A STRONG SUPPORTER. OKAY ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR. BOB GIVE ANY COMMENTS
YOU WANT TO MAKE TO US AS WE
ENGAGE AND THEN AND THEN AND
THEN LET'S WILL COME BACK ON
THURSDAY. OKAY IT MAY I THANK
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE IN THE
TRACHSEL TO OPEN UP THIS ENTIRE
TECHNOLOGY. AND I AM MORE HAPPY
TO SHARE WHATEVER INFORMATION
WE HAVE. WITH SOME OF THE
REQUEST THAT YOU'VE MADE. AND
WORK WITH THE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE SO WE CAN COME BACK
ON THURSDAY. AND FINALIZED. AND
FINE TUNE SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. OKAY THANK YOU
HOPE BOTH OF ONE. MESS OF YOUR
TRAVEL PLANS FIGURES TO EVENT-
BUT- WHAT WILL WILL GO TO. ANY
DENNIS OF. BRIDGET BRIDGETT U.
S. SENATOR THING AND I JUST
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR. A VERY MEANINGFUL GROW BY
EVERYBODY WAITED WITH
MEANINGFUL COMMENTS AND- WE
WANNA GET THIS RIGHT SO. A GOOD
THANK YOU SENATOR MANY MEMBERS
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. OKAY LET'S
GO NEXT TO ITEM EIGHT THIS IS
YOUR BUILDING AND SALAS. SB SIX
SEVENTY ONE ON TRANSPORTATION
CLEAN FREE QUARTER EFFICIENCY
SYSTEM YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN. WHEN
READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I AGREE GREAT
DISCUSSION BY ALL- THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS FOR SB SIX SEVENTY
ONE AND I THINK THAT. COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS FOR WORKING WITH
US- THE MEASURE IS A CRITICAL.
IS CRITICAL IN PLANNING FOR THE
FUTURE OF CLEAN FREIGHT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA- AS WE KNOW IT'S THE
BACKBONE OF OUR CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY MOVING TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF GOODS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. EACH YEAR. AT THE SAME
TIME FREE QUARTERS ARE ALSO A
MAJOR SOURCE OF GREENHOUSE. GAS
EMISSIONS AND HARMFUL AIR
POLLUTANTS THESE AIR POLLUTANTS
INCLUDE PARTICULATE MATTER
DIESEL PARTICULATE MATTER.
NITROGEN OXIDE SULFUR OXIDE
WHICH CAUSE CANCER ASTHMA. SB
SIX SEVENTY ONE TACKLES THIS
ISSUE BY REQUIRING THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. TO COLLABORATE WITH
OTHER RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES
INCLUDING THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD. TO DEVELOP STRATEGIES TO
CONVERT EXISTING FREE QUARTERS
INTO CLEAN FREE QUARTERS. THE
STRATEGIES THAT ARE DEVELOPED
AS PART OF THE CLEAN FREIGHT
CORRIDOR. EFFICIENCY ASSESSMENT
WILL THEN BE FOR HOLD INTO. THE
STATE'S AGING FUNDING PROGRAMS
AND GUIDELINE RELATED FREIGHT
IN ORDER TO DRIVES. SHE IN HOW
WE PRIORITIZE SUSTAINABLE IN
FREIGHT. WE'VE ALSO INCLUDED A
NUMBER OF EQUITY MEASURES AS
WELL. AND TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
TODAY I HAVE A RUSH DILLON THE
SENIOR POLICY MANAGER FROM
BREED SO CAL. AND MICHAEL
TURNER THE DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER. AFRICAN GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR ELLIE METRO I
THINK YOU AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE WHEN APPROPRIATE SB
SIX SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU
CENTER. IT'S CLEAR WITNESSES MR
WITH THE MEMORIZED ON. A LARGE
COMMUNITY YES BURGLAR. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS OF MOMS
ROCHDALEAND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THREE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SEVEN ONE. BILL SENCILLAS FOR A
CLEAN BREAK CORD OR ADDITIONS
THE ASSESSMENT SOMETHING THAT
WE DESPERATELY NEED FROM A
HEALTH PERSPECTIVE. CURRENTLY
DOMINATED BY DIESEL WHICH IS
EXTREMELY HARMFUL TO PUBLIC
HEALTH THE HELP AFFECTED SO SEE
THAT WOULD BE- INCLUDE
CARDIOVASCULAR AND RESPIRATORY
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND SOMETIMES
EVEN PREMATURE DEATH. A CLEAN
RECORD OR QUESTIONS YES ASPEN
IS NOT VERY TO ACHIEVE HEALTH
EQUITY AND IMPROVE PUBLIC
HEALTH OUTCOMES IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING THE HIGHEST USED.
AIR POLLUTION LEVELS MANY
CALIFORNIA NEIGHBORHOODS
ESPECIALLY BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES EXPLAINING TO ME
THAT THE CONTRACT TRAFFIC INTO
THE PORTS RAIL YARDS AND
WAREHOUSES. THESE COMMUNITIES
BEAR THE BRUNT OF DIESEL
POLLUTION. WE NEED A CLEAN
RECORD OR EFFICIENCY ASSESSMENT
TO ADDRESS THE HEALTH EQUITY
ISSUE BY GETTING CLEAN TRUCKS
ON THE ROAD TO MITIGATE DIESEL
POLLUTION AND ARE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. LASTLY IN ORDER TO
IMPLEMENT THESE NECESSARY
CHANGES THE ASSESSMENT PROCESS
MUST BE INTERDISCIPLINARY WE
NEED IMPORTANT ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE THE CDC. AND EVERY SOURCES
BOARD WORKING TOGETHER TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS NOT DISPLACING
RESIDENTS AND THE PLAN THAT
EQUITABLE FOR THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WOULD BE IMPACTED. THREE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA URGES YOUR
SUPPORT AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NEXT
YEAR FROM MICHAEL TURNER FROM
ELEMENTARY. THANK YOU SURE
ALLEN IN- THE MICHAEL TURNER ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
AND I LIKE TO CONVEY OUR
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX SEVENTY ONE
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK CARE
GONZALEZ FOR CARRYING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. SB SIX
SEVENTY ONE ADDRESSES ONE OF
THE KEY TRANSPORTATION ISSUES
IN OUR REGION EMISSIONS FROM
THE GOODS MOVEMENT SECTOR WILL
FULLY UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE SECTOR OF THE ECONOMY TO
OUR REGION WE ALSO SEE THE
IMPACT IT HAS IN TERMS OF
CONGESTION ON OUR FREEWAYS AS
WELL. WHAT ISN'T SO VISIBLE IN
THE AIR QUALITY IMPACTS OF
GOODS MOVEMENT ON KEY QUARTERS
IN OUR STATE. SB SIX SEVENTY
ONE PROVIDE STRONG TOOLS TO
ASSESS THE IMPACT OF FREEDOM
MISSIONS ON IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES AND PROVIDE A
PATHWAY TO ADDRESS THOSE
EMISSIONS THROUGH EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND RESOURCES. THREE
QUARTERS OF LOS ANGELES CROSS
TRUE HISTORICALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES BUT AS A REMNANT
ABOUT FREEWAYS WERE PLANNED AND
BUILT IN LOS ANGELES THAT IS
ALSO LEFT A LEGACY OF LASTING
POLLUTION IN THOSE SAME
COMMUNITIES. SB SIX SEVENTY ONE
PROVIDES A FORMALIZED WAY IN
WHICH TO ASSESS THESE IMPACTS
BY TAKING ADVANTAGE OF EXISTING
PROCESS SEES IT THEN PROVIDES A
PATHWAY TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES
BY LEVERAGING EXISTING
RESOURCES THE BILL ALSO
DEMONSTRATES THAT WE CAN FIX
THINGS FIRST AND FIX THINGS
RIGHT AT THE SAME TIME. SECURE
THE CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
THIS BILL IN ORDER SUPPORT
THANK YOU TO TURN APPRECIATE
THAT OKAY LET'S- I DON'T SEE
ANYONE HERE IN PERSON OR IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES YOU WANNA TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF SB SIX SEVENTY
ONE. BUT IT IS SOMETIMES SILVA
TO SHOW. FOR SB SIX SEVEN TWO
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THERE
AT THIS TIME. FIRST TIME IT
WILL COME FROM ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
BUT- YES GOOD MORNING- MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS DID YOU LEAVE
MALACHOWSKI PAUL I'LL BE HAPPY
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF XP SB SIX SEVENTY
ONE THANK YOU. CONNECT COMMENT
TO STREAMLINE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO LAURA
PART AND YOU HAVE A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. FOR BRITAIN
ADDITIONAL INTEREST PART AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU OKAY LET'S
GO TO OPPOSITION FOLKS WANT TO
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE REGISTERED
OPPOSITION OR ANY WE OPPOSITION
WITNESS. BUT NOBODY IN HERE IN
PERSON OR IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR WHO WANTS TO RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
OPPOSITION SB SIX SEVENTY ONE.
FOR A POSITION FOR SB SIXTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THE FAMILY OF KNOWING
TREPIDATION OKAY I WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS THOUGHTS COMMENTS
CENTER SKINNER- WINS PROCREATE
OR MOVE THE BILL. AS A OF A-
REP OF A NOTHER- IN ONE OF OUR
SIGNIFICAN PORTS OBVIOUSLY NOT
AS LARGE AS THE PORTS IN
SENATOR DOLE'S WHOSE DISTRICT-
A. R. MY AREA ALSO HAS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT GOODS MOVEMENT
CORRIDORS AND WE IT IS WHILE
EVERYONE IS IMPACTED BY THE
POLLUTION FROM THESE FREIGHT
CORRIDORS THOSE MOST IMPACTED
OR THE NEIGHBORHOODS MOST CLOSE
BY BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE
MOVE DATE VITAL THAT'S WHERE
THEY'RE IN THE WORST TRAFFIC
CONGESTION AND SUCH AND THEIR
THEIR EMISSIONS ARE THE WORST
AND WE NOTE THAT IN WHEN WE
COMES TO. THE NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS IT IS THE DIESEL
EMISSIONS PRIMARILY FROM OUR
HEAVY DUTY BUT NOT ONLY BUT
PRIMARILY FOR MORE HEAVY DUTY.
GOOD TO CORD OR TRUCKS THAT ARE
CAUSING THAT- HEALTH IMPACT SO
THE MOREWE CAN DO THE BETTER I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE CENTER
BRING THE BILL AND AS I
INDICATED THAT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME- I WILL THE BEST. THANK
YOU FOR THE SENATE. I KNOW JUST
WANNA CLARIFY YOU YOU ARE
TAKING THE- THESE MINOR THESE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE SUGGEST.
GREAT OKAY THE CONSTITUTIONAL
ACADEMIA MOVEMENT SPECIFICALLY
MENTIONING BRIDGES FOR STUDY
HOW HAVE YEARS AS AFFECT ROSES
KINDS OF THINGS ARE AN IMMENSE
ALL RIGHT. EIGHT FIVE MOVE BY
CENTER SKINNER ANY FINAL
COMMENTS NOW WILL LET YOU CLOSE
AND I'M IS GONNA SAY THANK YOU
AGAIN TO THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS AND I WANT TO THANK
MISTER DILLON MISTER TURNER FOR
THEIR- TESTIMONY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU OKAY. ALRIGHT
LET'S- LET'S CALL THE ROLL
SECRETARY PLEASE KALRA. ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB SIX SEVEN ONE
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ THEM. ****
AMENDED THE FIRST. AMENDED AND
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. ALLEN HI. HI
ALLEN AYE BATES. FIVE EIGHT
FIVE DAILY. DALY AYE GONZALEZ
HI. I SKINNER. SKINNER AYE
STERN. BURKE OWSKI HI MY COUNTY
I. OKAY AND WILL HOLD THAT OPEN
FOR CENTERS KERN SINISTER AND
OUT ON. PINE FACTORS AND SPOKE
TO PRESENT THE NEXT BILL. BUT
HE'S NOT ON CAMERA THIS IS GO
AHEAD WITH A TWO FIFTY FOUR
OKAY ALL RIGHT LET'S DO THAT
AND THEN WILL WILL- THEY WILL
GO BACK TO AND- THE CENTRE
STARNES AFTER SB FIFTY FOUR SO
I WILL. PASSED THE GAVEL TO MY
ESTEEM BOOSTER THANK YOU.
WORKERS ARE ALLEN FIFTY MEMBERS
THAT IS PRESENT I WILL KEEP
THIS BRIEF I KNOW YOU'RE VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THIS THIS ISSUE
IN THIS BILL- IT'S BASICALLY A
REINTRODUCTION OF LAST YEAR'S
BILL. THE IDEA IS THAT SB FIFTY
FOUR- SEEKS TO. REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF DISPOSABLE SINGLE USE
PACKAGING IN FOOD WHERE WASTED
BURDENS TAXPAYERS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS PLAGUES- ART PUTS
OUR OUR NATURAL ENVIRONMENT AND
ALSO IMPACTS HUMAN HEALTH
WE'VE- LOOKED A BIT INTO SOME
OF THE TOXICITY ASSOCIATED.
WITH ALL THE PLASTICS THAT ARE
GETTING INTO OUR BODIES. HERE'S
SOME FACTS WE ALL HEARD FIRST
WHAT. LILLY LESSONS PERCENT OF
SINGLE USE PLASTIC IS ACTUALLY
RECYCLED. THE COST OF RECYCLING
IT IS NOW EXCEEDING THE SCRAP
VALUE OF THE PLASTIC MATERIAL
ITSELF. I NEARLY EVERY PER
PIECE OF PLASTIC IT'S PRODUCED
IT'S EVER BEEN PRODUCED IT
STILL EXISTS IN OUR LANDFILLS
STILL EXISTS IN THE ENVIRONMENT
THESE ITEMS FRAGMENT INTO
SMALLER AND SMALLER PART
PARTICLES. NOT CONCENTRATING
TOXIC CHEMICALS AND
CONTAMINATING OUR FOOD AND
DRINKING WATER SOURCES WE'RE
ALL APPARENTLY CONSUMING ABOUT
A CREDIT CARDS WORTH. OF
PLASTIC EACH WEEK. INTO OUR
BODIES SAID THAT SOME OF YOU
GUYS GOT A CHANCE TO SIT IN ON
ON THE CELL NUMBER CORKS
HEARING WHICH TALKED ABOUT. THE
FACT THAT A MAJORITY OF HUMAN
PLACENTAS NOW HAVE. MORNING
LEVELS OF PLASTIC THAT ARE
BEING- IT POTENTIALLY PASSING
ON THAT TOXICITY TO. NEWBORN
BABIES. SO THIS EXPOSURE IS
GOING TO PLAY CANCERS BIRTH
DEFECTS AND IMPAIRED IMMUNITY
ENDOCRINE DISRUPTION AND OTHER
SERVICE YOURSELF PROBLEMS IT'S
ALSO BECOMING A- FINANCIAL
ISSUE. FOR OUR COMMUNITY START
GUIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BEEN
ABOUT HALF A BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR NOW ON. ON ON LITTER
CLEANUP AND LITTER PREVENTION-
BUT THEY'RE ALSO IMPORTANTLY
AND THIS GETS TO SOME OF THE
ISSUES WE TALKED ABOUT A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO. YOU'LL REMEMBER THIS
CONVERSATION CENTER DOLLY
CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE NOW
RAISING THEIR GARBAGE AND
RECYCLING RATES TO KEEP UP WITH
THE MOUNTING COSTS OF MANAGING
ALL THE MATERIAL IT'S
ULTIMATELY OUR- VOTERS ARE.
TAXPAYERS REPAIRS THAT ARE
PAYING MORE AND MORE. TO
ADDRESS THE FACT THAT THE
PRODUCERS HAVE NO SKIN IN THE
GAME OF THE GUARDS OF THE
PRODUCTS THEY'RE PUTTING OUT ON
TO THE MARKET. SO SINCE COUNTY
SACRAMENTO JUST RAISE THE RATES
ADDITIONAL TEN DOLLARS A MONTH.
TO HANDLE THE WASTE MANAGEMENT
CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE HAVING
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS
HERE WITH THIS BILL WHICH IS.
SEEKS TO ESTABLISH A
COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORK. TO
ADDRESS THIS POLLUTION AND
WASTE. RACES IN THREE KEY WAYS
OF ALL IT'S- BE. THE COSTS OF
THE END OF LIFE MANAGEMENT OF
THIS MATERIAL TO THE PRODUCERS
WHO ARE ULTIMATELY THE ONES WHO
REALLY DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT A
PACKAGE FOR YOU KNOW WHAT
WHETHER NOT TO THE- TO PACKAGE
THEIR THEIR PRODUCT IN
RECYCLABLE CONTAINER OR SOME.
MULTILAYERED POUCH THE WHILE
CONVENER FLASHY. BECOMES TRASH
THE CLOGS OUR LANDFILLS WE'VE
WE'VE- COME ACROSS SITUATIONS
WHERE- PRODUCERS WILL LITERALLY
CHANGE THE RESIN TYPE IN A
BOTTLE. NO DO IT FOR IN A
STATIC REASON AND THAT DECISION
WILL SINGLE HANDEDLY RENDER
THAT ITEM NON RECYCLABLE IT
MEANS THAT THAT ITEM INSTEAD OF
BEING- SENATOR RECYCLING SYSTEM
IS NOW. GOING STRAIGHT TO THE
LANDFILL AND F COURSE IT'S US
IT'S THE TAXPAYERS THE REPAIRS
THAT ARE PAYING THE COST. OF
THAT EVEN THOUGH IT'S THE
PRODUCER WHO'S MAKING THE
DECISION WITH LITTLE OR NO
ACCOUNTABILITY OR SKIN IN THE
GAME MORE. RESPONSIBILITY
ASSOCIATED. THE SET UP THE
FIRST THING. THE SECOND ISSUE
IS SOURCE REDUCTION SO ASKING
THEM TO YOUR RIGHT SIZE THEIR
PACKAGING AND MOVE TOWARD
REUSABLE SO. WHEREVER THEY CAN.
AND THEN LASTLY REQUIRING THE
MATERIAL. THAT DOES REMAIN IN
THE MARKETPLACE BE TRULY
RECYCLABLE OR COMPOSTABLE WITH
METRICS TO BACK THAT UP- AND
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES THIS HAS TO
DO WITH MOVING FOLKS THAT
THERE'S LOTS OF TYPES OF
PLASTIC WE TALKED ABOUT YOU
KNOW THE NUMBERS. ONE THREE
SEVEN AND- AND SOMETIMES IF A
PRODUCER SIMPLY JUST CHANGES
THEIR PLASTIC USE FROM A THREE
TO A TWO. THAT ACTUALLY RENDERS
THE ITEM RECYCLABLE- IT'S THE
YOU KNOW- DID BUT RIGHT NOW
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO- THERE'S
THEY HAVE NO SKIN IN THE GAME
ASSOCIATED WITH MAKING THAT
DECISION. SO WE KNOW THIS IS A
TOUGH AND COMPLICATED ISSUE WE
SPENT THE BETTER PART OF THE
TWO AS TWO AND A HALF YEARS. IN
DETAILED DISCUSSIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS WE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS- YOU KNOW WE CAME VERY
CLOSE TO GETTING THE BILL
PASSED LAST YEAR THE POLICY
PASSED OUT OF THE SENATE. OF
THE BOTH IN EARLY FORM AND THEN
ALSO IN FINAL FORM- YOU KNOW
I'M NOT GIVING UP ON A
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION TO THIS
CRISIS WE KNOW THERE'S A BALLOT
MEASURE OUT THERE AS WELL-
THAT. DID YOU KNOW. THAT IS
THERE. ARE NONE. I KNOW THAT
THEY DID SOME OF OUR SUPPORTERS
ARE LESS OPTIMISTIC THAT WE CAN
GET A MEANINGFUL BILL THROUGH
BOTH HOUSES I'M NOT. YOU KNOW
THE I THINK SOME OF THEM ARE
PUTTING THEIR- THEIR ENERGY
INTO THE BALLOT MEASURE AND
THAT STILL MAY BE WHERE THIS
GOES BUT- BUT I ACTUALLY THINK
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE TO STEP UP. AND
DONE COME UP WITH OUR OWN
SOLUTIONS AND THAT WE CAN WORK
WITH THE MODIFY. SO ARE ANY HOW
THE BALLOT MEASURE IS PENDING
BEFORE COUNTY ELECTION
OFFICIALS BUT- YOU KNOW ALL ALL
APPEARANCES SEEM SUGGEST THAT
IT'S GOING TO QUALIFY. IT'S MY
SINCERE HOPE THAT THROUGH OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH LEGISLATORS
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO CRAFT A COMPREHENSIVE
FROM PROGRAM THAT. ACHIEVES ARE
ARE THREE GOALS A BILL THAT
WILL BE FLEXIBLE ENOUGH. TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS RAISED BY
INDUSTRY BUT STRONG ENOUGH TO
CONVINCE INITIATIVE PROPONENTS
TO COME BACK TO THE TABLE. I'M
CONFIDENT WE CAN DO THAT- WITH
ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL'S DEREK DOLPHY AND I
WHICH WAS WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES THE LEAGUE
AND OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
BEEN WITH US EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY BECAUSE THEY- HAVE
ALTERNATELY BEEN. DEALING WITH
THE BURDEN ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
WASTE. AND IT ALSO JORDAN WELLS
WITH THE NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP
ACTION COUNCIL. THANK YOU
SENATOR. OUR MODERATOR. PLEASE
I HAVE OF THE- LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES COME ONLINE. AND I'M
NOT OT SURE IF IT'S DERRY GO
FEET FIRST AND THEN JORDAN
WELLS. PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS THEIR
DOLPHIN HAPPILY CALIFORNIA CITY
BUT HAPPY SUPPORTING CONTENT SB
FIFTY FOUR BY SENATOR ALAN
WHICH SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT
SINGLE USE PACKAGING OF
PRODUCTS ARE RECYCLABLE OR
COMPOSTABLE BY TWENTY THIRTY TO
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW CAL CITIES
ALONG WITH COUNTLESS OTHER
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WASTE HAULER
IN ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS
STRONGLY ADVOCATED FOR THE
PREVIOUS VERSION OF SB FIFTY
FOUR BY FOUNDER ALAN AND EIGHTY
TEN EIGHTY BY FROM THE NUMBER
INVOLVED WHICH SOUGHT TO
ACHIEVE A SIMILAR GOAL.
CALIFORNIA HAS REBUFFED
RECYCLING SYSTEM THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE SPENT BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO CREATE MAINTAIN
AND OPERATE HOWEVER THE WAY
CALIFORNIA RECYCLED HAS CHANGED
AND SO TOO MUST THE RECYCLING
SYSTEM CITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
HAVE SEEN THE COST OF RECYCLING
INCREASE IN ONCE RELIABLE
RECYCLED MATERIAL MARKET NO
LONGER EXIST. CHALCIDICE
CONDUCTED A SURVEY IN DECEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY THAT SHOWED
SEVEN OUT OF TEN CITY SURVEYED
ANTICIPATE OF SOLID WASTE AND
RECYCLING RATE INCREASED
BETWEEN ONE AND 20% IN THE NEXT
THREE YEARS A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO UPDATING AND
UPGRADING OUR RECYCLING SYSTEM
IS NEEDED WE CAN NO LONGER
FOCUS SOLELY ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COLLECTING AND
PROCESSING. WILL BE IN MIND AND
HAVE AN END MARKET FOR THEM HOW
DID HE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN
DEVELOPING APPROACH THANK YOU
AND REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF SINGLE
USE PLASTIC WASTE AND HELP
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND RESIDENTS
PAY LESS TO RECYCLE WE LIKE TO
THINK KINDER ALLEN FIRST
CONTINUE FOCUSING LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. NOT JUST
FOR CITIES BUT THE ENTIRE STATE
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY. THANK YOU NOW ON MR
WEALTH. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM VERY INVOLVED WITH
THE NATIONAL STORAGE OF ACTION
COUNCIL A NONPROFIT THAT
ADVOCATES FOR CIRCULAR ECONOMY
CALIFORNIA LOOK THE NATION IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WITH THE
INTRODUCTION OF ENATE BILL
FIFTY FOUR IT SHOWED PRODUCERS
THAT CALIFORNIA WOULD NO LONGER
ALLOW THEM TO PRIVATIZE THE
PROFITS. ALL EXTERNALIZING AND
SOCIALIZING THE COSTS ON TO
PEOPLE AND PLANET. BRING ME
OVER TWO YEARS SINCE SB FIFTY
FOUR WAS FIRST INTRODUCED. WE
HAVE LOST BROWN AND WASTED TIME.
THE GOOD NEWS IS CALIFORNIA'S
EFFORTS OVER THE PAST TWO PLUS
YEARS HAVE ENCOURAGE EFFORTS IN
OTHER STATES INCLUDING MAINE
MASSACHUSETTS NEW YORK OREGON
AND VERMONT. BUT IF WE DO NOT
GET THIS DONE CALIFORNIA WILL
EFFECTIVELY CEDED LEADERSHIP ON
THIS GROUND BREAKING POLICY
WHICH HAS THE WORLD'S FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IS
UNACCEPTABLE. PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY IS NOT NOW THERE
ARE OVER FOUR HUNDRED E. CARE
PROGRAMS IN THE WORLD IN
CALIFORNIA LED THE NATION BY
PASSING THE FIRST EXTENDED
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY LAW FOR
PHARMACEUTICAL THE NEEDLES. AND
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. IT IS A
PROVEN POLICY APPROACH THAT IS
WIDELY UTILIZED IN COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD INCLUDING
TWENTY FIVE COUNTRIES IN THE E.
U. CANADA BRAZIL AND ISRAEL TO
NAME A FEW. AND I COMPANIES
OPERATING THESE PROGRAMS THAT
OTHER COUNTRIES ARE THE SAME
COMPANIES THAT CLAIM THEY CAN'T
DO IT HERE. BUT THEY CAN AND
THE PROOF IS THAT THE ALREADY
JAILED. CALIFORNIA MUDSLIDE THE
US ONCE AGAIN. BEATING SENATOR
ALAN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND
URGE THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
SUPPORT THE STYLE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AS WELL SO WE'LL I
DON'T SEE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF THE COMPUTERS IN
THE WAY NO ONE IN TWENTY FORTY.
THERE'S NO WAY TO TWENTY FORTY
THEN OUR- MODERATOR PLEASE-
OPEN THE LINES FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIFTY FOUR. JUSTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. PINE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR MEMBERS KALIFAT COUNTERCLAIM
AND ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA INTO COURT AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT CONGRESS
CONTINUE TO WORK ON OUR ON THE
BALLOT. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE ONE OH TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOODAFTERNOON SENATOR
DEVELOPMENT SALAS WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU. BY
NINETY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. MY
GOD CANCEL CONSUMER WATCHDOG
PLEASE RECORD SB FIFTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WHY NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
NOTES ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA APART THANK YOU.
FINE ONE AWAIT YOU ARE OPEN.
ISABEL'S STORY REPRESENTING
INDIVISIBLE STATE STRONG-
COALITION EIGHTY ONE GROUPS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. FIND ONE HUNDRED TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOT ONLY
REGARD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS AND SUPPORT
AS WELL AS ON BEHALF OF SEVENTH
GENERATION SUPPORT THE CONCEPT
THANK YOU. BY NINETY THREE
PLEASE CALL AT. MUMBLING ALONG-
WE WILL GO. TO NINE ONE
FIFTEEN. HELLO AT LEAST QUALIFY
AND MEMBER OF THE GLENDALE
ENVIRONMENTAL COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. BY ONE FORTY
YOU ARE OPEN. HI JENNIFER
TANNER- IN THE IMMENSELY STRONG
SUPPORT FROM INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA THIRTY THREE AND
ALSO PUT EIGHTY ONE GOOD FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE STRONG
THANK YOU. SUTTER SAID FIND ONE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
JUST SIXTEEN I'M SORRY WHITE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING MY COOPER FOR
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE- WE
ARE ACTUALLY NOT SUBMIT A
LETTER YET BUT DID WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND STAFF FOR
THEIR CHILDREN WORK ON THIS
ISSUE OVER THE LAST. THREE
YEARS THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE
ONE OH SIX YOU ARE OPEN. HI
THIS IS ELISE FUNDRAISER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND ALSO
CALLING IN ON BEHALF OF A TOOL
IN SUPPORT AND THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THE CONTINENTAL. BY NINETY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
THIS IS A WILL KRIEGER ON
BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT. NINE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
HEARING HEARING CAN WITH THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FIFTY FOUR
AND THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN. BY
NINETY NINE YOU ARE OPEN. HI
STEPHANIE GROUND WORK TOGETHER
WE WILL INDIVISIBLE MOSCATO
JOINING AND WITH CALIFORNIA
STATE STRONG INDIVISIBLE OTHER
EIGHTY CHAPTERS AND STRONG
SUPPORT. BY ONE OH NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS GENEVIEVE
ABIT ON ON BEHALF OF THE CLEAN
LOBBYING COALITION IN SUPPORT-
AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN. BY ONE
OH THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. KATHY
SAY FIRST SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. PINE FORTY
ONE EUROPE. BY TONY GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF COMER IN NORTH
AMERICA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU. BUT- FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MONICA
COMPAGNON WITH THE GLENDALE
ENVIRONMENTAL COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY FOUR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ON. BY ONE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANY
WORK AND OPEN AYE MY
CONSTITUENT AND SENATOR ALLEN
MEMBER AT INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA THIRTY THREE AND IS
BANNED SINGLE USE PLASTIC IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. FINE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS BARBARA KRUGER I AM A
MEMBER OF INDIVISIBLE EAST BAY
AND ALSO- CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG AND A CONSTITUENT OF
SENATOR SKINNER IN SUPPORT
STRONGLY. AND LINE ONE ELEVEN
YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
CHERYL AUGER AND I'M PRESIDENT
OF BAND SINGLE USE PLASTICS AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR BEN ALLEN
FOR CONTINUING WITH SB FIFTY
FOUR. AND AS A FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR
SB FIFTY FOUR. WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER ONE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT. THERE WE WILL GO TO
LINE. ONE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN THE WATER
WITH CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU. AND
THERE ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU THEN WILL NOW GO TO THOSE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTY FOUR AND
WE DO HAVE A LEAD OFF FROM THE
CALCHAMBER ANIMAL WITH RETAIL.
SEE HE ON THE LINE MODERATOR.
PLEASE GO AHEAD SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRED NUMBERS
COMMITTEE AT WRIGLEY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE CONTINUE HAVE A
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL TO BE CLEAR
OPPOSITION FOCUS IS REALLY ON
SB FIFTY FOUR THE
REINTRODUCTION OF THE
CALIFORNIA CIRCULAR ECONOMY
ACROSS THE- POLLUTION REDUCTION
ACT INTRODUCED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. AT THE BILL FOR YOU
DAYS REALLY WORK IN PROGRESS
WITHOUT MANY OF THE PROVISIONS
CONTAINED AND- PRIOR SB FIFTY
FOUR VERSIONS I DO WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING CENTER ALLEN
FOR HIS CONTINUED LEADERSHIP
AND ENGAGEMENT ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT SUBJECT MATTER. OFTEN
CENTERED AROUND NOT ONLY
ADVANCE IT'S IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION BUT ALSO-
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT PUBLIC
POLICY CONVERSATIONS LIKE WHAT
WE'RE HAVING HERE TODAY THAT
LEAD AT THE MORE INFORMED-
POLICIES AND LAWS. BURKE WITH
THE CENTER THAT IT IT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS
DEFICIENCIES IN OUR MANAGEMENT
AND RECYCLING OF PACKAGING
MATERIAL. AND COME UP WITH A
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION. TO
ADDRESS IN THE- GENERAL CONTENT
WITH SB FIFTY FOUR THIS
LAUDABLE AND ONE WE ACTUALLY
AGREE WITH THE CONCEPT. WE
SHARE THE GOAL OF CREATING A
COMPREHENSIVE POLICY OF
MANAGING OUR WASTE MATERIALS.
REDUCING UNNECESSARY PACKAGING
IN A CIRCULAR ECONOMY MODEL.
CREATING AND MARKETS SOURCE
OU'RE DOING MATERIAL SOURCE
REDUCING MATERIALS WERE
FEASIBLE. A FORTY POLLUTION OUR
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT. IS I NEED
FOR RECYCLABILITY AND BRINGING
MUCH NEEDED INVESTMENT THE
SYSTEM ALL ARE VERY NECESSARY
COMPONENTS TO ACHIEVING THE
SENATORS VISION. YET WHILE WE
SHARE THE GOAL WITH THE SENATOR
THERE HAS BEEN DISAGREEMENT.
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS ON THE
MECHANIC BE THE BILITY AN
IMPLICATION A PRIOR VERSION THE
BILL. WITH THE FINANCIAL IMPACT
THE FOOD AND AGRICULTURAL
SECTORS RETAIL JUST ABOUT EVERY
HOUSEHOLD AND CONSUMER SECTOR-
PROVIDING GOOD TO CONSUMERS AND
OTHER BUSINESSES. BUT IT IS
NOT. CALCHAMBER AND MEMBER
COMPANIES WELCOME CONTINUED
ENGAGEMENT IN GOOD FAITH THE
SENATOR HE STAFF AND THE
LEGISLATURE ON A COMPREHENSIVE
POLICY THAT ADVANCES THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY. OVER THE PAST
FEW YEARS AND AT THE CENTER AND
SUFFOCATED. THE COMPLEXITY WITH
THE ISSUE INCLUDING UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES REGRETTABLE
SUBSTITUTE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
BEEN SIGNIFICANT COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH CREATING THE
VISION. I HAVE BEEN
ILLUMINATED. AND HIGHLIGHT BOTH
REALLY TO SCALE THESE
CHALLENGES BEFORE US AND THE
NEED FOR FURTHER REFINEMENT OF
THESE POLICIES. WE HOPE THAT
THIS YEAR STAKEHOLDERS ON ALL
SIDES CAN OVERCOME THE
DEFICIENCIES. THAT WE HAVE
NOTED OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
SUCH AS- LACK OF CRITICAL
DEFINITION THE BILL WHICH WE
BELIEVE ARE NECESSARY TO THAT
MARKET THE GOLDEN ALLOW
COMPANIES TO DESIGN FOR
RECYCLABILITY. A LACK OF
STANDARDIZATION THAT HINDERS
ATTRACTING THE LARGE INVESTMENT
INTO THE SYSTEM- AND PROVIDING
CONSUMERS AND COMPANIES. WITH
CONSISTENT RECYCLING RULES.
DELEGATING WITH THIS
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY TO CARRY.
AND PROVIDING OUR WITH THE MORE
ROOM A- TO PUSH MADE REGULATE
UNDER DAY NOTE AND COMMENT.
CONDITIONAL SAILING LACK OF
FUNDING AND A LACK OF PATHWAY
TO BUILD THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO ACHIEVE THESE GOALS.
CALCHAMBER IN ITS MEMBER
COMPANIES REMAIN AT THE TABLE
WE WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
SOLUTIONS FOR THE DANCE IN THE
SENATORS VISION OF A CIRCULAR
ECONOMY THAT REDUCES WEIGHT.
INCREASES REAL RECYCLING AND
AVOID POLLUTION OUR NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT THAT. I HIT THEM IN
CALIFORNIA MERGES. THAT ALLOWS
FOR BOTH ECONOMIES ENVIRONMENTS
TO THE SERVER YOU NEED TO
THRIVE. WITH THAT I THANK THE
SENATOR AND-THE LEGISLATURE WE
CONTINUE LOOKING FORWARD TO.
FURTHER ENGAGE ON THE TOPIC
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I DON'T
SEE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM OFF
STEPPING OUT FOR A POSITION OR
IN TWENTY FORTY SO WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES. A MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYONE QUEUING UP
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. FIFTY FOUR.
SOME. OKAY. MOTHERCARE YEAH.
MISTER MODERATOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE LINES. OKAY. I
THINK IT WAS MUTED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. REPORTER. I DON'T THINK
WE'RE HEARING SOMEONE QUEUED UP
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IF YOU.
TO SHOW UP ARE YOU WAITING FOR
THE PUBLIC I'M IN ORDER WAITING
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION WHO ARE ON THE PHONE
LINES. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE OLD ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE ONE. THIS
IS GAIL DEL HANA ON BEHALF OF
THE THREE THOUSAND FRESH
PRODUCE FARMERS OF WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
CLOSED AND LYFT AMENDED. FOR
THE SAME REASONS EXPRESSED BY
THE CHAMBER I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR ALAN FOR THE CONTINUED
CONVERSATION. AND NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE. AB THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD EIGHTY THREE. HELLO THERE
NO COOKING ON A REPRESENTING
THE HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION THE PET
FOOD INSTITUTE AND THE NATIONAL
ERA POLITICIAN WE ARE ALL
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED AT THE
TIME BUT TO CREATE THE FOUNDERS
MARK AND WILL CONTINUE-
COMPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LINE ONE HUNDRED SIXTEEN
YOU ARE OPEN. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MANUALLY ON BEHALF OF
pTHE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNCIL ALSO OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED FOR THE REASONS STATED
THANK YOU. ONE ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTER NUMBERS THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO CARRY ON BEHALF OF
NEGLECT WE ALSO HAVE CURRENTLY
UNEMPLOYED LESS MANAGE THAT
YOUNG FELLOW UT WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE AUTHOR AND
HIS STAFF FOR CONTINUE TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY. THANK YOU.YOU
MUST MAKE YOUR MIND EIGHTY FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. SHASTA LAKE
AFTERNOON TAYLOR ROCHLIN
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU ALSO
OPPOSES MOST AMENDED FOR THE
REASONS NOTED THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN TO SHOW OPPOSITION TO SB
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AND WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
OH FIVE. THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS
BORN AYE YOU ARE REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE WERE
PACKAGING ON THE ENVIRONMENT
AND THE FLEXIBLE PACKAGING
ASSOCIATION ALSO AND IMPOSE
LESS AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU.
REALLY BY NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE JOE ACT WHERE WE'LL
BE AT THE PLASTICS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. WHY ONE TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE ALSO OPPOSE
UNLESSAMENDED FOR THE REASONS
STATED THANK YOU. STEVETDENT
SURE THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU THEN ARE
WITHOUT WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ON ANY QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATOR GONZALEZ I JUST WANNA
SAY AT THANK YOU AGAIN SENATOR
ALLEN I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN AT
THIS- YOU'RE FULLY COMMITTED I
KNOW WE'RE GONNA SAY THE THINGS
THAT WE WOULD CONTINUE TO BE
REPEATED BUT- HAPPY TO CONTINUE
TO CO AUTHOR AND BE IN THIS
JOURNEY WITH YOU I KNOW IT'S
NOT EASY- BUT WHAT I LOVE IN
THE ANALYSIS AS WELL AS I MEAN
IT STATES THE OBVIOUS BUT WE'RE
SEEING THE RETURN OF SINGLE USE
DURING THIS PANDEMIC AND SO I
THINK THAT IS JUST YOU KNOW
REGRESSING BACK TO WHERE WE
DON'T WANT TO GO AND I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS BUT WE-
WE NEED TO KEEP ADVANCING THIS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE ABSOLUTELY
NEEDS TO WEIGH IN. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE. IF YOU'RE SKINNER
THANK YOU- FINANCIER CENTER ON
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BACK- IF ANYTHING- WE IT'S TOO
LITTLE TOO LATE AND NOT AS A
CRITICISM TO YOU AND I WOULD
JUST SAY IN RESPONSE THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY COULD ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE THEY HAVE THEY COULD
CHOOSE NOT TO PROLIFERATE THE
PLASTICS THE CONSUMER IS NOT
DEMANDING THAT PLASTICS BE
PROLIFERATED THE LEVEL THAT
THEY ARE ESPECIALLY NOT SINGLE
USE A- A DISPOSABLE PLASTIC SO.
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT UNFORTUNATELY- BECAUSE WE
HAVE NOT PUT IN PLACE THE
PROPER REGULATIONS OR MARKET
SIGNALS TO- TO HAVE BUSINESS
DECIDE TO PERFORM OTHERWISE
WHICH THEY COULD HAVE ON THEIR
OWN WE HAVE TO ACT. AND I JUST-
I FIND IT DIFFICULT TO
ESPECIALLY IN HERE THE CHAMBERS
COMMENTS ABOUT- WHATEVER IT IS
YES- I THOUGHT MR GONZALEZ
ALREADY MOVED IT. DIDN'T DID
YOU KNOW. OKAY I MOVED THE BILL
THANK YOU AND I HOPE WE CAN GET
THIS DONE. THEN SENATOR ALLEN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YEAH I
MEAN JUST THINK MY COLLEAGUES
IN A STERN SUMMER CASKEY-
CENTER TWO THOUSAND AND CENTER
SKINNER WHO STAFF WAS WITH US
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY THE
DEVELOPING OF THIS BILL LAST
YEAR AND IN IN AND DIDN'T
PLAYED A REALLY CRITICAL ROLE
HELPING TO CONCEPTUALIZE THIS-
ENORMOUS ISSUE. AB YOU KNOW
WHAT. AS ALWAYS WE ARE SO
COMMITTED TO JUST. THAT I WAS
EVEN TALKING TO SENATE ALL
ABOUT THIS WITH A NUMBER OF
INDUSTRY GROUPS THAT CAME OUT
OPPOSITION AT THE BEGINNING-
TWO YEARS AGO. AND WHOSE ISSUES
WE WERE ABLE TO PAINSTAKINGLY
WORKED THROUGH. HERE THEM OUT
WORK THROUGH- I MEAN WE I HAVE
A LIST OF A PET PAGE ALONG THE
PROMINENT INDUSTRY GROUPS WHO
DROPPED THEIR OPPOSITION AT
SOME POINT OR ANOTHER DURING
THE COURSE OF THE NEGOTIATIONS.
OVER THE LAST SESSION AND SO
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE IN THAT
SPIRIT- BUT WE'RE GONNA KEEP
OUR EYES ON THE PRIZE GIVEN THE
ENORMITY THIS PROBLEM IN THE
IMPACT IT'S HAVING ON. NOT JUST
OUR ENVIRONMENT BUT ALSO OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN OUR
REPAIRS. POCKETBOOKS AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN
AND NOW CERTAINLY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS OVER THE
YEARS SO WITHOUT US. MEMBER
SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THE ITEM NUMBER. AS FIFTY FOUR
BY SENATOR ALAN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALLEN. I ALLEN
AYE BATES REGRETTABLY NO. AT
THE TABLE AND ONLY THIS VALLEY.
DALLY NOT VOTING GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ FIVE SKINNER ALL RIGHT
SKINNER AYE STERN- AND I Y.
CASKEY HI ASKI I'D- THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU. FRAZIER THAT
OKAY FINALLY WE ARE GOING TO
CENTER STERN WHO'S GOING TO
PRESENT SB FOUR TWENTY THREE.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY
SENATE OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN APOLOGIES FOR MISSING
THE ORDER- BEFORE I BEGIN
PRESENTATION I JUST WANT TO
FIRST THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS AND
ACCEPT THEIR MAINTENANCE- YOU
SEE THEM ON THE BOTTOM OF THE
PAGE SIX. WHICH STRIKES- FROM
SECTION TO THE BILL THE TERM
SCOPING PLAN AS A REPORT A OR
B. WOULD NOT HAVE TO
SPECIFICALLY CONSIDER- WITHIN-
THERE SCOPING PLAN- AB BUT THIS
BILL IS INTENDED. BOTH WITHIN
THE AIRPORT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WRIT LARGE THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION AND
OTHER STATE ENERGY AGENCIES TO
ACCELERATE AND- IMPROVE THEIR
THEIR THINKING AND THE KIND OF
PROCESS THAT THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH AS WE APPROACH SB ONE
HUNDRED GROUP GOALS IT'S
NECESSARY FOR. PC AND OTHER
AGENCIES TO LOOK AT FOR
INSTANCE THE OUTAGES WE'VE HAD
IN THE PAST FEW YEARS- BOTH
FROM WILDFIRES AND FROM SOME OF
THE ROLLING BLACKOUTS WE SAW
LAST SEASON WAS LOOKING OVER TO
TEXAS I'M TRYING TO FIND A
DIFFERENT WAY. TO BUILD
RESILIENCY IN OUR GRADE AND
CLEAN MANNER GOING FORWARD IN
THE FUTURE I THINK THE
CALIFORNIA CAN BOTH ACCELERATE
IT'S PAST TO SB ONE HUNDRED
WHILE WE MAKE OUR GREED MORE
RESILIENT IF WE ARE ABLE TO
CONSIDER AND EVALUATE MORE
COMPREHENSIVELY A LOT OF THE
ZERO CARBON. A BASELOAD
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE OUT THERE
NOW- BOTH A COMMERCIAL AND
DEMONSTRATION SCALE SO THIS WAS
ALL- IDENTIFIED IN THE SB ONE
HUNDRED REPORT RECENTLY PUT OUT
THEIR OWN FIRM ZERO CARBON
RESOURCES LIKE GEO THERMAL
OFFSHORE WIND GREEN ALECTRA
LYTIC HYDROGEN WHICH WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER IN THE
HEARING TODAY LONG DURATION
ENERGY STORAGE MULTI DAY ENERGY
STORAGE AND OTHER RESOURCES. SO
WE THINK HAVING THESE KIND OF
FIRM FLEXIBLE BASE LOAD POWER-
RESOURCES THAT ARE AT OUR
DISPOSAL IN THE STATE WILL
ALLOW US. TO BUILD OUR GREED IN
A DIFFERENT WAY WE STAYED
INTACT- NOT I'LL OUR- AND NOT.
I KNOW CLOSING ARE OFF TO IT TO
NEW RESOURCES AND DOUBLING DOWN
ON- ON THE FOSSIL FUEL
RESOURCES IN THE PAST THAT
FRANKLY ARE MUCH MORE
VULNERABLE TO EXTREME HEAT AND
EXTREME COLD EVENTS. SO WE CAN
GET INTO MORE DETAILS ANOTHER
WORD THE TAIL END OF THE
HEARING. TODAY I'M SO HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS BUT I
BELIEVE- I BELIEVE WE HAVE A-
THE BILL'S SPONSOR- CLEAN POWER
CAMPAIGN WITH THE JOHN WHITE AS
WELL AS DAN JACOBSON WAS
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WOULD GO TO YOUR YOUR PRESENTED
IN SUPPORT. YES THEY ARE LIGHT
WITH THE CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN
YES PLEASE. OKAY IS EXPRESSED
PERSONAL SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
ALSO WE WANNA- FIRST OF ALL
THANK THE STAFF FOR RUNNING A
REALLY GOOD COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
THAT I THINK PUTS THE CONTEXT
OF THIS BILL IN IN THE RIGHT
PLACE ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
WE NEED THIS BILL IS BECAUSE
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
HAD TO NARAL A SET OF RESOURCES
THAT THEY LOOKED AT. IN THEIR
MODELING THEY JUST DIDN'T
CONSIDER ART Q. THERMAL OR OF A
LONG DURATION STORAGE EVEN
THOUGH THESE RESOURCES ARE HAVE
LATER BEEN CALLED OUT AND SEEN
AS NEEDING TO BE ADDED SO WE'RE
WE'RE BASICALLY DOING IS IT IN
THE BILL IS EXPANDING THE RANGE
OF TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE ARE
EXAMINING OUR PLANNING PROCESS
TO INCLUDE RESOURCES THAT WE
THINK ARGUABLY GOING TO BE
NEEDED TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
ACHIEVING OUR GOALS OF BOTH
AFFORDABILITY AND ECONOMICALLY.
WE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND- IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU HEY WE HAVE A MUTUAL FRIEND
AND CONGRESSMAN LEVIN. DATE IN
THIS MATTER HIM AWHILE BACK SO
IT'S GOOD TO BE ABOUT BUILDING
YES GOOD GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE.
OKAY LET'S HEAR FROM YOUR OTHER
WITNESS THAT SENATOR THIS IS
DAN JACOBSON FROM AN ARMY
CALIFORNIA ON THE LINE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN GOOD
AFTERNOON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- ARE 1100% CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS DESIGNED TO
FACILITATE THE ADOPTION OF A
DIVERSE SET OF CLEAN ENERGY
TECHNOLOGIES. YEAH THE CURRENT
MODELING CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION HAS BEEN
CONSTRAINED WITH LIMITED THE
EVALUATION OF KEY TECHNOLOGIES
SUCH AS CENTER DESCRIBED THE
BOX FOR WIND GEOTHERMAL AND
MULTI DAY STORAGE. SB FOUR
TWENTY THREE RESPONSES CHECK TO
THIS CHALLENGE BY ENSURING THAT
SUCH TECHNOLOGIES OR
APPROPRIATELY ABOUT VALUATION
MODELS AND THAT THE VALUE OF
THESE TECHNOLOGIES TWIRLA
TRICITY SYSTEM. ARE CONSIDERED.
THE REASON CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION SAYS TO ONE HUNDRED
REPORT NOTED THAT ADDITIONAL
ANALYSIS IS NEEDED TO EVALUATE
WHETHER THE PROJECT PORTFOLIOS
WILL MEET SYSTEM RELIABILITY
REQUIREMENTS WHILE CONTINUING
TO ASSESS RESOURCES ON
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABILITY. PETER
ANALYSIS BE UPDATED TO REFLECT
THE MARKET TRENDS INCLUDING
CHANGES IN PRICE AND THE
COMMERCIALIZATION OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AN UPDATE TO TOTAL
RESOURCES. WE'VE ALREADY TALKED
ABOUT IT HAS BEEN ALL ALONG
HEARING I'LL KEEP MY COMMON
SHORT AND JUST SAY THIS BILL IS
GOING TO BE REALLY CRITICAL AS
WE WORK TO STAVE OFF THE WORST
IMPACTS CLIMATE CHANGE AND MOVE
CALIFORNIA 2100% CLEAN ENERGY.
THEN DO IT SMARTLY AND AN
AFFORDABLY BERMAN CALIFORNIA IT
SUPPORTS FOUR TWENTY THREE AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS AND I GO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
OKAY I DON'T SEE ONE IN PERSON
HERE AT TO ADD ON- OR IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IF THERE'S ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINES. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT FOR
US BEFORE TWENTY THREE.
MODERATOR THANK YOU TO SELL
YOUR OF SUPPORT FOR SB FOUR
TWENTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE WILL
ONE ONE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANKS REPRESENTING PLUG IN
AMERICA IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
THANK SENATOR PER TERM FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THAT THANK YOU.
BY MORAL SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M EMBEDDED WITH THE WIDENING
GROUP ON BEHALF OF FORM ENERGY
IN SUPPORT. NINE FIFTY NINE YOU
ARE UP. FIFTY NINE PLEASE ON
YOU. ONE FIFTY NINE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT. WELL
WE'LL MOVE ON TO ONE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. JANICK
PROCTOR THREE FIFTY SILICON
VALLEY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN. WHY ONE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS
IS DAVID WEISSMAN OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR NUCLEAR
RESPONSIBILITY ALSO STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
FIND ONE TWENTY SIX. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YEAH KATHY SHAFFER SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP. OKAY
THANK YOU ALRIGHT LET'S NOW- I
KNOW WE THERE'S BEEN A CHANGE
IN THE LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS-
WE HAVE TAKEN MACKLERWHO'S
HERE TO RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC POWER AUTHORITY. LET'S
LET'S GO TO YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS PAGE NOT
CLEAR WITH THEM SAID BY THEIR
ABOUT THE HAPPENED SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE. AND APOLOGY MISTER CHAIR
BECAUSE OF THE TIGHT TIMELINE
BETWEEN ENERGY COMMITTEE AND
EACH YEAR WE COULD NOT GET OUR
UPDATED LETTER SUBMITTED IN
TIME. WELL KEEP MY COMMENTS
BRIEF. ARE WE APPRECIATE YOUR
MOMENT THE AUTHOR ACCEPTED IN
THE PREVIOUS COMMITTEE. HOWEVER
AS WE STATED IN ENERGY
COMMITTEES THE PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES CONTINUE TO REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT THE IDEA THAT
THE CDC WOULD PLAY A ROLE IN
PROCUREMENT. I WOULD RATHER DO
NOT UNDERSTAND WHY THE FEES YOU
WOULD HAVE A ROLE IN
DETERMINING RELIABILITY GIVEN
WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR.
ALL THAT SAID WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING PROACTIVE
CONVERSATIONS AUTHORED. BACK
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. OKAY
THANK. OUR ANYONE ELSE WANT TO
TESTIFY IN A BECAUSE OUR VOICE
OUR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I
DON'T SEE ON HERE PERSON OR IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY- LET'S GO TO
THE PHONE LINES UP A MODERATOR
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO VOICE OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS BILL. AS BEFORE
TWENTY THREE. TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AND
WILL BEGIN TO FIND FIFTY NINE.
FIFTY NINE YOUR OPEN PLEASE ON
MUTE. NINE FIFTY NINE. HELLO
YOUR ALL YOUR LINES OPEN. HELLO
I'M SORRY IT WAS NEVER GIVEN A
WIDE AND IS THIS LINE FIFTY
NINE YES YES. HI I'M SORRY I
GOT TO BE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL EARLIER AND I DIDN'T
REALIZE THAT LINE TO DENY WITH
MINE AND MY ABLE TO STILL
TESTIFYING SUPPORT YES PLEASE
JUST GO AHEAD AND QUICKLY- NOT
YOUR SUPPORT AFFILIATION NAME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MANY MEMBERS OF THE
TIME AND NOW BEEN POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN BUSINESS COUNCIL WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
TWENTY THREE AND WE'RE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THEIR B. OVERSIGHT
COORDINATION- TO THE SCOPING
PLANTLETS PROSPECT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M SORRY
THAT MY LINE THE- OPEN EARLIER.
NO TROUBLE. THANK YOU WITH NOTE.
PINE AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO
LINE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU TO ALAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
APOLOGIES THANK YOU TO CHRI THE
AUTHORITIES THE ALTERNATE
REPORT INVEST BEFORE TWENTY
THREE HAVE ISSUED EARLIER THANK
YOU. ONE ONE TWENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AS CHAIR MEMBERS GREG
COOK REPRESENTED THE CALIFORNIA
POWER AGENCY INSTITUTE IN THE
OPPOSITION AND I WOULD LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
POWER AUTHORITY THANK YOU. JUST
REMINDER TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR
SB FOUR TWENTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE ONE TWENTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BASS- ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. LINE ONE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PATRICK WELCH
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION ALAINA COMMENTS WITH
MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH MOTOR
APPRECIATE THAT OKAY LET'S NOW
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
DISCUSSION. BOTS ISSUES. PART
OF THE BILL OKAY THIS REMOVED
BY CENTER SKINNER. A OKAY
SINISTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANKS FOR THE
ENGAGEMENT AND WE ASK FOR A
VOTE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FIVE
THIRTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL I
DO NOT- BY THE WAY O. OKAY I'M
SO SORRY I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
YOU HAVE ACCEPTED THE AMENDS.
YES OKAY AND SO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED- TO THE- BUT
AS THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMUNITY OPERATIONS APPRECIATE
THAT WOULD OCCUR PETITION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. S. ITEM
NUMBER NINE AS BEFORE TWENTY
THREE BY SENATOR STERN. ALLEN
FIVE I BATES WELL BATES NOW
DALLY ALLEY NO GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ TIME SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE STERN TONIGHT- AND
I Y. CASKEY HI ASKI I'D- OKAY.
WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT
ITEM LET'S NOT LIFT THE CALLS
ON THE OTHER ITEMS SO AS TO
ALLOW OUR MEMBERS TO ADD ON. IF
YOU HAVE ALREADY VOTED YOU ARE
FREE TO GO. PFIZER LET'S LET'S
LET'S START GOING BACK THROUGH
FILE OR SO MEMBERS CANNOT
CENSUS AREA THIS IS A ITEM
NUMBER YEAH SO IT'S WILL GO
THROUGH THE WHOLE. THE WHOLE-
CALENDAR GAINED JUST TO MAKE
SURE EVERYBODY IS SET SO SIR
ITEM ONE IS THAT'S P. THIRTY
SEVEN CORTESE. I REMEMBER ONE
SB THIRTY SEVEN BY IT SENATOR
CORTESE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
ALLEN HI. HI SKINNER. FIVE
SKINNER I SEVEN. THE SIX SEVEN
SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT LET'S NOT GO OUT INTO SB
FOUR SEVENTY FIVE ALSO BY
CENTER CORTESE. AND IN NUMBER
TWO SB FOUR SEVENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR CORTESE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED BUT FIRST BE RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION. ALLEN FOR ALL
YOUR HELP HI ALLEN I. SKINNER
SKINNER I'D SIX YOU'LL COME TO
A CLOSE RIGHT. YEAH YEAH YES
I'D LIKE TO HAVE A KEY ROLE
OKAY. THANKS FOR OKAY THAT'S
PART WE'RE CLOSER ON THAT THAT
SIX ZERO- WITH THIS IS ONE OF
STANDS IN HIS POST. LET'S GO
WILL CALL THE ROLL ON THAT
LET'S NOT GO TO ITEM THREE THIS
IS SB FIFTY NINE CAREER AS
CANNABIS PROVISIONAL LICENSES
BILL. AS EXHIBITS KALRA. I AND
NUMBER THREE SB FIFTY NINE BY
SENATOR KABIR OF THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. DOLLY. OKAY AT
SIX ZERO SIX ZERO WILL CALL THE
ROLL ON THAT ITEM LET'S GO TO
ITEM SIX THIS IS- DIED JUST
BEFORE FIFTY ONE- ON BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING WE HAVE A
SEVEN TO ZERO THAT ONE'S DONE
OKAY WE HAVE SEVEN ZERO SO
WE'RE DONE WITH THAT ONE THAT'S
CLOSED HOW ABOUT I AM SEVEN S.
B. SEVEN OH SORRY- WE'VE
OBVIOUSLY HELD OVER ARGILLITE
IS SB SIX SIXTY TWO TO THURSDAY
FOR SOME ADDITIONAL WORK. THAT
BRINGS US TO ITEM EIGHT SB SIX
SEVENTY ONE GONZALEZ IS BILL-
SENATOR GONZALEZ IS BILL SB SIX
SEVENTY ONE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
STERN. STERN AYE EARN FIVE
SEVEN ZERO FIVE SEVEN ZERO
CLOSER ON THAT ITEM- I THINK
WE'RE ALL SET WITH ITEM NINE
RIGHT TO STERN BILL SO LET'S GO
TO THE CONSECUTIVE. OPEN THE
ROLE. EVERYBODY HERE IS ON
SEVEN ZERO OKAY FANTASTIC OKAY
SO LET'S NOW FINALLY- AS SB.
FIFTY FOUR. THE CHAIRS BUILDED
CENTER STERN GETS ADMITTED TO
THAT YES YES OKAY SO WE'RE ALL
SET WITH THAT OKAY SO IT SEEMS
LIKE WE'VE GOT EVERYBODY'S
VOTES RECORDED. THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR A LONG BUT
ULTIMATELY VERY AND INTERESTING
AND FRUITFUL HEARINGS. HAS JUST
TO REMIND EVERYBODY WE ARE
GOING TO BE. BRINGING THE BAND
BACK TOGETHER ON THURSDAY THAT
WILL BE OUR LAST HEARING FOR
HOUSE OF ORIGIN BILLS IN THIS
COMMITTEE. IT'S GOING TO BE IN
THE SENATE CHAMBER ACTUALLY.
AFTER THEY- THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT AFTER THEY
CLEAR OUT- A CLEAN THE CHAMBER.
IS THAT NOT CORRECT. SO THAT'LL
BE AFTER SESSION THURSDAY
MORNING IN THE SENATE CHAMBER.
HI IF ANY CHANGES HAPPEN WITH
THE LOCATION LET YOU KNOW.
RIGHT WITH THAT THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.